WE HAVE A A LONG AND EXTENSIVE
AGENDA TODAY.
SO I WANTED TO INVITE AUTHORS
WHO HOPE TO HAVE THEIR BILLS HER
TODAY TO PLEASE -- COME ON DOWN --
I'VE I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW WHOSE HAS
THE FIRST COUPLE BILLS UP IS NOT
GOING TO ARRIVE.
HERE -- UNTIL MUCH LATER IN THE
A HIGH IN THE MORNING -- SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
TO OUR QUE HAN MCCARTY MEDINA
WALKER RUBIO THIS.
BE AWARE TO BE GREAT A FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD WOULD BE
NEXT UP TO COME ON BY SO WE CAN
GET OUR HEARING GOING.
OUT WE CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM.
SO WE WILL BEGIN AS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
I AM ALSOTOLD THAT OUR VICE
CHAIR IT WILL NOT BE HERE AND
ATTENDANCE TODAY.
SO -- BE AWARE.
OF THAT -- NAME WITH THAT WILL
TAKE A PAUSE AND HOPE THAT AS AN
ASSEMBLY AUTHOR WILL -- WILL BE
HERE IN JUST A MOMENT
.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING -- TO CALL
THE COMMITTEE BACK -- TO TO
ORDER -- I SEE WE DO HAVE AN
AUTHOR -- HERE AND BEFORE I
INTRODUCE HER I WANT TO SAY A
COUPLE THINGS -- THE ASSEMBLY
HAS A SENT OVER A PACKAGE OF
FIVE SIX OR MORE BILLS DEALING
WITH PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION.
AND WE HAD A CHANCE OVER THE
LAST FEW WEEKS -- TO TO LOOK AT
THEM AND TALK WITH THEM.
ABOUT THEM AND I I JUST WANT.
TO EXTEND MY APPRECIATION -- TO
ALL OF THEM FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
AND TRYING TO TAKE ON  VERY
IMPORTANT -- ISSUE -- THAT IS
AFFECTED -- A LOT OF STUDENTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA -- AND SO I
AM A VERY APPRECIATIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO AT HIS LABOR.
MARKET OUTCOME -- MEASURE THAT
HE'S ADVANCING I'M APPRECIATIVE
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN FOR
THE WORK HE'S DONE ON NONPROFIT --
DEFINITIONS IN INSTITUTIONS I'M
APPRECIATIVE OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
OUR K. HANDS WORK ON OUT OF
STATE -- INSTITUTIONS AND THEIR
ONLINE INSTRUCTION THAT THEY DO
PROVIDE.
I AM ALSO THANKFUL FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY'S WORK ON
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES.
AND HOW THEY HAVE BEEN USED --
IN THE PAST -- TO CREATE -- A
ARE A LESS THAN FAVORABLE
CIRCUMSTANCE.
AM ALSO APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA AS WORK ON TUITION
RECOVERY -- WE HAVE SCHEDULED A
SUNSET REVIEW. FOR THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION.
AFTER THE COMING YEAR.
AND AT THAT THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE GONNA HERE TODAY -- WE'LL
BE JOINED BY MANY OTHER ISSUES
THAT ARE OUT THERE IN REGARD TO
HOW THE BUREAU IS DOING THEIR
WORK.
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
THAT WE NEED TO UNDERTAKE -- TO
ENSURE THAT THAT THEY'RE DOING
THEIR WORK WELL AND PROTECTING
OUR STUDENTS -- BUT WITH THAT WE
HAVE A A GOOD COLLECTION OF
BILLS THAT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
ON THE SUBJECT AND I SEE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER QUE HAN IS
HERE.
AND I'D LIKE TO INVITE HER UP BY.
TO PRESENT HER BILL WHICH IS
ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL -- THIRTEEN
FORTY FOUR WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM CURRENTLY BUT WILL.
BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND WE
WELCOME YOU TO OUR COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M ALSO
PRESENTING ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN SPELLING BEE THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE DO YOU MIND IF I
PRESENT THAT FIRST LIKE TO
PRESENT THAT WOULD FIRST YES BUT
YOU GET OFF TO A GOOD START BY
PRESENTING YOUR BILL HOW WELL
THEY WITNESS ASKED ME TO TAKE.
THEIRS FIRST TO BE ONLINE IT'S
OKAY IT'S ALL.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT I'M BETTER
PREPARED OF MY OKAY SO WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN ON ITEM NUMBER.
SIX ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
HIS ****.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER K. HAND
TWO PRESENTS AND WE WELCOME YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ON THIS
BILL -- ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER THE CONVERSATIONS ON
THIS BILL AND HELPING IT TO GET
TO THE PLACES THAT -- WITH THE
RECENT OFFERS AMENDMENTS AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE IS A NARROWER
AND MORE SIMPLIFIED BILL THAT
WOULD PREVENT COVERT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES FROM INVADING STATE
OVERSIGHT.
SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD REQUIRE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
DETERMINE WHETHER AN INSTITUTION
THAT CLAIMS TO BE A NONPROFIT
COLLEGE IS ACTUALLY OPERATING AS
A NON PROFIT FOR PURPOSES OF
RECEIVING AN EXEMPTION FROM
STATE OVERSIGHT.
THE BILL WOULD ONLY FOCUS ON
NONPROFIT COLLEGES THAT
PREVIOUSLY OPERATED AS FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES ON OR AFTER
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TEN SOME FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES ARE STARTING TO USE AND
NONPROFIT LABEL MISLEADING
STUDENTS WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
DODGING APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT.
THESE COVERT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
ARE TRYING TO GAME THE SYSTEM.
A DECLINE IN ENFORCEMENT OF
NONPROFIT STATUS BY THE FEDERAL
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE IS
ALLOWING SOME FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES TO GET AWAY WITH USING
COMPLICATED FINANCIAL SCHEMES
AND SHELL CORPORATIONS TO LAY
CLAIM TO THIS NONPROFIT STATUS.
THIS EMERGING PROBLEM IS ALREADY
AFFECTING CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
FOR EXAMPLE GRAND CANYON
EDUCATION INC IS A FOR PROFIT
COMPANY TRADED ON THE NASDAQ
THEY CREATED GRAND CANYON
UNIVERSITY AND CLAIM IT AS A
NONPROFIT COLLEGE.
HOWEVER THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NONPROFIT GRAND CANYON
UNIVERSITY IS ALSO THE CEO OF
THE FOR PROFIT GRAND CANYON
EDUCATION INC IN ABOUT 60% THE
TUITION REVENUE.
THAT THE NONPROFIT COLLEGE
RECEIVES FLOWS THROUGH TO THE
FOR PROFIT COMPANY.
AND GEORGETOWN LAW PROFESSOR
NONPROFIT LAW EXPERT BRIAN GOLLY
SAID THE NONPROFIT IS
ESSENTIALLY A TRUSTWORTHY
LOOKING WRAPPER AROUND A FOR
PROFIT BUSINESS.
THIS ARRANGEMENT MAKES A MOCKERY
OF THE CONCEPT OF THE NONPROFIT.
WITHOUT ANY OBJECTIVE CHECK ON
THEIR NONPROFIT CLAIM THESE
COVERT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES WILL
CONTINUE TO MISLEAD STUDENTS AND
AVOID APPROPRIATE STATE
OVERSIGHT.
IN FACT OTHER COLLEGES ARE
ALREADY FOLLOWING GRAND CANYON
UNIVERSITY EXAMPLES AND CLAIMING
NONPROFIT STATUS.
THERE FOR CALIFORNIA MUST STEP
UP AND STEP IN TO PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS AND ENSURE THAT THE
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT REMAINS
FOR THESE COVERT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES TRYING TO GAIN THE
SYSTEM.
TODAY WE HAVE BOB CHARMIN SENIOR
FELLOW AND DIRECTOR OF HIGHER
EDUCATION AND EXCELLENCE AT THE
CENTURY FOUNDATION AND ANGELA
PERRY POLICY ANALYST AT THE
INSTITTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS.
NOBODY IS THANK YOU THANK YOU
RATE AND THE BEFORE WE HEAR FROM
YOUR WITNESSES.
I DO SEE THAT WE HAVE A A QUORUM
PRESENT.
SO I'D LIKE TO ASK HER TO CALL
THE IF THE ROLE.
GLAZER HERE GLAZER HERE CHIANG
ARCHULETA YOUR ARCH LETTER HERE
DOT.
DOT HERE GALGIANI HILL YOU'RE
STILL HERE LEYVA.
THEY'VE BEEN HERE PAN WELL.
OKAY SO WE DO HAVE A CORPSMAN
BEFORE YOUR WITNESSES BECAUSE I
DO WANT TO REMIND.
THEM AND AND OTHERS THAT -- THE
COMMITTEE PRACTICES BEEN TO
ALLOW FOR TWO WITNESSES -- ON
BOTH SIDES TRYING TO CONFINE
THEIR REMARKS FOUR MINUTES
CUMULATIVELY.
AND WITH THAT WE WELCOME YOUR
REMARKS YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND TELL ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO ONE COULD BE
REASONABLY CONFIDENT THAT AN
ENTITY WITH A TAX EXEMPT
DESIGNATION FROM THE IRS WAS.
LEGITIMATELY STRUCTURED AS A NON
PROFIT MEANING ONE THAT IT'S
INCOME WAS DEDICATED TO
EDUCATIONAL AND CHARITABLE
PURPOSES AND NOT EXTRACTED FOR
PROFIT.
AND SECOND THAT ITS GOVERNANCE
OR HOW IT IS CONTROLLED WAS
WITHOUT ANY SIGNIFICANT
CONFLICTS THE TRUSTEES.
WERE ABLE TO MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON WHAT IS BEST FOR
STUDENTS AND THE COMMUNITY NOT
WHAT LINE THEIR OWN POCKETS OF
THE POCKETS WITH SOME CONTRACTOR
THAT HAS A STRANGLEHOLD ON THEIR
FINANCES.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR ABILITY TO
RELY ON THE IRS DESIGNATION IS
GONE DUE TO AN UNRELATED
CONTROVERSY OVER POLITICAL NON
PROFITS AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL.
FOR PROFIT OPERATORS HAVE BEGUN
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
SITUATION SETTING UP SHALL
NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS GETTING
AN IRS EXEMPTION AND USING THAT
IN THEIR MARKETING.
IN A RECENT CALL WITH INVESTORS
THE CEO OF THE NASDAQ TRADED
NONPROFIT UNIVERSITY GRAND
CANYON.
BOASTED QUOTE BEING OUT THERE A
MILLION TIMES A DAY SAYING WE'RE
NONPROFIT HAS HAS HAD AN IMPACT.
HE WAS REPORTING A PROFIT MARGIN
OF 34%.
NOW OTHER FOR PROFITS WENT TO
FOLLOW THIS MODEL WHICH THEY ARE
DECLARING AS THE INDUSTRY
STANDARD A NONPROFIT UNIVERSITY
THAT STEERS 6265% OF ITS REVENUE
TO ONE SOLE SOURCE COMPANY WITH
A LONG TERM CONTRACT THAT IS
VERY TOLD DIFFICULT. FOR THE
NONPROFIT TO GET OUT OF AB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE SAYS THESE
TYPES OF SO CALLED NON PROFITS
THOSE THAT HAVE CONVERTED DO NOT
HAVE THIS DO NOT HAVE THE
STRUCTURE THAT PROTECTS
CONSUMERS.
AND THEREFORE SHOULD NOT GET THE
EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S REGULATORY APPROACH.
AS IN MANY OTHER STATES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS CALIFORNIA'S
PRIMARY AUTHORITY ON THE
LEGITIMACY OF NOT OF A NONPROFIT
ENTITY.
THIS BILL PROMS AND AG REVIEW OF
FORMER FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS
SEEKING CALIFORNIA EXCEPTIONS AS
NONPROFIT.
IT ALSO CLARIFIES WHAT ARE
CONSIDERED PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
BEYOND OUR THREE PUBLIC SEGMENTS.
THANK YOU AND I ARE CHEN I'VE OF
THANK YOU NEXT NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ANGELA
PERRY I'M A POLICY ANALYST WITH
THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS I'M HERE TO OFFER
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE WHICH WOULD
PREVENT INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION FROM EVADING STATE
OVERSIGHT.
BY MISREPRESENTING THEMSELVES TO
STUDENTS AND TAXPAYERS.
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS ARE
REQUIRED TO DEVOTE SCHOOLS
REVENUES TO EDUCATIONAL PURPOSE
AND LEADERS ARE PROHIBITED FROM
TAKING A PROFIT -- RAMPANT
DECEPTIVE AND UNFAIR TREATMENT
OF STUDENTS HAS BEEN RARE
ILLEGITIMATE NONPROFIT COLLEGES
BECAUSE OF FINANCIAL
RESTRICTIONS PLACED ON THE
SCHOOLS DESIGNED TO MAKE IT
DIFFICULT. FOR THEM TO BE BAD
ACTORS IN THE SPACE WE AE NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS WHICH LEGITIMATELY
SEEK TO CONVERT TO BECOME
NONPROFIT HOWEVER.
AS AN ENFORCEMENT OF NONPROFIT
STATUS HAS BEEN HAS DECLINED AT
THE FEDERAL IRS SOME OF THE FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS HAVE STARTED
TO USE AN ILLEGITIMATE NONPROFIT
OR PUBLIC LABEL TO TRACK
STUDENTS WHO ARE SUSPICIOUS OF
FOR PROFIT.
COLLEGES AND TO ESCAPE
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT.
THIS PROBLEM IS ALREADY
AFFECTING CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
AN INSUFFICIENT OVERSIGHT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL HAS MADE STATE
ACTION ESSENTIAL.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S FAILURE
TO EXERCISE APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT PUTS CALIFORNIANS AT
RISK AB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE WOULD
PREVENT THOSE FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS FROM INVADING STATE
OVERSIGHT AND DECEIVING STUDENTS.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY OTHER OTHERS HERE
WHO.
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THAT
WISH TO IDENTIFY THEMSELVES BY
NAME AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE
COME ON UP.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS NATALIE LINES I'M WITH
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN OAKLAND WE
REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF STUDENT
LOAN BORROWERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
HE'S IN MAR DEL CONSUMER REPORTS
FORMALLY CONSUMERS UNION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD MORNING DANIELLE KENDALL
KAISER ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING NATALIE HANDLED ON
REPRESENTING NEXT AND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME UP.
OKAY CREATE ONE MORE SPACE AT
THE TABLE JUST CHOOSE
[inaudible]
DESK MONACO.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GEORGE
MILLER ON BEHALF OF ASHFORD
UNIVERSITY -- THE SCHOOL THAT IS
CURRENTLY IN THE MIDST OF DOING
JUST THAT A CONVERSION FROM A
FOR PROFIT ENTITY TO A NOT FOR
PROFIT ENTITY -- IN THE IN THE
HOPES OF GETTING AWAY FROM A
MORE SHAREHOLDER CENTRIC WAY OF
GOING ABOUT OPERATING A SCHOOL
AND COMING MORE STUDENT CENTRIC
A SORT OF THAT IS THE REASON AND
RATIONALE.
FOR I BELIEVE THE ASHFORD IS
GOING THROUGH I THINK IT IS VERY
LEGITIMATE MNEMONICS DANCE OF
CALLS WITH THEM.
AND IN THE MIDST OF SERIOUS
DISCUSSIONS FIGHTS BETWEEN THE
TWO ENTITIES IN TERMS OF
STRUCTURING THIS -- IF THERE WAS
AN ARMS LENGTH DEAL AND NOT A
SHAM CONVERSION I THINK THIS IS
CERTAINLY IT -- WE'RE CURRENTLY
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED WE THINK
THAT -- THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
MORE NEUTRAL ARBITER AT LESS
POLITICIZED PROCESS THAN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S.
OFFICE IS IS A BETTER -- PLACE
FOR THE STRUCTURE FOR THIS TO BE.
REVIEWED AND WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE -- OUTSIDE COUNSEL --
MISTER TONY GUIDA TO TO TOUCH ON
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS -- I REPRESENT -- AFTER
UNIVERSITY OF THEIR OUTSIDE
COUNSEL I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY --
THAT PRACTICES EXCLUSIVELY IN
HIGHER EDUCATION -- EIGHTY ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT IT'S IT'S
IMPORTANT STRESSES AFTER
UNIVERSITY DOES NOT OPPOSE
ADDITIONAL SCRUTINY -- FOR
TRANSACTIONS LIKE THIS -- THEY
ALREADY NEED TO HAVE AS AS
MISTER CHAIRMAN MENTIONED
APPROVAL BY THE IRS -- APPROVAL
BY THEIR REGIONAL CREDITOR --
THE WASHER -- SO THE ISSUE IS IS
JUST WITH -- THE THE MANNER IN
WHICH IT'S DONE IN MAKING SURE
THAT IT'S DONE IN A WAY THAT
SAID THAT THE MOST EXPEDITIOUS --
WITH RESPECT -- TO NONPROFIT THE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
CURRENTLY -- APPROVES --
TRANSACTIONS WHERE -- NONPROFITS
ARE ARE EXITING FROM BEING A NON
PROFIT -- IN -- WHETHER IT'S BY
SALES POTENTIALLY ALL THE ASSETS
ARE WITH RESPECT -- TO THE THE
THE HEALTH AND HOSPITALS
HOSPITALS NONPROFIT HOSPITALS
SELLING TO A FOR PROFIT HERE --
A WIN -- INSTITUTION IS IS
TRYING TO BECOME A NONPROFIT --
IN CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD -- REVIEWS THE TRANSACTION
AND WE WOULD WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT THAT THEY
WOULD BE A BETTER -- PLACE --
FOR THE REVIEW TO OCCUR --
THERE'S THERE'S CURRENTLY A FORM
OF THE TO USE THAT IS
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE PAGES
THERE ARE THERE'S THERE'S A
SPECIAL SECTION IN THE FORM IN
THE REVIEW OFFER HOSPITALS WE
WOULD ASK THAT -- EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS ALSO -- CONVERTING --
COULD COULD BE ADDRESSED IN A
SIMILAR WAY -- IN ANOTHER -- A
PROPOSED AMENDMENT AND THAT THAT
WE WOULD SUGGEST IS THAT -- WE
WOULD HAVE OUR A RESTRICTIONS
WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY T GO
DIRECTLY TO COURT -- WHICH CAN
OCCUR WITH RESPECT TO A SALE OF
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL THE ASSETS TO
AVOID -- A POTENTIAL ISSUES AND
AND AND YOU KNOW POLITICALLY
SHOULD TO SUCH A WE HAVE A QUIRK
MAKE BASICALLY MAKE THE DECISION --
AND I GUESS THE THE FINAL POINT
IS THERE IS THERE IS LANGUAGE I
HERE WHERE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS TO REVIEW AND DETERMINE
WHETHER QUIRK FUNCTIONS --
REMAIN WITH THE INSTITUTION --
CORE EDUCATIONAL FUNCTIONS IS IS
IS IS A TERM OF ART AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WALK FOR INSTANCE
I HAVE SPECIFIC POLICIES FOR A
AND A AND THEN IF I SEVEN QUIRK
FUNCTIONS -- THAT CANNOT BE.
GIVEN BY AN INSTITUTION IS
SOMEBODY ELSE SO WE WE JUST ASK
THAT FOR INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
ACCREDITED BY WHY ASK THAT THAT
DETERMINATION BE MADE BY WHAT --
AND NOT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL --
GET ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION COME UP
AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS
ANGIE MINETTI HERE ON BEHALF OF
SYLVIA ALSO ECHOING THE COMMENTS
OF THE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEN -- NO FURTHER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
DODD.
YEAH I WOULD JUST LIKE YOU --
SOMEBODY TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
OF THE OPPOSITION HERE -- THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE IF YOU
LOOK AT ALL OF THE VARIOUS
AUTHORITIES OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND AND THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
THEY TO ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE IS THE DOMINANT AGENCY.
THAT MAKES JUDGMENTS ABOUT THE
TREATMENT OF NONPROFIT ASSETS
WHETHER WHEN INDIA AND ISSUES OF
PRIVATE INURNMENT WHETHER
SOMEBODY IS PROFITING OFF OF A
NONPROFIT.
ORGANIZATION -- IT IS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THE IRS BECAME THE
ARBITER ON THESE ISSUES
BASICALLY.
THROUGH A FLUKE OF THE FACT THAT
IT WAS A TAX THAT IT WAS THAT
YOU GOT A TAX EXEMPTION MADE IT
A TAX ISSUE THIS IS REALLY MORE
A CONTROL AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION ISSUE.
THAN A PAYMENT SENATE ISSUE OF
THE PAYMENT OF TAXES.
I WROTE SO I GUESS MR -- SO I
GUESS THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING YOU
IS IS WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THE PROPOSAL THAT -- THAT THEY
HAVE. FOR YOUR GIVE A TO THE
BOARD WAS DEPORTED WITH THAT SIR
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TRYING TO
TAX BOARD.
I MEAN REALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO FIND OUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY IF THIS IS A SHAM ARE NOT AS
SHE AND YOU THINK THAT'S THAT'S
NOT.
GOOD ENOUGH.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE IS
WHERE THEY HAVE TRADITIONALLY
LOOK AT ISSUES OF CAN GENERAL
AND HOLDING WAS SOMEONE
PROTECTION. TO THE WEST OF THE
POT I HAVE NOT THE ONLY THE ONLY
SITUATION I HAVE FOUND WHERE THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD -- EXAMINED
THIS KIND OF AN ISSUE WAS
RELATED TO BLUE CROSS AT SOME
POINT IN THE PAST I AM NOT I
HAVE NOT GONE BACK AND LOOKED AT
YOU KNOW OTHER.
OF THE OTHER POSSIBILITY IS THE
ONLY ONE THAT I'VE SEEN IN
HISTORY.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING FOR THE
AUTHOR IS THAT AND THE NONPROFIT
THE ROLE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND MANAGING NONPROFITS AS WHY
HE CHOSE THEM AS THE APPROPRIATE
LOCATION IN CALIFORNIA TO BE
HANDLING THIS AND I KNOW HE'S IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS.
IS WORKABLE FOR THEM AS WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YEAH THE THE CALIFORNIA HAS A
DIFFERENT ONE AS SOMETHING OF
THAT.
I RECOGNIZE YOU AS OUR
CALIFORNIA HAS A PROVISION IN
THE SENATE BECAUSE IT MIRRORS --
TO FIVE A ONE TWO THREE A
SECTION OF THE INTERNAL REVENUE
CODE IN ITS.
IT'S IT'S IN THE TAXATION CODE
SECTION TWO THREE SEVEN OH ONE
D..
AND IT READS A CORPORATION
ORGANIZED AND OPERATED
EXCLUSIVELY FOR EDUCATIONAL
PURPOSES NO PART OF EARNINGS TO
WHICH A NURSE TO THE BENEFIT OF
ANY PRIVATE SHAREHOLDER
INDIVIDUAL AND WE WOULD WE WOULD
SUBMIT THAT'S THE SAME --
REQUIREMENTS THAT IS BEING
IMPOSED IN IN THIS BILL -- FOR
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL LOOK AT IN
IN.
THE FOR TO CHECK FOR HAS A LOT
MORE EXPERIENCE IN IN REVIEWING
IF THAT'S WHAT THEY DO INTEREST
MY UNDERSTANDING IT'S A IT'S A
VERY HIGHLY REGARDED -- AGENCY
WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
CENTER DOT I GUESS I'VE GOT TO
ASK YOU THE SAME QUESTION.
IT SOUNDS LIKE EITHEROR YUP
WOULD BE SATISFACTORY WHAT'S THE
BIG DEAL ABOUT GIVING IT TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND I'LL ME
TRYING TO HANDLE AT EIGHT I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY HERE.
BELIEVES THAT THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD IS A POLITICIZED --
INSTITUTION I THINK THAT THEY GO
AND THEY LOOK AT SORT OF THE
FOUR CORNERS AS WE SAID IN
POSSIBLY LOOK AT FOUR CORNERS OF
THE AND AND MAKE YOUR
DETERMINATION.
BASED UPON THAT THE FOUR CORNERS
OF THE LAW AND ONE THING THAT
CONCERNS US I THINK SHOULD
CONCERN OTHERS.
IS THAT YOU'RE GOING -- TO AN
ENTITY. FOR BETTER FOR WORSE
THAT IS A VERY POLITICIZED --
INSTITUTION AGENCY AND SO I
THINK WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO HAVE
MAKE SURE THAT NO MATTER WHAT
THE PROCESS IS THAT IT IS AN
IMPARTIAL PROCESS.
AND AND NOT A POLITICAL PROCESS.
I EITHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
WELL AT THE MEDIA.
SAY I I APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN TO WORK ON THIS
YEAR YEAH I I AM SENSITIVE TO
THE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED --
BY A COUPLE OF INSTITUTIONS --
BUT FOR ME I I A L. WELL THERE'S
SOME CRITICISM OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AT TIMES --
OVER THE DECADES FOR MAYBE --
ALLOWING POLITICS -- TO TO
EMERGE -- I THINK BY BY A BY A
WIDE MARGIN THEY TO AN
EXCEPTIONAL JOB WITH GREAT
PROFESSIONALS THEY'RE AND IF IF
WE HAD AN EXAMPLE OR EXAMPLES OF
OF WHERE THERE'D.
DETERMINATIONS HAVE BEEN SO
CALLED POLITICIZED I WOULD BE
THE FIRST TO ASK US TO COME BACK
AND TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
ATTHAT ISSUE. TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER OR NOT WE WANT TO HAVE
TO CHANGE AND AND HOW THIS.
THIS BILL IS HIS PROPOSED -- IS
IS IMPLEMENTED -- BUT I DON'T --
I DON'T SEE THIS AS A
POLITICIZED ISSUE -- AT THE
MOMENT.
AND I DO THINK THAT -- WHAT'S
BEING SUGGESTED HERE IS -- IS A
PRUDENT COURSE I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THAT THE
ANALYSIS RAISES HIS --
CLARIFYING HOW THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL PROVIDES NOTICE TO AN
INSTITUTION AND THE ZERO ABOUT A
DETERMINATION -- AND THE
CRITERIA THAT'S REGRETS HOUSTON
I GUESS I WOULD ASK YOU ON ON
HIS BEHALF. TO CONTINUE TO WORK --
TO CLARIFY THAT THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE.
THAT TIES IS OKAY WITH YOU AND
WERE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
CLOSING MAYBE COMMENT UPON THAT.
YES AND I KNOW THAT I AM MR
BERMAN IS COMMITTED IS IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE OFFICE OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THEM
ON THAT NOTICE AND HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO NOTIFY.
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION IS
COMMITTED TO THAT ONGOING WORK
AS THIS.
BILL HOPEFULLY LEAVES THE
COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO JUST
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE CHAIR
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS THE
STATE'S TOP LAWYER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL AND THEY
WORK HARD TO PROTECT.
THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING OUR STUDENTS AND SO
YOU KNOW I THINK THATWAS WHY
MISTER BERMAN GAVE THIS
AUTHORITY TO THEM AND I THINK HE
IS OPTIMISTIC THEY WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR ISLAND.
VERY GOOD MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATION FOR
THE SHARING YOUR CONCERNS IS
THERE A MOTION FROM MY COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
MOVE THE BILL.
WITH THAT THE SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
DODD AYE AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN HI CAN I WILL.
ALL RIGHT SAID THAT CURRENTLY
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT WILL
HOLD A REAL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SO NOW I'D LIKE TO INVITE YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL.
THE ITEM SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR THANK YOU
AGAIN -- I WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF AND THE CHAIR FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL PROVIDING
GUIDANCE AND THAT GUIDANCE WAS
SO HELPFUL THAT HELPED US REMOVE
OPPOSITION SO I APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION.
AND TODAY I AM PRESENTING ON A.
B. THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WHICH
PROVIDES CRITICAL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND SAFEGUARDS TO
THE NEARLY HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
ENROLLED IN ONLINE FOR PROFIT
OUT OF STATE INSTITUTIONS THE
LARGEST LARGER SHARE OF
CALIFORNIANS ENROLLED ONLINE AT
SCHOOLS AND OTHER STATES ARE
ENROLLED IN THESE FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS.
AND IT'S ONE OF THE MOST TROUBLE
BUSINESS SECTORS TODAY.
THESEINSTITUTIONS ARE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE WORSE STUDENT
LOAN REPAYMENT OUTCOMES IN
CALIFORNIA BASED DISTANCE
EDUCATION PROVIDERS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE TOOK STEPS
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
FROM POSSIBLE PREDATORY OUT OF
STATE ONLINE BUSINESSES BY
REQUIRING THEM TO REGISTER WITH
THE BUREAU.
OF PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY OF POST
SECONDARY PRIVATE EDUCATION.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW APPLIES ONLY
TO THOSE PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN
CALIFORNIA NOT THOSE THAT A ROLL
CALIFORNIANS STUDENTS FROM
OUTSIDE THE STATE.
THIS BILL EXTENDS AS REFORMS IN
CURRENT LINE EXTENDS PROTECTIONS
FOR THOSE INSTITUTIONS.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS A
REGISTRATION PROCESS FOR THESE
OUT OF STATE SCHOOLS BUT NO WAY
FOR THE STATE TO IDENTIFY
PROBLEMS AT THE SCHOOLS REMOVE
THE ABILITY TO ENROLL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
AT A SCHOOL WHICH MAY POSE A
REST TO THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
THESE INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE INFORMATION
IF YOU'RE A WHICH MIGHT SIGNAL
THAT THERE'S A REASON FOR
CONCERN INCLUDING PENDING
INVESTIGATIONS OF LAW AND
LAWSUITS AS WELL AS
ACCREDITATION PROBLEMS.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE THESE DISCLOSURES AND
ADDITIONALLY OFFER A COMPLAINT
PROCESS FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AS WELL AS CREATE KEY ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS THAT WILL CLOSE THE
GAP BETWEEN STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
STATE INSTITUTIONS.
AND THOSE WHO CHOSE TO ENROLL IN
ONLINE IN PROGRAMS LOCATED OUT
OF STATE.
WITH ME TODAY IS ANGELA PERRY
AGAIN TO TESTIFY AS WELL AS AT
HOWARD FROM THAT CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY INSTITUTE FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO AND I
WILL TURN IT OVER.
ANGELA.
THANK YOU AGAIN THANK -- AGAIN
ANGELA PERRY WITH THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIRD AB.
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR OUT WELL
SOME HOPE THAT ONLINE EDUCATION
CAN HELP MORE STUDENTS EARN
COLLEGE DEGREES.
THE PROMISE OF DISTANCE
EDUCATION ALSO HAS PERILS.
THE CHALLENGES IN ASSESSING
ACADEMIC RIGOR AND STUDENT
OUTCOMES FOR ONLINE PROGRAMS CAN
BE EVEN GREATER THAN IN
TRADITIONAL PROGRAMS AND THERE'S
A LONG HISTORY OF OVER PRICED
AND POOR QUALITY PROGRAMS
LEAVING STUDENTS WITH DEBTS THEY
CANNOT AFFORD.
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ARE ENROLLED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION PROGRAMS BASED
EXCLUSIVELY ON LINE MOST OF
THESE ARE EXCLUSIVELY AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WERE TUITION IS LOW AND CREDITS
TYPICALLY TRANSFER EASILY TO
OTHER UNIVERSITIES HOWEVER THERE
ARE NEARLY ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ROLLED ONLINE.
IN PROGRAMS WHICH ARE LOCATED
OUT OF STATE.
AND THE LARGEST SHARE OF THE
STUDENTS ARE AT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES WERE STUDENTS ARE
PARTICULARLY LIKELY TO END UP
WITH THE DEBT THEY CANNOT REPAY.
THE AVAILABLE DATA SHOW THAT
THERE'S REASON FOR CALIFORNIA TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE STUDENTS
OUT OF STATE INSTITUTIONS THAT
AND ROLL CALIFORNIANS ONLINE
HAVE WORST STUDENT OUT CUT
THROUGH LOAN OUTCOME PREPAYMENT
RATES.
THAN DO CALIFORNIA BASED ONLINE
PROGRAMS. FOR HIS HISTORY WITH
PREDATORY PER FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES HAS LED TO THE CREATION
OF MANY PROTECTIONS FOR STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN THESE PROGRAMS
HOWEVER THE LOTS OF
TRADITIONALLY ONLY APPLIED. TO
STUDENTS LOCATED WITHIN
CALIFORNIA -- AND ATTENDING
SCHOOLS LOCATED WITHIN
CALIFORNIA.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE TOOK AN
IMPORTANT STEP BY CREATING A
REGISTRATION PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER THE
REGISTRATION PROCESS -- SUFFERS
FROM THREE FATAL FLAWS A FIRST.
THE STATE LACKS THE INFORMATION
NEEDED TO IDENTIFY RISK TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SECOND STATE
LACKS THE AUTHORITY TO REVOKE
SCHOOLS REGISTRATION IF A
PROBLEM IS IDENTIFIED.
AND THIRD THE SYSTEM LACKS A
COMPLAINT PROCESS MEANING
STUDENTS HAVE NO WAY TO IDENTIFY
ISSUES TO THE BUREAU DIRECTLY.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD FOR THE
STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE I OUT WE
HAVE A STUDENT STORY FROM IT
NATALIE LINES OF THE HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC RIGHTS ADVOCATES THAT
SHE CAN SHARE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
WARNING.
AB MY NAME IS NATALIE LINES I'M
AN ATTORNEY WITH HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
OAKLAND WE REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF
STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
A SUSAN CURTIS IS ONE OF OUR
CLIENTS SHE'S WORKING TODAY SO
I'M GONNA BE READING A STATEMENT
FROM HER.
IF YOU COULD JUST SUMMARIZE IT
AGAIN TO SENSITIVITY TO TIME AND
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SURE OKAY I'LL.
BE BRIEF ALL CREDIT THAT
IMPORTANT POINTS.
MY NAME IS SUSAN CURTIS I WANTED
TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCE ATTENDING
HOPPING UNIVERSITIES ONLINE
PROGRAM BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT.
PROTECT STUDENTS WHO ARE
ENROLLING IN ONLINE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS -- I'LL JUST SUMMARIZE
THAT SUSAN AND ROLLED IN
KAPLAN'S PARALEGAL PROGRAM.
AND I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
OUR EXPERIENCE -- SHE WAS
CHARGED UNIVERSITY LEVEL FEES
FOR AN ASSOCIATE PROGRAM THAT
DIDN'T PREPARE HER TO ENTER THE
MARKET PLACE AS A PARALEGAL.
AND LEFT HER WITH LOANS IN
EXCESS OF THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- SHE WE DID NOT
RECEIVE BASIC SKILLS AND SHOULD
NOT RECEIVE HER LEGAL SPECIFIC
SKILLS.
OUR PROFESSORS MADE THEM BY
BOOKS BUT THEN HE DID NOT TEACH
FROM THE MATERIAL THAT THEY MET
THEM BY -- THERE WERE LOTS OF
TECHNOLOGY PROBLEMS WHICH I
THINK IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO NOW. FOR EXAMPLE.
IN ADDITION TO ALL THE OTHER
TECHNOLOGY PROBLEM AND SHE
EXPERIENCE SHE HAD SHE FAILED A
CLASS BECAUSE YOU TAKING EXAM
AND THE PROGRAM FINDER OUT AND
SHE COULDN'T FINISH THE EXAM --
THEY SAID THEY HAD CAREER
SERVICES WHEN THEY AND ROLLED
HER AND THEY DIDN'T HELP HER
FIND AN INTERNSHIP THEY WOULD
EVEN HELP HER WITH HER RESUME.
AFTER SHE GRADUATED WITH HER
CERTIFICATE SHE COULDN'T EVEN
GET A JOB AS A LEGAL SECRETARY
SHE CONTINUES TO WORK AS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT FOR
ABOUT EIGHTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR
WHICH IS WHAT SHE WAS.
DOING BEFORE SHE GOT THE
CERTIFICATE.
THE FIND FINALLY AND JUST ONE
LAST SENS FROM HER BECAUSE I
THINK I'D LIKE TO AT LEAST LET
HER BE PRESENT TODAY.
I BELIEVE THE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS SHOULD BE PROTECTED
FROM MISLEADING INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY ONLINE SCHOOLS JUST
BECAUSE SCHOOLS ARE BASED OFFICE
WHERE THEY SHOULD NOT GET A FREE
PASS.
AND SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE
SAME LAWS AS OF THE CALIFORNIA
BASED SCHOOL.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING HER STORY.
THROUGH OUR THAT USED UP ALL THE
TIME SO THAT LIKE TO ASK YOU
COULD SUMMARIZE REMARKS THAT I'D
APPRECIATE IT.
PLEASE DANCE REQUIRE A AT HOWARD
ON BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN DIEGO SCHOOL OF LOS
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INTO SORT OF
REPUBLICAN FLOOD PLEASED TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
AND PERSONAL NOTE OF THANKS TO
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF NOT JUST
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL BUT
FOR ALL OF THE BILL.
COMMITTEE STAFFORD UNBELIEVABLY
HARD THANK YOU WITH THAT THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THAT LIKE TO COME UP
AND IDENTIFY THEMSELVES YES I'LL
HANDLE AND REVERSING NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
HE'S IN MARIN DEL CONSUMER
REPORTS ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
IMAGINE WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGE A CHANCE
OFFICE IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DANIEL CANDLE KAISER ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BOB SHERMAN WITH THE
CENTURY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU I ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE THAT UNDERSCORES THE GOOD
WORK OF THE AUTHOR AND ALSO SAY
MY WONDERFUL COMMITTEE STAFFER.
PUTTING TOGETHER A TERRIFIC BILL --
THAT'S BEFORE US -- I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION ONCE YOU
THIS ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR MY COLLEAGUES CENTER
ARCHULETA.
YES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
APPEARANCE TODAY IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE STOP THIS TYPE
OF OF THE ACTIONS THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE BY SOME OF THE
SCHOOL.
BUT WALK ME THROUGH HOW WE CAN
STOP IT.
THAT THAT'S THE IMPORTANT THING
BECAUSE IF YOU SAY WE'VE GOT
HUNDREDS UPON HUNDREDS -- EVEN
OF THE THOUSANDS THAT THAT ARE.
THEN ROLLED IN SOME OF THE
SCHOOLS.
AFTER THIS BILL IS PASSED.
HOW DO WE CUT IT OFF HOW DO WE
FIND THE BAD GUYS SEPARATED FROM
THE GOOD GUYS AND WHAT IS THE
PUNITIVE ACTION THAT WE SHOULD
TAKE? TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE NO
LONGER IN PRACTICE.
WALK ME THROUGH THAT.
YES SO THIS BILL REALLY.
LOOKS AT THE QUESTION OF AND THE
REGISTRATION PROCESS AND TAKING
REGISTRATION A FROM THE SCHOOLS
THAT ARE GETTING THAT -- WE KNOW
ARE HIGHLY PROBLEMATIC I
UNDERSTAND IN MY CONVERSATIONS
WITH THEM THE CHAIRMAN AND THAT
COMMITTEE STAFF.
THAT IT ISN'T CLEAR THAT THAT
WILL TAKE ALL OF THESE FOLKS OFF
OUT OF THE MARKET BECAUSE WE
ALREADY KNOW THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE.
OPERATING WITHOUT THE
REGISTRATION SO I THINK THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP AND I THINK YOUR
POINT IT'S IMPORTANT WE CONTINUE
TO MONITOR THIS AND MAKE SURE
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
AND FARE WARS MORE TEETH THAT WE
FOLLOW UP.
IN AND I WOULD IMAGINE THERE
SHOULD HAVE TO BE SOME
DISCLOSURES PUBLICLY.
ABOUT THE CRITERIA THE SCHOOL TO
GRADUATION RATE SOME OF THE
COMPLAINTS THAT ARE PUBLICLY OUT
THERE SO STUDENTS CAN GO ONLINE
AND SEE THE PROS AND CONS OF
APPLYING AT THAT PARTICULAR
SCHOOL AND MORE IMPORTANTLY IS
THE COST.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE JOB THAT
THEY GOT OR THEY DIDN'T GET.
IT RIGHT YEAH.
THIS BILL DOES REQUIRE THOSE
DISCLOSURES AND IT MAKES THEM
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE SO THAT IF
YOU ARE SHOPPING FOR AN
INSTITUTION YOU CAN GO ONLINE
AND COMPARE AND MAKE SURE YOU
ARE BUYING A PRODUCT THAT WILL
GIVE YOU THE EDUCATION YOU NEED
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL HELP PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S DANCE I'M.
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR GIVING
THE OPPORTUNITY CLOSE I KNOW
SENATOR HILL YOU WERE INVOLVED
IN SOME OF THE ORIGINAL.
FIREMAN'S OF OF REGISTRATION AND
THIS YEAR I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS THAT
I KNOW THIS BILL -- BILLS A BILL
TO POT.
SO WITH THAT UNLESS THERE'S
FURTHER COMMENT I'D LIKE TO GIVE
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY CLOSE NOW
MRS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
I HOPE WE WILL CONTINUE TO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
GOT I THINK CENTER LEYVA DID YOU --
DID HEAR YOUR THEIR CENTER
LEVELS MOVE THE BILLING WITH
THAT SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
ARCHULETA VIRTUALLY THE AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN PAN I WILL.
ALL RIGHT THAT BILL CURRENTLY
ENJOYS ENOUGH SUPPORT TO MOVE
FORWARD WILL GIVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT GOING BACK TO OUR
AGENDA ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO IS
HERE.
THAT'S ITEM.
FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FORTY THE WELCOME.
YOUR COMMITTEE -- YOU'RE NOT
HERE EARLIER WHEN WE BEGAN BUT I
I WANTED -- TO SAY AGAIN HOW
MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND THOSE OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY FOR
THIS FULL PACKAGE OF PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY BILLS THAT WE'RE
HEARING TODAY -- VERY IMPORTANT
AND VERY IMPACTFUL TO SO MANY OF
OF CALIFORNIANS AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR GOOD WORK IN
THIS AREA.
WITH THAT LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
ON OUR BILL AS WELL AS THE
ENTIRE PACKAGE -- THAT IS
RESPONDING TO RECENT ACTIONS BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND EDUCATION
SECRETARY DEVICE.
OF ABANDON CRITICAL PROTECTIONS
FOR STUDENTS AGAINST PREDATORY
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES THAT HAVE
PRIORITIZE PROFIT OVER STUDENT
SUCCESS.
ARBIL AB THIRTEEN FORTY WILL
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
FROM OVERPRICED INEFFECTIVE CREW
TRAINING PROGRAMS BY PROVIDING
ESSENTIAL DATA TO PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS IN THE PUBLIC ON
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES.
AT PRIVATE FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS.
THE FEDERAL GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
RULE WAS IMPLEMENTED UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION OF PRESIDENT
OBAMA TO ADDRESS AN ALL TOO
COMMON STORY STUDENTS PROMISED
BY RECRUITERS THAT THEY'LL FIND
A JOB IN AN INDUSTRY.
WHO TAKE OUT TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS OF DEBT?
ONLY TO FIND UPON GRADUATION
THAT THEY CAN'T GET THE JOB THAT
THEY WERE PROMISED.
THERE THEN UNEMPLOYED
UNDEREMPLOYED FACING
ASTRONOMICAL DEBT REPAYMENTS OR
EVEN LOAN DEFAULTS.
THE VICTIMS ARE TYPICALLY LOW
INCOME FAMILIES VETERANS WOMAN --
AFRICAN AMERICANS LATINOS AND
OTHERS.
BASED ON THE INITIAL DATA FROM
THE FEDERAL EDUCATION DEPARTMENT
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY PROGRAMS
FOR A CALIFORNIA DID NOT PASS
THE TEST.
THESE PROGRAMS GRADUATED OVER
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO
LEFT SCHOOL WITH ALMOST A
BILLION DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN
DEBT.
LAST YEAR TRUMP AND ABBAS MOVE
TO SCRAP THE FEDERAL GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT RULE FUELING THE
GROWTH OF PREDATORY SCHOOLS AND
ABANDONING SAFEGUARDS THAT HAVE
PROTECTED OUR STUDENTS.
TODAY'S HEARING ON THIS BILL IS
VERY TIMELY BECAUSE THIS PAST
FRIDAY US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION UNDER THE DIRECTION OF
SECRETARY TO BOSS FORMALLY
RESCINDED THE ROLE.
SCRUBBING THE RULES ALSO
ELIMINATED A CRITICAL SOURCE OF
INFORMATION ON THE ACTUAL WAGES
THE STUDENTS AREN'T AFTER
GRADUATING.
IN THE ABSENCE OF THE ROLE THE
ONLY SOURCE OF INFORMATION THAT
WE HAVE AN EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES
AT THE SCHOOLS OR VERY LITTLE ON
RELIABLE ALUMNI SERVICED A
SURVEY DATA.
OUR BILL IS PASSED BY THE
ASSEMBLY WOULD'VE REINSTATED A
VERSION OF THE GAME FROM POINT
ONE CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR YOUR STAFF FROM GAUGING
WITH US ON AUTHOR AMENDMENTS AS
CURRENTLY AMENDED FOR THIS
COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY WILL TAKE A
MAJOR STEP TOWARD MAKING FOR
PROFIT SCHOOLS MORE ACCOUNTABLE
AROUND GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT.
BY CLOSING A MASSIVE GAP IN OUR
STATE OUTCOMES DATA FOR THESE
JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS OUT FOR
PROFIT SCHOOLS.
BY CREATING A PROCESS FOR WAGE
DATA MATCH WITH THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT.
THE MATCH DATA WILL THEN BE
AGGREGATED BY PROGRAM AND BY
INSTITUTION AND POSTED IN A
DATABASE ON THE BUREAU'S WEBSITE
FOR THE PUBLIC TO SEE.
THE STATE WILL SHED LIGHT ON THE
ACTUAL WAGES THAT STUDENTS OF
THESE PROGRAMS FOR AN AFTER
GRADUATING.
AND ALLOW PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS
THE PUBLIC ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT
THE ACTUAL QUALITY AND WORTH OF
SOME OF THESE DEGREES.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE OUR HOPE IS
ONCE WE HAVE THIS DATA WE CAN
DETERMINE NEXT STEPS TO PROTECT
OUR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
THE STUDENTS WHO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS ABANDONED OUR
STUDENTS DESERVE BETTER WITH
THAT WHEN I TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES.
HELLO I ANGELA PERRY WITH THE
INS FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS -- I'M OFF I'M HERE TO
OFFER SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY WHICH WOULD MAKE
RELIABLE VERIFIED OUTCOMES DATA
FOR FOR PROFIT SCHOOL STUDENTS
AVAILABLE. FOR STUDENTS
TAXPAYERS AND POLICY MAKERS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE FIRST TIME.
STUDENTS AT PRIVATE COLLEGES OR
IN POST SECONDARY EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE HISTORICALLY NOT
HAD ACCESS TO RELIABLE VERIFY
DATE O OUTCOMES.
MANY STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO NO
DATA AT ALL AND THE DATA THAT IS
AVAILABLE IS UNRELIABLE IN
INCOMPLETE.
THIS MEANS THAT STUDENTS ARE NOT
ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT THE INVESTMENT THEY ARE
MAKING WHEN THEY ENROLL IN
SCHOOLS AND TOO MANY BAD ACTORS
HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THIS TO
PREY UPON STUDENTS OF COLORS.
STUDENTS OF COLOR FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS
FOSTER KIDS SINGLE MOTHERS AND
VETERANS.
THIS LACK OF DATA ALSO LEAVES
POLICYMAKERS WITHOUT THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT HIGHER
EDUCATION POLICY IN CALIFORNIA.
ALL THREE OF THE PUBLIC SEGMENTS
HAVE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE OUTCOMES
DATA FOR THEIR GRADUATES CREATED
THROUGH A DATA MATCH WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT.
AND AS PLANTS DEVELOP TO CREATE
A STATEWIDE LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA THAT SAME
EDT DATA WILL ALSO POVIDE THE
WORKFORCE OUTCOMES FOR THAT
SYSTEM.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY REPRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THAT SAME
EDT DATA AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
AT FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS THAT AS
WELL IT WILL MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO
INCORPORATE THE STUDENTS INTO
THE CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
AS IT DEVELOPS.
AB THIRTEEN FORTIES MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS HAVE STREAMLINED THE
BILL WILL STILL PREFERRED
PRESERVING THIS ESSENTIAL DATA
MATCH ENSURING THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WILL HAVE ACCURATE DATA
EVEN AS THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
HAVE BEEN WITHHOLDING
INFORMATION.
AND ROLLING BACK PROTECTIONS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT THE
BILL ENERGY -- I'VE VOTE AND WE
HAVE AN A STUDENT TEST MANY
TREES IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE
YOUR STORY.
GOOD MORNING OF MANY MORE
RESEARCH ON THIS IS MY THIRD
TIME COMING TO SACRAMENTO TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT ROLE.
AT FIRST I TOLD THE I'D
COMMITTEE ABOUT MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE ATTENDING A PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT LEAVING ME WITH
NEARLY HALF A MILLION DOLLARS IN
STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
AND A WORTHLESS DEGREE WITH
CREDITS THAT WILL NOT TRANSFER.
I TOLD THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE THE
STORIES OF MY CLASSMATES.
HOW MANY OF THEIR FINANCIAL AND
PERSONAL LIVES HAVE BEEN RUINED
BY?
THE EXCESSIVE DEBT AND LIMITED
OR NONEXISTENT JOB PROSPECTS.
THEY'RE LIKE TO ADDRESS AND THE
IDEA THAT THE INDUSTRY TALKING
HEADS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
CONTINUE TO HARP ON THEY'RE
CLEARLY DOING THEIR BEST TO
CONVINCE THE PUBLIC THAT THE FOR
PROFIT EDUCATION INDUSTRY HAS
PUT STUDENTS FIRST.
AND OTHER MOTIVES ARE IN SOME
WAY ALTRUISTIC BECAUSE THEY
SERVE NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS.
WELL I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THAT
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS A
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENT THERE ARE
ONLY STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT BEING
SERVED BY THE VAST PUBLIC
EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
ALREADY EXISTS IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE STUDENTS ARE LEFT WITH FEW
OPTIONS IN THEIR FINANCIAL.
EIGHT AND STUDENT LOAN DOLLARS
ARE BOON TO THIS INDUSTRY AND
ITS SHAREHOLDERS.
I CURRENTLY WORK AS A NURSING
ASSISTANT SO I'LL GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE.
FROM THE HEALTHCARE FIELD.
A QUICK SEARCH YESTERDAY SHOW ME
THAT I TUITION AND FEES FOR A
VOCATIONAL NURSING PROGRAM IN A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
COSTS APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
A TUITION COMPARISON SHOP SITE
SHOWED ME THAT ONE LARGE FOR
PROFIT OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA
CHARGES A WHOPPING FORTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE HUNDRED
EIGHT FOR THAT SAME EXACT
PROGRAM NOT INCLUDING BOOKS AND
SUPPLIES.
ANOTHER LARGE FOR PROFIT CHARGES
A BIT LESS THAN THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND FOR THE SAME PROGRAM
AND PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THESE FOR
PROFIT OR TEACHING THE EXACT
SAME CURRICULUM.
BY LAW FOR LICENSING.
AND PREPARING STUDENTS FOR THE
EXACT SAME LICENSING EXAM.
BOTH OF THE FOR PROFITS I
MENTIONED HAVE LOWER PASS RATES
AND HIGHER DROPOUT RATES.
SO YOU TELL ME WHICH OF THE
STUDENTS YOU THINK ARE MORE
LIKELY TO STRUGGLE WITH THE
EXCESSIVE THAT.
I CAN'T BEGIN TO FATHOM HOW THEY
JUSTIFY THAT SORT OF EXCESSIVE
TUITION INFLATION.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT I
SEE THEM TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
LARGE POPULATIONS OF STUDENTS
WHO CAN'T WHO EITHER CAN'T FIND
AN OPEN SPOT?
AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR FEEL
THEY HAVE NO OTHER CHOICE.
BUT TO PAY NEARLY SIX TIMES THE
AMOUNT FOR THE EXACT SAME
PROGRAM.
I SEE THEM SUCKING UP INCREDIBLE
AMOUNTS OF FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN
IN STATE GRANT MONEY.
WITHOUT ANY ACCOUNTABILITY TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL INFORMATION TO
STUDENTS SO THAT THEY CAN MAKE A
WELL INFORMED CHOICE ABOUT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL AND FINANCIAL
FUTURES.
SO I ASK YOU.
WHY THE SCHOOL SHOULD NOT BE
HELD TO THE SAME EXACT STANDARDS
AS PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA?
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT LEGISLATORS
DO THE JOB THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SEEMS UNWILLING TO DO
AND PROTECT STUDENTS AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH A
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT RULE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH TERESA
AND WHAT WAS THE DEGREE THAT YOU --
WENT THROUGH A PRIVATE COLLEGES
WAS A NURSING DEGREE NO THAT
CAME AFTERWARDS BECAUSE I
COULDN'T FIND A JOB BUT I HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN VISUAL
JOURNALISM.
THAT'S WITH THE DEGREE THAT YOU
WERE GOING THROUGH THE PRIVATE.
THAT'S WHERE I GOT MY ORIGINAL
BACHELORS DEGREE YES OKAY --
TERRIFIC WELL THANK YOU BOTH OF
THIS PERIOD THREE SIR FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ANY OTHER WTNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD AND
IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
DANIEL CANNED ACOSTA -- BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
IMAM MAJID WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCE OFFICE
IN SUPPORT.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER DOWN
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
NOW THE LINES WITH HOUSING
ECONOMIC RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT.
HE'S IN MARTINDALE CONSUMER
REPORTS ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BOB SHERMAN WITH CENTURY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
AT OUR UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO
SCHOOL OF LOS ANGELES ADVOCACY.
REPUBLICAN RESPONSE LEGAL CLINIC
OLD FROM.
THANK YOU OKAY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND AND SUPPORT THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NOT BAD.
FOR NO NO I A YOU CAN DO IT IN
THE BACK MIKE I FIGURED A
TWEENER IS THAT RIGHT.
YEAH GOOD EXPLAINED MAP BACK
REPRESENTING CAPS WE WERE
OPPOSED TO THE PREVIOUS VERSION
OF THE BILL WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WORK CERTAINLY THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK.
CERTAINLY DON'T AGREE WITH SOME
OF THE ASSERTIONS THAT WERE JUST
MADE UP YOU KNOW VERY PROBABLY
ABOUT OUR SECTOR.
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE BILL --
NOW THAT IT'S BEEN AMENDED AND
WE HAVE REMOVED OR OPPOSITION
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SHARE MEMBER SCOTT GOVERNOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR THE STAFF
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING ON
THE FILM REMOVE OPPOSITION.
THERE ARE A FEW OUTSTANDING
ISSUES THAT WOULD LIKE TO SEE
FIXED GOING FOR WE DISCUSSED
WITH THEM.
ARE WE LOOK FORWARD TO RESOLVING
THIS THE BILL WAS FALLING THANK
THANK YOU MISTER GOVERNOR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS LIVE IN ALL
TOMORROW ON BEHALF OF AMBER
EDUCATION SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
COLLEGE IN CARRINGTON COLLEGE
JUST.
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES -- WE REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION IN A NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND SOME
OF THE TECHNICAL FIXES THAT WE
STILL THINK NEED TO BE.
IN THE BILL THANKS THANK YOU.
THE MORNING JENNIFER TANNA HELL
WITH ERIN READING ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF WEST COAST UNIVERSITY
AN AMERICAN CAREER COLLEGE ALSO --
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN IN
ONE I THINK THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE. FOR FOR WORKING ON
THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR GEORGE MILLER ON
BEHALF OF ASHFORD FOR A WANT TO
THANK CHAIRMAN AND LAUGHTER --
IN THE CHAIR STAFF IN PARTICULAR
AND THE AUTHORS OFFICE FOR
WORKING WITH US AND AGAIN WE
REMOVE OPPOSITION AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL ARNOLD ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NOR STATE UNIVERSITY
IN ELK GROVE WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS WE
THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE FINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR THOUGHTS.
AND FRED JONES WITH PROFESSIONAL
BE THE FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA
DID -- ALL THE REST.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT SPENT ON BEHALF A UP I
COLLEGES AS WELL WE'LL BE MOVING
OPPOSITION GOING TO NEUTRAL
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU.
WELL -- ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
FOLKS IN OPPOSITION OR TWEENER
OR ANYTHING IN BETWEEN OKAY WILL
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE -- WELL I WANNA I
WANNA THANK AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
Q. FOR YOUR GOOD WORK IN
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA I FIND
OF ALL THE BILLS THAT WE'RE
HEARING TODAY -- THIS ONE IS THE
MOST CONSEQUENTIAL.
AND I A I A SO AGREE WITH THE
GOALS THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH.
I KNOW WE WERE TRYING TO GO A
LITTLE FURTHER BUT I THINK THAT
WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE US TODAY --
IS A MEASURABLE -- POTENTIAL
IMPROVEMENT FOR STUDENTS AND AND
AND THEIR RECOGNITION
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT.
THAT DEGREE THAT THEY'RE TRYING
TO ATTAIN MIGHT REALLY MEAN IN
THE REAL WORLD.
AND SO I I THANK YOU AGAIN. FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP -- WE ARE GOING
TO BE AS AS A MATCH THE
BEGINNING OF THIS HEARING WHERE
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A SUNSET
REVIEW ON THE BUREAU.
AND I A IN VALUE AND ALL THOSE
INVOLVED IN THIS ISSUE TO BE
INVOLVED AS WE LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE IN MORE DETAIL -- IN THE
COMING YEAR.
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK
TO BE DONE AND I KNOW THAT.
THAT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES -- IN
AND THEN AND THE PROMOTION OF
THIS BILL WAS THAT THAT WAS THAT
A TECHNOLOGY CHALLENGE A PRIVACY
ISSUE.
ALL THOSE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO WORK THROUGH AND
THAT VERSION OF OF THE BILL
THAT'S BEFORE US TODAY.
BUT IT DOES REQUIRE MORE
VIGILANCE AND MORE WORK -- AS IT
GOES FORWARD BUT IT CERTAINLY
HAS.
HAS MY SUPPORT ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
CENTER HEALTH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND IN AS I LISTEN TO THE
THE THE BILLS THAT ARE COMING
FORWARD TODAY DEALING WITH THE
SITUATION OF OF SECONDARY.
EDUCATION I I GET EXCITED THAT
THE SOLUTIONS THAT -- THAT HAVE
BEEN CRAFTED IN AND IT REALLY
WORKED ON IS THIS IS A DIFFICULT
ISSUE A LONG TERM AND LONG
STANDING ISSUE WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND I NOTICED THAT
THANK THE THE STAFF OF THIS
CONSIDER COMMITTEE AND THE
CONSULTANTS WHO HAVE WORKED SO
HARD.
ON DEVELOPING THE THE THE THE
MATTER AND AND REALLY THE
ABILITY TO TO CREATE -- A VIABLE
SOLUTION TO SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT -- PROTECT OUR STUDENTS AND
REALLY -- THERE HAS BEEN
CONSIDERABLE ABUSE THERE HAS
ALSO BEEN VERY GOOD EDUCATION
PROVIDED.
BUT IT'S THE ABUSE WE HAVE TO
GET AFTER AND I THINK THESE
BILLS ARE DOING ITS OWN REALLY
PLEASE MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AS WELL AND IN TAKING
THEM ON AND AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE DO.
SEE SOME GOOD VIABLE PRODUCTS AT
THE END OF THE DAY THANK YOU TO
BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
GREAT -- SELLING NUMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
LET ME FIRST AGAIN APPRECIATE --
THE COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION
AND THE CHAIRS -- DEEP GAUGING
WITH US ON THIS BILL ME JUST A
FEW POINTS IN RESPONSE TO SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE.
OF FIRST I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH
THE CHAIRMAN THAT THE BUREAU --
HAS NOT DONE THE JOB THAT I
THINK WE NEED IT TO DO WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS SECTOR.
I AND I KNOW THAT THE OPPOSITION
HAD RAISE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
AROUND TECHNOLOGY IMPLEMENTATION
IS A REASON WHY WE COULD
NECESSARILY EMPLOYMENT GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT RULE TDAY.
RESCUE TO SUPPORT THE IDEA OF
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT DATA
ACCOUNTABILITY -- I WILL
CERTAINLY BE PARTNERING
HOPEFULLY WITH YOU.
IN THAT SENSE IT REVIEW TO DO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO GET THAT
BUREAU WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE.
THE SECOND THING I WANT TO SAY
IS -- TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
UP WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH THIS
PACKAGE IS NOT -- IN A IT'S NOT
A 100% INDICTMENT OF THE FOR
PROFIT INDUSTRY WE ARE REALLY
TRYING TO TARGET THE BAD APPLES
IN THE INDUSTRY.
WHO HAVE REALLY OUT LETTER
STUDENTS DOWN AND LET TERESA AND
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND OTHER
STUDENTS WHO WENT TO SCHOOL FOR
WHO PAID FOR A BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF STUDENT LOAN DEBT?
WHO GOT NOTHING IN RETURN TO
ENSURE THAT WHILE THEIR STORIES
WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IN
THE FUTURE WE'RE ADDRESSING IT
AND SO?
OUR HOPE IS THAT THIS IS A BILL
THAT -- REALLY ECHOES THAT THE
SAYING THAT SUNSHINE IS THE BEST
DISINFECTANT THAT WITH THIS DATA
WE WILL GET ACCOUNTABILITY WILL
GET TRANSPARENCY AND WILL DO A
BETTER JOB FOR STUDENT AS WELL
AS SEND A MESSAGE. TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THAT CALIFORNIA
WILL BE STEPPING UP IF THEY'RE
BACKING AWAY FROM OVERSIGHT AND
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND
WITH THAT I'M GONNA RECOGNIZE
THE MOTION FOR CENTER HILL.
AND AS THE SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARE TO THAT I GOD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA I AM I CAN I WILL.
RED BILL CURRENTLY HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT THANK YOU AND
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOUS AND
REGULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
WELL I DO SEE THAT -- SOMEONE
MEDINA HAS BEEN THE MOST PATIENT
PERSON HERE ALTHOUGH ASSEMBLYMAN
CHAO IS EARLIER IN THE AGENDA
BUT I'M GONNA.
LEAVE IT TO YOU ALL TO DECIDE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT FIRST.
SOME WOMEN MEDINA WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
NINE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX AND WITH THAT PLEASE
PROCEED AS YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY I
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX TIME AND
AGAIN WE'VE SEEN FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES PREY ON LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
CHARGE EXORBITANT AMOUNTS IN
TUITION.
AND FAILED TO PROVIDE THE SKILLS
AND JOBS PROSPECTS THAT OUR
PROMISE.
IN THE WORST CASE SCENARIOS
CLOSE CAMPUSES WITHOUT ANY.
OF RETRIBUTION.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX WILL ALLOW
VICTIMS OF FOR PROFIT SCHOOL
CLOSURES.
AND MISS REPRESENTATION TO
RECOVER FUNDS WHILE ATTENDING
SCHOOL.
IT EXPANDS THE STUDENT TUITION
RECOVERY FUNDS DEFINITION.
OF AN ECONOMIC LOSS TO RECOVER
LOSSES BEYOND TUITION EXPENSES
INCLUDING HOUSING TRANSPORTATION
AND CHILDCARE.
AS WELL AS ANY EXPENSES INCURRED
BY THE STUDENT AS A RESULT OF
THE CLOSE SCHOOL SUCH AS
TRANSCRIPT FEES THE COST OF
SERVICES.
RELATED TO DEBT RELIEF.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX ENTERS ITS
STUDENTS IS SUBJECT TO
DEMORALIZING DEBT COLLECTION AND
LAWSUITS FROM PRIVATE STUDENT
STUDENT LOAN COLLECTORS.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT WITH NO NO VOTES.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
JASON SPENCER.
THE STUDENT.
THE STUDENT AND NATALIE LIONS
WITH THE HOUSING AND ECONOMIC
RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
VERY GOOD I'D LIKE FORTY HEARING
YOUR WITNESSES LET ME KNOW THAT
AS FAR A I KNOW THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION HAS RISE.
SO I WELCOME YEAR.
CONSOLIDATED COMMENTS BOB.
HELLO MY NAME IS JASON SPENCER
HEIGHTENED WELL TAKE A ROUTINE
SCHOOL BETWEEN NOVEMBER TWO
DOLLARS ELEVEN SEP.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE R. GRADUATED
WITH HIS HIS CERTIFICATE FROM
WHILE TECH HEATING VENTILATION
AIR CONDITIONING PROGRAM.
WHEN I FIRST VISITED WHILE TECH?
REPRESENTATIVE GAVE ME A SPEECH
ABOUT HOW GREAT IT IS.
HOW GREAT IT IS THE PROGRAM WAS
A LATE DAY LISTED JOB PLACEMENT
RATE STATISTICS THAT TURNED OUT
TO BE FALSE?
FINANCIAL A REPRESENTED TALKED
OF THE PROGRAM HAD ME FILL UP
PRIVATE LOAN DOCUMENTS.
I NEVER TOLD ME THAT WHILE TECH
KIND OF FINANCIAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE PRIVATE LENDER.
HE TOLD ME ONCE I GRADUATED DAY
WILL HELP ME FIND A JOB RIGHT
AWAY.
YEAH WHEN HE WAS ABOUT TO
GRADUATE WHEN I WAS ABOUT TO
GRADUATE ACTS WILL TAKE FOR A
JOB ASSISTANCE.
AND THEY DO NOTHING TO HELP ME.
AFTER LEAVING WALLET SAID.
I CANNOT FIND A SPECTRUM OF POT
ONES ARE RELATED TO ME TAMARA
PHIL BUT ONLY LASTED A COUPLE
DAY.
NOW THAT I WORK FOR SOUTHWEST.
MANITOBA HAS NOT RELATED TO MY
FILL OF STUDY.
A JAVA COULD HAVE A TABLE
THOMAS'S TICKET.
I HAVE COMPLETELY GIVEN UP HOPE
OF FINDING AN H. BACK JOHN.
MEANWHILE AM DROWNING THE
STUDENT LOAN DEBT THAT WHILE
TECH PRESSURE ME TO TAKE HOME.
WELL TAKE CHARGE ME SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND FORMS IN NINETY IN
TUITION FOR THE H. SPECS
DIFFICULT PROGRAM.
AND NEARLY HALF OF THAT DAY'S
PRIVATE STUDENT LOANS WITH
INTEREST I ENDED UP PAYING
ELEVEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN DOLLARS AND TWENTY
EIGHT CENTS AND PRIVATE LOANS.
I SUBMITTED A BAR DEFENSE
APPLICATION TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
IN A MINUTE AGREE TO COVER 30%
OF MY FOR A LONG DAY.
EVEN THOUGH THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS RECOGNIZED THAT WELL TAKE
THE FARTHEST TUNES LIKE ME.
EVEN THE DEPARTMENT HAD THESE
CHARTS ALL THE MY FEDERAL LOANS
THAT DOESN'T COVER DEPRIVE LOAN
DEBT.
A TOOK OUT TO GIVE MY AGE EXETER
COULD STONE'S LIKE ME YOU WHOSE
FAULT LIES. FOR BY PRIVATE
SCHOOL RELY ON CALIFORNIA'S
DOING TUITION RECOVERY BOND TO
BE ABLE TO FULLY RECOVERED A
FINANCES LOSSES WE EXPERIENCED
WITHOUT ANY GAMES.
THANK YOU JASON FIRST COMING AND
SHARING YOUR STORY ABOUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT -- YOU FIND YOURSELF IN.
BUT HOPEFULLY WITH THE ADVANCE
FOR THIS BILL YOU'LL SEE THAT
YOU'RE A ENGAGEMENT HAS MADE A
DIFFERENCE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE THE PROBLEM THEIR NEXT
WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
UNDERSTAND THAT -- I SHOULD BE
BRIEF AB MY NAME IS NATALIE
AGAIN FROM HOUSING AND ECONOMIC
RIGHTS ADVOCATES -- AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX IS IMPORTANT STEP O
RECOGNIZING THE FAR REACHING AND
DEVASTATING EFFECTS.
ON THAT FIELD FOR PROFITS CAN
HAVE ON THEIR STUDENTS IN BRIEF
SOME O THOSE -- AFFECTS BEYOND
TUITION COSTS ARE A COSTS FOR
TRANSPORTATION FOR LONG COMMUTES --
TO SCHOOL OR TWO INTERNSHIPS
THAT DON'T EVEN ASSIST IN
GETTING A JOB CUTTING HOURS AT
WORK -- SOMETIMES KIND CUTTING
WORK ENTIRELY -- LOSING BENEFITS
LIKE HEALTH CARE -- PAYING DOWN
FAMILY SAVINGS ON CHILD CARE
SCHOOL SUPPLIES AND STUDY AIDS --
STUDENTS DID THE THINKING THEY
WERE GOING TO GET A LEG UP AND
THEN THEY JUST END UP WITH A
BUNCH OF THAT AND AND NOT JUST
FOR TUITION AND SCHOOL SUPPLIES.
SO WE ARE ADVOCATING FOR THAT AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX OF SAID SO
THATCALIFORNIA'S STRING TUITION
RECOVERY CAN BETTER.
NOT COMPLETELY BUT BETTER REPAIR
THE HARM DONE TO THE STUDENTS
AND GIVE THEM A REALISTIC CHANCE
OF RECOVERING.
WE ARE DR THANK YOU NATALIE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I'LL HANDLE IT ON ONCE AGAIN --
REPRESENT A NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANIEL CANDLE KAISER BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
EMERGENT BUT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIVE CHANCES OFFICE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS A MARTIN DEL CONSUMER REPORTS
ALSO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ENGINE PERRY INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I WOULD GET ON A REPRESENTING
THE CENTURY FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE NOW WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONSERVE QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
CENTER ARCHULETA YES I'M JUST
LIKE TO THANK YOU --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS ALL
MORNING [inaudible]
PROTECTING -- STUDENTS
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE TRYING TO
BETTER THEIR LIVES IN TRYING --
TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES
AND THROUGH AN EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM THAT OBVIOUSLY WE FOUND
FLAWS IN -- BUT THIS BRINGS IT
TO THE FORWARD COOL DRINKS ARE
SHUTTING DOWN.
PLAY ME BANKRUPTCY SO THIS WILL
OPEN THE DOOR TO ELIMINATE THAT
BURDEN THAT YOU HAVE SIR.
THAT -- THEN I THINK THAT YOUR
FAMILY'S IS OFFICE OBVIOUSLY
SUFFERING FROM AS WELL.
SO I I THINK THE IS THE STUDENT --
TUITION RECOVERY BILL I THINK
WOULD WOULD BE THE NAME OF THIS
ONE BUT I THANK YOU FOR AND I'M
GLAD WE'RE WE'RE TAKING THAT THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
ANSWER ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING AFFORD SO I WILL --
URGENT AYE VOTE ON THAT.
RIGHT WITH THAT TO US A MEMBER
MEDINA WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE YES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU TO THE WITNESSES AND IN
CLOSING JUST -- TO SAY ALSO THAT
LAST WEEK.
OF MANY OF US RECOGNIZE THE
BETTER THAT ARE OF THE YEAR.
I I DID -- AND AS WE'VE SEEN --
AS WE HEARD IN THE ASSEMBLY --
HIGHER ED COMMITTEE MANY OF THE
VICTIMS HAVE BEEN VETERANS SO I
THANK THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I POD
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CENTER TO LET AS MOVE THE BILL
WITH THAT THE SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD AYE DODD AYE
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE TILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
AYE PAN HI AND I WILL.
THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OF CONTRAPTION MEMBERS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU FOR COMING.
CANNELLA INVITES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO TO COME FORWARD THIS IS --
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE ASSEMBLY
BILL.
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE SILLY NUMBER
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND WE
WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY ABOUT THE
YOUR BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND NOW SENATORS --
THIS MORNING I LIKE TO PRESENT
THAT TO YOU AB.
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE I LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
LISTED ON PAGES SEVEN EIGHT OF
THE ANALYSIS TO PROVIDE DE
CALIFORNIA.
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL OR SEE A
AND T. C. WITH MORE DISCRETION.
IN THE SCHOOL APPROVAL PROCESS
AND ALSO MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WITH
STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR MASSAGE
THERAPY SCHOOLS MICHAEL CA NTC.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THAT
STUDENTS BE NOTIFIED WHEN THEY
ARE ATTENDING A NON APPROVED
SCHOOL WHICH CAN JEOPARDIZE
THEIR ABILITY TO BECOME
CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST.
CA ANTI C. IS TASKED WITH
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC BY
CERTIFYING MASSAGE PROFESSIONALS
AND MEET THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS.
AS WELL AS APPROVING MASSAGE
PROGRAMS THAT MEET THE MINIMUM A
TRAINING AND CURRICULUM
STANDARDS UNDER BE IN PEACE
SECTION SIX OF FORTY SIX TWELVE
THE CITY HOUSE SO THE DISCRETION
TO REQUIRE THAT MASSAGE
THERAPIST BE CERTIFIED BY THE CA
IN DC.
IN ORDER TO PRACTICE WITH INTO
THEIR JURISDICTION.
CONSEQUENTLY THERE HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS -- ANTS INCIDENTS WERE
A STUDENTS GRADUATE WITH A
MASSAGE THERAPY SCHOOL FROM A
MASSAGE THERAPY SCHOOL THAT IS
NOT APPROVED BY CA NTC.
AND AS A RESULT -- CANNOT BECOME
CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST TO
LEAVING THEM UNABLE TO PRACTICE
THEIR PROFESSION.
CURRENTLY THERE'S NO FIXED
TIMELINE FOR SCHOOL APPROVAL
THERE'S ONLY ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAY PROCESS -- FOR CA MTC TO
APPROVE OR DENY AT SCHOOL UPON
RECEIPT OF RECEIPT OF THE
COMPLETED APPLICATION HOWEVER IN
REALITY.
IT OFTEN TAKES MUCH LONGER TO
RECEIVE THE FINAL DECISION IN
FACT THOUGH SOME APPLICATIONS --
HAVE BEEN PENDING FOR TWO TO
THREE YEARS MEANWHILE STUDENTS
WHO ATTENDED THOSE SCHOOLS ARE
IN UNABLE TO OBTAIN
CERTIFICATION IMPACTING THEIR
LIVELIHOOD.
NOW THIS BILL AB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE WILL PROVIDE A BETTER
NOTICE TO STUDENTS WHEN THEY
ATTEND A SCHOOL WHICH IS NOT
APPROVED WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
ESTABLISHING A FIRM TITLE --
TIMELINE OF FOR THE APPROVAL
PROCESS AND ALSO PROVIDE MORE
CERTAINTY TO THE STUDENTS SO
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
RADIO WITNESSES HERE IN FAVOR.
A GOOD AFTERNOON THAT SHERMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALMOST AT
ANY OHER SEE OVER THE
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
CONSUL.
I WOULD HAD MANY DISCUSSIONS
CONSTRUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ANY STAFF.
AND IT'S COLD QUE IT ALL CAME
DOWN -- TO DEFECTED TO THESE
POSSIBLE TO WRITE LEGISLATION.
THAT RECOGNIZES -- LEGITIMATE
STUDENTS HARD WORKING STUDENTS
ARE LOOKING TO BECOME
PROFESSIONAL MASSAGE THERAPIST
BUT AT SAME TIME.
GOES AFTER THE BEST BAD APPLES
SPECIFICALLY ARE FRAUDULENT
SCHOOLS AND DIPLOMA MILLS -- WE
SUPPORT IS BILL.
ADAIR ID FINALLY I DO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE -- LISA SILVA FOURTH
OR ANALYSIS THEY'RE STILL COUPLE
TWEAKS -- DEATH WE ARE WILL
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING ON
WEDNESDAY COMMITTEE AND THERE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHEN S..
MY NAME IS BERNADETTE MARIE I
MISS CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL CERTIFIED MASSAGE
THERAPIST AND I'M ALSO HERE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED
BODY WORK AND MASSAGE
PROFESSIONALS.
WHICH HAS OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA I
PERSONALLY AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND ASSOCIATED BODY WORK
AND MASSAGE PROFESSIONALS ALSO
SUPPORTS THIS BILL WE STRONGLY
RECOGNIZE THE EXTRAORDINARY
LEADERSHIP.
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO HAS --
BROUGHT FORWARD IN TERMS OF
HELPING WITH THE SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE BEEN I HAVE APPLICATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN PENDING INDEED IN
SOME CASES.
AS I WROTE IN MY LETTER OF
SUPPORT FOR OVER THREE YEARS --
AND I DO ALSO WANT TO ECHO
MISTER NET NAILS ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
OF ALL THE GREAT WORK THAT
ALYSSA HAS DONE AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITHOUT WE URGE YOUR
AYE.
AYE VOTE ON THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YOU COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
ANYONE ELSE HERE.
OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEEFOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MEMBERS.
LIKE TO INVITE.
NUMBER CHAO TO CLOSE IF YOU'D
LIKE I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
ABOUT A VOTE DOWN RIGHT CENTER
LATEST MOVE THE BILL AND WITH
THAT THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE CHIANG ARCHULETA.
ARE TO LET AYE DODD.
OF YANNI.
YANNI AYE HILL HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN HI CAN I WILK.
VERY GOOD THAT BILL CURRENTLY
HAS THE VOTES TO GET OUT WILL
HOLD REAL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
RIGHT I SEE A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY IS BACK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THIS IS THE LAST OF THE FIVE
BILLS DEALING WITH A PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION THIS IS --
I'D OF FILE ITEM.
EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE THAT I
INVITE YOU TO BEGIN AS YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU A MISTER CHAIR --
FIRST THANK YOU FOR A WORKING
WITH US AND THANKS TO YEAR --
CONSULTANT AS WELL FOR FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS ON THIS
ISSUE IT IS A NEW WANTS TO ISSUE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THEWITNESSES AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION
THAT WERE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
TRY TO FOCUS ON THE ISSUE AT
HAND AND AS WE NOTED EARLIER.
THIS IS A A BIG INDUSTRY IN OUR
IN OUR STATE AND OUR NATION IS
HAS ITS.
PLUSES AND IT CERTAINLY HAS ITS
THE NEGATIVE AS WELL.
IT'S NOT.
A PERFECT INDUSTRY AND AND ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT -- IS
PARAMOUNT IS MAKING SURE THAT WE
PROTECT STUDENTS AND THE GOAL
THIS BILL IS FOCUSING ON THE
RECRUITMENT IN THE FRONT END --
IN ESSENCE IT'S A VERY SIMPLE
PURPOSE MANY TIMES PEOPLE ARE
PAID TO GET PEOPLE IN THE SEATS
LITERALLY THEIR **** IN THE
SEATS.
WE WANT TO CHANGE THE DYNAMIC SO
PEOPLE ARE COMPENSATED TO CAP
SUCCESS THINK OF A CAP AND GOWN
AT THE END OF THE DAY -- SO
CURRENT LAW -- ONLY PREVENTS
THESE KICKBACKS BY -- EMPLOYERS
OR EMPLOYEES FOR ENROLLING
STUDENTS -- AND DOES NOT INCLUDE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS THIS
WOULD CHANGE THAT LOOPHOLE -- WE
VIC WE'VE PUT FORWARD AMENDMENTS
TO WE THINK ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS WAY TO
TERMINATION AND EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION BASED UPON --
OVERALL PRACTICES AND WORK BY
THE BY THE INDIVIDUAL -- WE'RE
STILL OKAY -- FINE TUNING THIS
ISSUE LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING TO
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE TO DO SO.
GOING BACK A STEP A WIRE HERE IN
THE FIRST PLACE ALL OF THESE SO
CALLED -- SCANDALS -- ALL THE
SCANDAL START WITH THEIR SO
CALLED RECRUITERS AND AS THE
ANALYSIS NOTES.
AND PAGES SEVEN EIGHT THERE ARE
COUNTLESS EXAMPLES OF SOME OF
THESE HIGH PROFILE -- TACTICS IN
ONE EACH USE COMPLAINTS AGAINST
ASHFORD A COUPLE YEARS AGO
INDIVIDUAL TESTIFIED AS FAR AS
THAT TEAMS RINGING CAL BELLS AND
A TRUE BOILER ROOM ATMOSPHERE
THAT REMINDED THEM OF THE WOLF
OF WALL STREET.
IN THE NINTH CIRCUIT DECISION
LAST YEAR WITH ACADEMY OF ARTS
THERE IS EXAMPLES OF INDIVIDUALS
GETTING THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
INCREASES.
AND THE POTENTIAL DECREASES FOR
FAILURE TO MEETING IN ROME AT
TARGET TO GET AS FAR AS
ENROLLMENT VERSUS SUCCESS WE
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT ISSUE
WERE TRYING TO FOCUS ON IS
HAVING STUDENT GET SUCCESS AS
OPPOSED TO JUST GETTING THEM.
ROLL THE SEAT BECAUSE ROLE IN
THE SEAT COMES WITH -- FINANCE
RELATED MANY TIMES -- A LOT OF
STUDENT DEBT WITHOUT THE SUCCESS
OF THE END OF THE DAY -- WE DO
KNOW THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
FRANKLY IS CAN ONLY BE ADDRESSED
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE
IN THE CURRENT.
A SECRETARY FOR EDUCATION TO
ENFORCE THESE LAWS FOR A FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES IN THESE KICK
BACKS AND IS ABOUT ENSURING THAT
WE SUPPORT OUR CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT OUR BEST
INTERESTS.
SO THIS WOULD CODIFY THESE
PRACTICES IN STATE LAW.
AND ALLOW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO GO AFTER THESE.
INSTITUTIONS THAT DON'T --
PROTECT THEIR VULNERABLE
STUDENTS WE KNOW THIS IS A THAT
I I'VE THAT COHORT OF STUDENTS
THAT ARE MARGINALIZED MANY TIMES
IN THE FIRST PLACE LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR NOT A LOT
OF YOU KNOW FINANCIAL BACKGROUND
TO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GETTING.
THEMSELVES INTO SO WE WANT TO
PROTECT THEM ON THE FRONT END
AND FOCUS ON ACTUAL STUDENT
SUCCESS AT THE BACK END -- WITH
ME TODAY ARE MY TWO WITNESSES
THAT AS STUDENTS AND A
PRACTITIONER.
IN THE FIELDS OR START WITH MY
STUDENT THANK YOU WELCOME.
MY NAME IS STANDING RIGHT -- SO
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON SUPPORTING --
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE AND I
WENT.
TO MURNAU'S SCHOOLS OF BEAUTY
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND I DID
NOT HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
OR A GED.
THEY DOCTORED IN ATV TEST THAT
UP MADE IT SO THAT I WOULD PASS.
AND UP.
I WOULD RECEIVE THE MAXIMUM
FEDERAL STUDENT.
LOAN -- MONEY AND SO.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYONE
ENROLLED AT MARANELLO AT LEAST
WHILE I ATTENDED WAS EITHER ON
SOME SORT OF GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE OR THE THEY HAD TO
HAVE THEIR PARENTS COSIGN. FOR
THEIR LOANS.
SO.
WHILE I WAS IN ATTENDANCE THERE.
EVERYONE MIL.
IT WAS VERY APPARENT THAT.
MARANELLO SPECIFICALLY PRAYED ON
PEOPLE OF COLOR LOWER INCOME --
MANY TIMES FAMILY IS THAT YOU
KNOW SINGLE MOTHER.
FAMILIES AND THEY WANTED THE
MAXIMUM FEDERAL LOAN FROM EACH
STUDENT.
THE SCHOOL WENT AS FAR AS TO
ENROLL STUDENTS LIKE ME WHO DID
NOT HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
OR A GED.
AND THEY ALSO WENT AS FAR AS TO
CREATE A THE TISSUE SCHOOL AND
LA AND MADE HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS
FOR STUDENTS THAT LATER ON WERE --
WORTHLESS [inaudible]
SO -- LIKE I SAID I WAS ONE OF
THE STUDENTS THAT HAD A DOCTORED
ATB TEST.
THEIR SHARED ME THAT -- WHEN OUT
IN ROLE THAT I WOULD BE?
MAKING TEN TIMES MORE MONEY THAN
I WAS AT THAT TIME WHICH WAS
[inaudible]
ZERO SO I YOU KNOW THAT WAS THE
BAIT -- IS THE THAT I DIDN'T
HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR
GED THEY SAID IT'S OKAY TAKE THE
TEST SO I TAKE THE TEST AND JUST
LIKE THEY SAID I GUESS I GOT AN
AND NOBODY THAT.
ATTENDS THESE TYPES OF SCHOOL
SHOULD EVER MAKE MINIMUM WAGE
AND I HAVE NOT FOUND A JOB.
IN A SENSE.
TWENTY TWELVE THAT PAYS MORE
THAN MINIMUM WAGE -- THE SCHOOL
RECEIVED BY FEDERAL PELL GRANT
ON MY BEHALF WITHOUT MY CONSENT
OR KNOWLEDGE.
AND I FOUND THAT OUT MUCH LATER.
ALTHOUGH MY LOTUS WERE.
WERE FORGIVEN IF I DECIDE I
WANTED TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL.
I WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
FEDERAL PELL GRANT.
AND THAT WAS A BIG -- PUSH FOR
ME BECAUSE I DON'T.
I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF MONEY SO --
JUST SO WE'RE CLEAR.
THAT WOULD MEAN THAT -- I'D HAVE
TO BEG AND BORROW MY MOM AGAIN.
FOR RENT -- AND DUE.
TO MARANELLO AS THE STAY IN ON
MY CREDIT.
I CANNOT BUY A HOUSE LIKE I
CANNOT BUY A CAR.
I CAN'T EVEN GET A CREDIT CARD
IN MY NAME [inaudible]
AT ALL.
AND I HAVE TWO SMALL KIDS.
SO THIS IS REALLY BEEN A STAIN
ON MY CREDIT AND IT'S TAKING
YEARS -- TO TRY AND WIPE CLEAN.
I WAS PROMISED LIFELONG JOB
PLACEMENT ASSISTANCE AND THAT I
WOULD MAKE.
LIKE I SAID TEN TIMES MORE MONEY
WITH MY COSMETOLOGY LICENSE
WHICH WAS NOT TRUE -- I MADE
MORE MONEY WITHOUT MY
COSMETOLOGY LICENSE THAN I DO
WITH IT -- THIS WILL COMPLETELY
YOU COULD JUST WRAP UP THANK YOU
YEAH.
BUT I APPRECIATE YOU COMING HERE
AND SHARING YOUR STORY.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
SCHOOL'S BEEN SHUT DOWN IT
HASN'T CHANGED THAT TERRIBLE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH YOU FOUND
YOURSELF VERY SORRY. TO HEAR
THAT.
I KNOW THAT'S A PART OF WHY THIS
BILLS BEFORE US IN YOUR
TESTIMONY VERY COMPELLING THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU BUT
BY TWO OTHER WITNESSES --
MEMBERS PLEASURE TO BE HERE AT
HOWARD WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN DIEGO SCHOOL OF LOS
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY OFFENSIVE
VETERANS LEGAL CONNECTIONS ARE
FOR PUBLIC INTEREST LAW.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BILLS WELL I
SHOULD FOR SAY THAT THE POINT OF
THIS BILL IS TO FACILITATE
ENFORCEMENT OF THIS IMPORTANT.
LAWS -- AND PRINCIPLES OF BY
BRINGING CLARITY TO CURRENT LAW
AND BY BRINGING THE BEST PARTS
OF FEDERAL LAW DOWN INTO
CALIFORNIA HOW DOES THIS BILL DO
THIS.
FIRST IT STRIKES THE DEFINITION
OF EMPLOYEES THAT INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS ALSO CAN'T BE
PROVIDED OR OFFERED KICKBACKS TO
GET -- TO USE THE COLORFUL
PHRASE REAR IN CINCY.
THAT IS ALREADY FEDERAL LAW ALL
OF THE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT OPPOSE
THE BILL TODAY ALREADY HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH THAT.
IT INCLUDES FINANCIAL AID AS
AMONG THE THINGS THAT YOU CANNOT
KICK BACK FOR THAT IS ALREADY
FEDERAL LAW.
ALL THE PEOPLE HERE WHO MIGHT
OPPOSE THE BILL TODAY ALREADY
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THAT.
IT SAYS THAT THE BILL ADDS
DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY --
DIRECTLY FROM FEDERAL LAW THAT
TO PREVENT WINK AND NOD
ARRANGEMENTS -- AND IN BED THAT
CALIFORNIA LAW.
THAT IS NOT NOVEL.
THAT COMES DIRECTLY FROM FEDERAL
LAW.
EVERYONE WHO IS WHO MIGHT OPPOSE
THIS BILL ALREADY HAS TO COMPLY
WITH THAT BECAUSE OF FEDERAL LAW.
THE BILL ADDS THE WORD
CONTINGENT IN THIS IS A CRITICAL
ADDITION TO THE BILL.
AND THAT IS ON SCENE AND EITHER
FEDERAL OR STATE LAW.
AND THE REASON THAT'S IN THERE
IS BECAUSE IT BENEFITS
INSTITUTIONS BY CLARIFYING
ABSOLUTELY CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT
THIS IS NOT A STRICT LIABILITY
STANDARD.
BUT THERE HAS TO BE A CONTINGENT
QUID PRO QUO ARRANGEMENT THE
VIOLATE THIS LAW.
THAT BENEFITS INDUSTRY BUT IT
BENEFITS STUDENTS TO BY OFFERING
CLARITY AS TO WHAT THE LAW DOES
PROHIBIT AND WHAT IT DOESN'T
PROHIBIT.
AN ORIGINAL VERSION OF THIS BILL
USED THE WORD SUCCESS.
IT IN ORDER TO DEFINE THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT WERE PROHIBITED.
WE DELETED THAT BECAUSE SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION OBJECTED TO THAT
IS AMBIGUOUS EVEN THOUGH THAT
COMES FROM FEDERAL LAW.
ON WE DELETE A NEW POLL I'M
SORRY WE ADDED EXEMPTION -- AT
THE REQUEST OF AT A UT I WOULD
BECAUSE SHE DID.
A TERRIFIC I THINK EXEMPTION FOR
THEM.
OUT WHERE BY.
THE IF THERE OR COMPENSATION
ARRANGEMENTS ACTUALLY GET TO THE
CAP AND GOWN.
THAT HELP PEOPLE GO FROM
ENROLLMENT ALL THE WAY TO
GRADUATION WE CLARIFY THAT
THAT'S NOT ILLEGAL IN THOSE
INSTANCES THE INTERESTS OF
STUDENTS IN THE INTEREST OF GOOD
INSTITUTIONS ARE COMPLETELY
ALIGNED A VERY HELPFUL AMENDMENT.
THAT ISN'T SEEN IN EITHER
FEDERAL OR STATE LAW CURRENTLY
AND FINALLY -- AMONG THE MORE
AND PERHAPS.
MORE DOMINANT OF THE DISCUSSION
IS WE ADD THE WORDS CONDITION.
EMPLOYMENT RECOGNITION A
CONTRACTOR BENEFIT.
NOW.
THOSE WORDS ARE NEW.
BUT IT IS A CLARIFICATION.
OF KINDS OF ARRANGEMENTS THAT
ARE ALREADY ILLEGAL HOW DO WE
NOTICE.
WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE IT CANNOT
POSSIBLY BE THE CASE.
THAT UNDER CURRENT LAW.
IT IS ILLEGAL TO DOCK SOMEONE'S
PAY. FOR FAILING TO MEET A QUOTA.
BUT ENTIRELY LEGAL TO FIRE THEM
FOR FAILING TO MEET THAT QUOTA.
THE ANSWER IS NO THE BEST
READING THE BEST READING OF
CURRENT FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
EMBEDDED IN THE WORD
COMPENSATION.
IS THAT INCLUDES FIRING PEOPLE
WHEN THEY DON'T MEET A QUOTA BUT
IT ISN'T REALLY CLEAR AND THE
SMARTEST THING I'VE EVER HEARD
ABOUT DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS ENFORCEMENT FROM THE
NUMBER TWO WAS.
WE WIN TOO MUCH.
WHAT HE MEANT WAS YOU COULD
FINISH UP YES THANK YOU?
WE WENT TO MUCH MEETING.
WE NEED THE THE TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE FACILITATE CLEARLY IN
THE LAW THE FACILITATING FORCE
WHAT NOW.
IT IS FAIR THE WHOLE EAST.
ME IN PARTICULAR BY THE PETARD
CLEARED.
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH WE CAME WE
CAME VERY CLOSE WITH ONE
INSTITUTION ONE WORD AWAY FROM
BEING ABLE TO FIGURE OUT AN
AGREEABLE DEFINITION TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CAN STILL FIRE PEOPLE.
WHO ARE NOT PERFORMING?
IT IS FAIR TO HORSES MIGHT ACT
WE ARE AN ONGOING NEGOTIATIONS
WITH.
THE OPPOSITION AND WE ARE AT ONE
POINT WE GOT ONE WORD.
AWAY SO IT HAS COMPLETELY ARE
PHILLIP CHANCE TRY TO ADDRESS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AS
WE HEAR FROM THE THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
COME ON UP AND PLEASE JUST
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND ANY
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT.
PLEASE RETURN MEMBERS ALEX
TOWARDS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
IMAN **** WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE CALL JUST CHANCE
OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA PERRY INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS IN
STRONG SUPPORT HE MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS ADVOCATE ANI
REPRESENTING THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ALLEY LANDS WITH HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC CRICKET RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ST MARTIN DEL CONSUMER REPORTS
ALSO TRANSPORT.
DANIEL CANDLE BECAUSE OUR BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER ON
REPRESENTING NEXT IN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT AND OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OF THE GUYS OF ORGANIZE YOURSELF --
THE UP PROPONENTS TO GO OVER
TIME SO BE SURE THAT -- THERE IS
EQUAL TIME PROVIDED TO YOU.
IF NECESSARY [inaudible]
WITH RESPECT [inaudible]
OKAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MAP BACK
REPRESENTING CAPS OF CAPS IS THE
LEADING ASSOCIATION FOR
CALIFORNIA REPRESENT A HUNDRED
FIFTY TO TWO HUNDRED SCHOOLS.
WE'VE BEEN ENGAGE WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS ON THIS
BILL FOR WELL OVER A MONTH WE'VE
OFFERED TO SET OF AMENDMENTS --
I THINK I AGREE WITH ALMOST
EVERYTHING THESE SUPPLEMENTS AT
WE WE DO NOT ONE INSTITUTIONS
PROVIDING KICK BACKS TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES. TO INSURE MORE
STUDENTS EITHER -- IN ROLLING
THE INSTITUTION OR GET MORE
FINANCIALLY.
AND IN FACT IS A COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT CURRENT LAW
AND FEDERAL LAW VERY CLEAR ON
THAT ISSUE -- POTENTIALLY MAYBE
ONE OF THE ISSUES IS ENFORCEMENT --
WE DO KNOW THE BUREAU -- HAS HAS
KIND OF HISTORY IN A BACKLOG OF
OF THINGS IN AND MAYBE THEY ARE
NOT DOING IT.
BUT IRONICALLY THE FEDS AREYOU
MENTION THE ACADEMY OF ART THEY
PAID A SIGNIFICANT FIND TO THE
FEDS JUST LAST MONTH TO PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES WERE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE UNDER THE SAME
PROVISION OF LAW.
SO THE FEDS ARE EVEN UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
ON ENFORCING THE LAW.
SO WHAT IS THIS BILL DO IN MIND
WE HAVE CONCERNS.
IT HAS A LOT OF VAGUE AND NEW
TERMS THAT WILL PRESENT A BUNCH
OF UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE. FOR
INSTANCE THE BILL SAYS ANY
CONTRACT AND ANY BENEFIT FOR ANY
PERSON INVOLVED IN RECRUITING
ENROLLMENT CONTINUE IN A MOMENT
ATTENDANCE.
EVERY EMPLOYEE IN OUR SCHOOLS
WILL TOUCH ONE OF THOSE THINGS
AT ANY GIVEN DAY.
CAN WE NOT PROVIDE FOR A ONE
CASE THAT'S IN ANY BENEFIT CAN
WE NOT PROVIDED PENSION PLAN CAN
WE NOT PROVIDE A YEAR END BONUS
IF ANY OF THOSE EMPLOYEES WERE
AT ANY POINT INVOLVED.
IN THOSE ACTIVITIES.
NOW ONE OF THE MAIN PROVISIONS
THAT WERE CONCERNED WITH IS
SOMETHING CALLED THE CONDITION
THE EMPLOYMENT WHICH IS
CERTAINLY A NEW TERM FOR THE
SPACE.
CONDITION THE POINT SO WE HAVE
ENROLLMENT WE HAVE ADMISSIONS
FOLKS THEIR JOB.
IS TO TALK TO STUDENTS AND GET
STUDENTS INTERESTED IN THE
UNIVERSITY OR THE INSTITUTION
RIGHT THEY CAN'T GET PAID BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF FOLKS THEY
BRING IN.
BUT THEIR JOB IS TO MAKE CALLS
THEIR JOB IS TO FOLLOW UP ON
EMAILS THEIR JOB IS TO PROVIDE
TOURS THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
SO IF WE CAN'T CONDITION
EMPLOYMENT BASED ON THOSE
ACTIVITIES WE COULD NEVER
TERMINATE AN EMPLOYEE FOR NOT
DOING THEIR ROUTINE.
ACTIVITIES.
SO AGAIN THE GENERAL PREMISE OF
THE BILL WE AGREE WITH.
WORDS MATTER.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF IN THIS BILL WE
PROVIDED TWO SETS OF AMENDMENTS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
I I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS IS THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE HAD A THOROUGH
DISCUSSION ON THE BILL.
AND A THOROUGH UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS --
SO WHERE WERE OBVIOUSLY HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR -- AND
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO THAT
WITH THE WITH THE OFTEN SPONSORS
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO RESOLVE
ANY OF OUR CONCERNS TODAY.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
OPPOSED.
HI THANK YOU -- I'M HERE AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF ASHFORD UNIVERSITY
AND WEEK WE JUST HAVE ONE ISSUE --
THAT WOULD LIKE TO REYES AND IT
HAS TO DO HAVE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WITH RESPECT -- TO THE
THIS INCENTIVE COMPENSATION ROLE
AS IT'S REFERRED TO THERE'S
SOMETHING CALLED THE BUNDLED
SERVICES EXCEPTION -- AND THE
REASON IT'S IMPORTANT IS -- THE
BY BY THE THE AMENDMENT TO THE
TO THE STATUE THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED IN BRINGING IN THIRD
PARTY CONTRACTORS -- THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OF ENTITIES THAT THE
CONTRACT WITH BOTH OF FOR PROFIT
AND IN NONPROFIT EVEN PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS TO PROVIDE A GROUP
OF SERVICES. TO AN INSTITUTION
SO PRESENTING IN CALIFORNIA-THERE AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE
CONTRACTS WERE SOMEONE WILL COME
IN.
AND IN AGREE TO DEVELOP MARKET
AND AND EVEN OFFER IN IN IN IN
PART A PROGRAM AND THEY GET PAID
BASED ON REVENUE.
I AM AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL -- THE
BUNDLED SERVICES EXCEPTION
PROVIDES THAT IF IF THE THE
RECRUITING SERVICES ARE BUNDLED
WITH A BUNCH OF OTHER SERVICES.
AND THE THIRD PARTY IS AN
INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY AND
YOU'RE NOT PAYING SPECIFICALLY
FOR RECRUITMENT.
THAT THAT'S AN EXCEPTION TO THE
INCENTIVE COMPENSATION ROLE IN
WHAT WITH WITH CONVERSATIONS AT
THAT THAT I'VE HAD WITH THE
SPONSORS IT'S UNCLEAR -- AT
LEAST WHETHER THE BUNDLED
SERVICES EXCEPTION WOULD APPLY
TO THE CURRENT ITERATION OF THE
ROLE AND AND REALLY ARE OUR ONLY
REQUEST FOR AN AMENDMENT IS TO
JUST MAKE IT CLEAR -- BUT THAT
OF THE BUNDLED SERVICES
EXCEPTION DOES IN FACT APPLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
VERY GOOD -- OTHER WITNESSES --
IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON FRED JONES ON
BEHALF OF THE PROFESSIONAL
BEAUTY FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA.
LIKE TO ASSOCIATE OUR
ASSOCIATION WITH -- MATT BACKS
COMMENTS IN TOTO BUT VERY
SPECIFICALLY OUR PRIMARY CONCERN
WITH THIS BILL WAS.
DISINCENTIVE VISINE DOES THAT
HELP STUDENTS ACTUALLY FINISH
GRADUATE WE THOUGHT THAT WAS A
STEP TOO FAR AND YOU MENTION
GETTING THEM TO THE CAP AND GOWN.
BUT THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENT
STILL REFERS TO QUOTE UNQUOTE
CONTINUED ENROLLMENT THAT STILL
VERBOTEN.
SO I SEE WORDS DO MATTER THERE
ARE SOME.
CONFLICTS WITH THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE THAT WE SEE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISS CHAIR MEMBER SCOTT GOVERNOR
AT UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX WE
AGREE WITH MR BACK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'VE BEEN ALL TOMORROW ON BEHALF
OF SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY COLLEGE
CARE TO COLLEGE IN MEMBER
COLLEGE ALSO AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS MISTER BACK MAKE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
RENTS SPENCER BEHALF OF THE U.
E. I. COLLEGES AND LIKE LANA
COMMENTS WITH MR BACK.
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER TAYLOR HILL WITH A OUR
REGION ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN CAREER COLLEGE IN
BECAUSE UNIVERSITY ALSO -- IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED.
THANK YOU.
HI BY CHOICE WILL BE HALF OF THE
UNIVERSAL TECHNICAL INSTITUTE.
ON A THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE
IMMINENT CLARIFYING THAT.
WE CAN CONTINUE TO BASS --
INCENTIVE COMPENSATION TIED TO
GRADUATION RATES SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT -- WE REMAIN OPPOSED
THOUGH BECAUSE YOUR SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS OVER.
CONDITION APPOINTMENTS OF
POTENTIAL PAWN PHOTOS AND OTHER
METRICS IS THE OTHER METRICS IS
UNDEFINED AS OF LATE IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING THE AUTHOR
AND EDUCATION COMMITTEE -- TO TO
TO WORK ON THOSE ISSUES THANK
YOU.
HI JACK MODON FROM THE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA AUTOMOTIVE BUSINESS
COALITION THE AUTOMOTIVE SERVICE
COUNCILS CALIFORNIA -- WE HAVE
SIMILAR CONCERNS HIS UT I
UNIVERSAL TECHNICAL INSTITUTE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IS THE BILL MOVES OR
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL ARNOLD CALIFORNIA NORTH
STATE UNIVERSITY ALSO POSED FOR
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED I
WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE TO LOOK
AT SUBDIVISION M. ON PAGE SEVEN
WHICH IS.
THE PROVISION.
IN QUESTION THE ALTHOUGH WELL
INTENTIONED.
OUR FEAR OF IT IT IS SO OVERLY
BROAD THAT IT'S GOING TO REALLY
CREATE PROBLEMS FOR INSTITUTIONS
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING. FOR THEIR STUDENTS.
GREAT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I WILL BRING THE ISSUE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
CENTER PATH.
THANK YOU SELLER MCCARTY AND I
THINK THAT -- ISSUE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE BUT THE BELL --
COULD PERHAPS CAN YOU OR YOUR
SPONSOR ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPONENTS AND
WHERE YOU ARE AND YOUR
CONVERSATION WITH THEM THE FEEL
LIKE THAT.
BOB THIS AT OFTEN WORDS IN YOUR
MOUTH LIKE TO TELL ME IT I MEAN.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE THERE'S WAY TO
RESOLUTION OR YOU ARE IS THERE A
IS THERE -- OR DO YOU THINK THAT
THAT'S YEAH YEAH YEAH ALTHOUGH.
WE DON'T RESPOND TO THE OPPOSITE
YEAH HALL TURNED OVER TO MY
WITNESS IT IN A SECOND BUT I
WILL NOTE THERE IS A OF A LIST
OF ISSUES THERE BUT MANY OF THEM
AS YOU HEARD.
THERE'S NOT DISAGREEMENT FROM
WHAT THE GOAL IS AND WHAT
CURRENT PRACTICES WHAT THEY HAVE
TO DO.
IS JUST UP SOMEWHAT -- IN THE
DEFINITIONS OF AT IF WE'RE ABLE
TO THE SIXTY TODAY AND MOVE ON
TO THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE BIG
PICTURE I'M.
MORE THAN WILLING TO SIT DOWN
AND BRINGS TOGETHER TO HELP TO
BRING UP -- A RESOLUTION WE HAVE
TAKEN SOME ISSUES OFF THE TABLE --
AND WE TEMPTED TO TO PUT THESE
FORCES AMENDMENTS ON THE TWENTY
FIFTH TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES ARE KIND OF HASHING THEM
OUT TODAY.
LET ME LET TO MISTER HOWARD.
EXPENSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE CHAIR THANK
YOU A DOCTOR PANTS ON NO THIS IS
IT I'VE.
I SHOULD TURN IN MY LAWYER CARD
IF WE CAN FIGURE THIS OUT -- WE
WERE ON THIS IS A SITUATION
WHERE.
WE ARE ON THE SAME PAGE WE HAVE
THE SAME CONCEPTS.
AND WE'RE JUST TRYING TO CUT OUT
THE WORD SMITHING OF IT.
I'LL GIVE YOU A HARD EXAMPLE OF
THAT IF IT WON'T BE TOO BORING.
THE NEW SUBDIVISION AND AS A
NANCY THAT WE INCLUDED.
WE PUT THAT ACTUALLY IN THE BILL
TO SIGN TO EVERYBODY.
AS A CONCRETE SIGNED EVERYBODY
WE WANT TO KEEP TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
AND IF YOU YOU'LL RECALL THAT
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY FOR
EXAMPLE I BELIEVE MISTER BACKS.
THE SUGGESTION THAT A
CONTRIBUTION TO A FOUR OH ONE K.
WOULD BE UNLAWFUL UNDER THIS THE
REASON I RESPECTFULLY DISPUTE
THAT.
IS BECAUSE OF THAT WORD
CONTINGENT.
ADDING BOTH HERE ANDTHERE ARE
CERTAINLY IF OF FOUR OH ONE K.
CONTRIBUTION WERE ADDED BECAUSE
YOU MADE A QUOTA.
OR SUBTRACTED BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T
NEED A QUOTA THAT'S UNLAWFUL NOW.
IF YOU HAPPEN TO GET A FOR ALL
INCOME CONTRIBUTION FOR DOING A
GREAT JOB AT THE END OF THE YEAR
LIKE YOUR STAFF DOES A GREAT JOB
THE NEW YEAR.
THAT'S OKAY SO IF YOU LOOK AT
THE NEW N. WE PUT CONTINGENT
UPON QUOTAS WELL.
IN EVEN THOUGH SOME OF THE
MINUTES OFFERED BY.
MISTER BACK WOULD WOULD LIMóN A
QUOTE IS FROM THE WHOLE I'M
BORED.
I CAN TELL SO I THE THE THE
POINT IS YES OKAY SO WHAT IT
SHOULD BE THIS WE IF IF AS I
SAID IF I SHOULD TURN IN MY
BARCHART IF I CAN GET OKAY SO
SAYS.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE.
THERE'S OPPORTUNITY GET
RESOLUTION I CERTAINLY --
APPRECIABLY FINE ACCOMPLISH
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION
EXPRESSES ALSO SUPPORT FOR
GETTING TO THE END GOAL HERE --
I KNOW THAT -- I SAID ON THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE ALONG WITH
THE CHAIR HE'S SITTING NEXT TO
ME SO -- YEAH CERTAINLY I WON
WHILE THE CONVERSATION CONTINUE
AND SO I GUESS I WOULD MOVE THE
BILL AND AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
PICK UP RESOLVE ALL THE
DIFFERENCES.
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR
MY COLLEAGUES HERE.
CENTER LEYVA AND THEN SENATOR
ARCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I AM I
TOLD THE AUTHOR THEN I'M GONNA
LAYOFF TODAY BECAUSE I DO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS IT IS COMING TO
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
SO FORGET TELL THE COMMITTEE
TODAY THAN -- FOR A FEW THINGS
THAT I WOULD LIKE -- TO TO TALK
WITH YOU ABOUT ONE OF THEM IS
THE OTHER METRICS -- BECAUSE IF
YOU HIRE SOMEONE TO ANSWER
PHONES AND THEY'RE NOT ANSWERING
PHONES ARE NOT NECESSARILY
GIVING YOU KNOW MAKING A QUOTA
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY -- RE
RECEIVING SOMETHING A
COMPENSATION FOR THAT BUT IF YOU
HER SOME ANSWER PHONES ARE A
ANSWERING PHONES AND IF YOU
CANNOT THEN TERMINATE THEM.
AS AN EMPLOYER YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THAT SO -- I'M A
LAYOFF TODAY AND IF IT GETS TO
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE WE CAN
TAKE A HARDER LOOK AT SOME OF
THESE THINGS.
SENATE ARCHULETA YES SIR SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE.
PERTAIN -- TO YOU KNOW THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES THAT ARE
GIVEN AND OR CAN BEEN GIVEN OR
HAVE BEEN GIVEN -- CLOSING SOME
OF THE LOOPHOLES THAT ARE THERE
AND REFERENCE TO KICK BACKS.
AND IN IN THE FIRING OF OF THE
BAD TEACHERS IN THE BAD
ADMINISTRATORS.
OF FOR ALLOWING A CODE OF
CONDUCT TO IT HE EXIST.
OF WITHOUT ANY ONE BE
REPRIMANDED WHAT.
CAN YOU ANSWER THAT SURE I THAT
THAT IS NOT OUR INTENT AT ALL
AND WE'RE WILLING TO TO CLARIFY
THAT IT'S MORE THE FRIEND IF IT
WERE OKAY. FOR MANY PEOPLE FOR
NOT DOING THEIR JOB BUT IF YOU
SAY YOU'RE GOING TO HIRE
SOMEBODY AND YOU'RE GONNA PAY
THEM BASED UPON HOW MANY THINGS
ARE ABLE. TO TO ACHIEVE YOU KNOW.
IT'S AN ENROLLMENT IS THE BIG
ONE WE'RE FOCUSED ON BUT THAT
THAT CERTAINLY NOT ARE ARE
INTENSE AND AND I'M GLAD YOU
BROUGHT THAT UP AND I'M WILLING
TO CLARIFY THAT.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET OUT AS
COMMITTEE IN A DRESS AND THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE THE
BIGGEST.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER IT
GALGIANI.
I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS ATTEMPTING TO DO WHEN
YOU'RE TAKING ON A VERY
DIFFICULT -- ISSUE AREA AND THIS
WHOLE LARGER ISSUE AREA I GUESS
MY MY LARGEST CONCERN IS THAT
I'VE ALWAYS.
BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF K. TWELVE
TEACHERS WHEN THE SUBJECT COMES
UP ABOUT WHETHER -- TO TIES
THEIR WORTHINESS AND THEIR
COMPENSATION BASED ON THE
SUCCESS OF STUDENTS AT A SCHOOL
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT --
STUDENTS START AT DIFFERENT
STARTING POINTS SOME COME. TO TO
SCHOOL READY TO LEARN WHILE
OTHERS.
DON'T COME TO SCHOOL AS READY TO
LEARN AND ALL OF THOSE
CHALLENGES THAT WE SHOULDN'T --
CRITICIZE IN AND HOLD ITS
FAILURES K. TWELVE TEACHERS
BECAUSE THE STUDENTS AREN'T
ACHIEVING AT THE SAME LEVELS SO
I GUESS I'M I'M STRUGGLING WITH.
BECAUSE I FEEL THAT I SHOULD BE
HOLDING THAT SAME STANDARD WHEN
IT COMES TO TEACHERS WHO ARE
WORKINGWITH OTHER STUDENTS WHO.
ARE AT HIGHER GRADE LEVEL SO --
THAT'S WHERE I'M STRUGGLING
TODAY SOME GOING TO LAY OFF
TODAY INTEL -- YOU KNOW I CAN
THINK THIS THROUGH MORE AND AND
LEARN MORE.
IN RELATION TO THIS OTHER
COMMENTS OR ASK QUESTIONS. ONE
MORE THING IF YOU ARE GOING TO
SIT IN AND WORK OUT THESE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT I
THINK WE'RE ALL LOOKING.
FOR MY HEARING THAT ABSOLUTELY
AND IF YOU'RE NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT WE'LL WE'LL HAVE
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY HOPEFULLY
AND THE COMMITTEE OR THE FLOOR
TO TO ADDRESS WITH AN ADMITTED
THAT.
OKAY THANK [inaudible]
OF THE ALL RIGHT -- BEFORE I
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WANNA.
AGAIN SAY THAT -- I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
IN THIS BILL.
AND I THINK IT HAS THE RIGHT
MOTIVATION IN THE RIGHT GOALS
AND I CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE YOU BE SUCCESSFUL IN DOING
THAT -- IN THE RIGHT WAY.
AND I I DO THINK THAT THE
OPPONENTS HAVE RAISED SOME
CONCERNS THAT ARE MET THAT --
THAT HAVE MERIT TO THEM WE WE'VE
GOT I'VE.
WE HAVE TO CRAFTED CAREFULLY.
SO THAT WE DON'T INADVERTENTLY --
CREATE UNTENDED CONSEQUENCES
WHICH I DON'T THINK YOU WANT TO
SEE AND I I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US HERE WANT TO SEE SO.
I AM SUPPORTIVE OF GIVING ME
THAT OPPORTUNITY THE TIME TO DO
THAT THE BILL WAS FORWARD AND
THAT'S WHAT THESE FORTY AT TODAY.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE SURE THANK
YOU JUST FROM THE FROM THE BIG
PICTURE I I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY
AND I'M GONNA GIVE IT MY
ATTORNEY CARD ACTUALLY BUT BUT
BUT LOOK WHAT I'VE BEEN A LOT OF
COMMITTEES ARE FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENTS OVER TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH YOU KNOW.
BLACK AND WHITE.
HERE I THINK EVERYBODY THE SAME
ROOM AGREES WITH THE CONCEPT OF
OR TRYING.
TO WEED OUT SOME OF THE
PRACTICES WE THINK DON'T BENEFIT
STUDENTS NOR TAXPAYERS.
AND YOU KNOW I'M CONFIDENT THAT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO TO DO SO AND
WITH THAT -- RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU RIGHT.
OKAY VERY GOOD.
AND CENTER PAN HAS AS MOVE THE
BILL -- BUT BEFORE I RECOGNIZE
THAT MOTION THE ME JUST MENTION
IN THE ANALYSIS THERE IS.
SOME QUESTIONS RAISED ON THE
ISSUE OF THE EXEMPTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SO I DO WANT
TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO WITH THE
BILL DOES MOVE FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT.
THAT ISSUE -- AND MAKE SURE
THERE'S A GOOD RATIONALE FOR FOR
OF PROVIDING THAT EXEMPTION.
WITHOUT ALL RECOGNIZED MOTIONS
CENTER PANDA TO PASS TO
EDUCATION.
AS THE PASSES EDUCATION
COMMITTEE GLAZER HI GLAZER I'D
CHIANG.
ARCHULETA HI ARCHULETA AYE DODD
[inaudible]
GALGIANI.
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
AND HI CAN I WILK.
I READ A WHOLE THAT WOULD PUT
THAT BILL AND CALL.
OUT FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
I SEE THAT -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO HAS BEEN SITTING
PATIENTLY THE ONE INVITE HER UP
2% ITEM NUMBER.
TEN ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE.
NO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY ON
A. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN AN ACT
RELATING TO THE ADVERTISING OF
ON LICENSE CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF
FOR HELPING US WITH PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WHICH WOULD REMOVE
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION FROM
THIS BILL.
I THIS AMENDMENT WOULD LEAVE THE
PROVISIONS.
OF THE BILL TO BE ENFORCED BY
THE STATE'S ATTORNEY'S ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR
BY CERTAIN CITY AND COUNTY
PROSECUTORS.
AS YOU KNOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BEGAN ISSUING
LICENSES AT THE BEGINNING OF
LAST YEAR FOR CANNABIS
BUSINESSES TO OPERATE IN THE
STATE.
DESPITE SOME SUCCESSES DURING
THE FIRST YEAR AND A HALF OF ACT.
AND A HALF OF ALL LEGAL SALES
THE BLACK MARKET HAS CONTINUED
TO FLOURISH DRIVING DOWN LEGAL
SALES.
RESEARCH AND STUDIES HAVE
ESTIMATED THAT AS MUCH AS 80% OF
THE CAMERAS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
IS DONE VIA THE UNDERGROUND
MARKET -- IN ADDITION TO
DWINDLING TAX REVENUES THE
UNDERGROUND MARKET PRESENTS
SERIES PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH THREATS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THE CANNABIS PRODUCTS SOLD AT
THESE LOCATIONS DOES NOT NEED
ESTABLISH QUALITY STANDARDS AND
THE BATES.
STATE TESTING COME FOR COMBAT IN
THE UNDERGROUND MARKET IS A KEY
POLICY GOAL FOR THE LEGISLATURE
THIS YEAR AS WE WORK TO
IMPLEMENT PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FOUR THIS BILL HERE TODAY
WILL TARGET THE BLACK MARKET BY
CRACKING DOWN ON ANY SPORTS ON A
SPECIFIC PROBLEM.
THE ADVERTISING OF ILLEGAL
CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
CERTAIN PLATFORMS HAVE BEEN WELL
DOCUMENTED WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PRACTICE OF ADVERTISING ILLEGAL
OPERATIONS FOR PROFIT.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN WILL
CREATE CIVIL PENALTIES FOR
ENTITIES WOULD DECIDE TO
ADVERTISING LEGAL OPERATIONS IN
EXCHANGE FOR PROFIT.
AS A AS A LEGISLATURE WE CANNOT
SAY THAT WERE TAKING THE
CANNABIS BLACK MARKET SERIOUSLY
IF WE ALLOW THE UNDERGROUND
PROMOTION AN ADVERTISEMENT OF A
LEGAL BUSINESSES TO EXIST
WITHOUT CONSEQUENCE.
WE KNOW THAT THESE
ADVERTISEMENTS TRIED BUSINESSES
TOWARDS HE LEGAL OPERATORS AND
MUST FIND A WAY TO RESTRICT THIS
PRACTICE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY AND I WILL NOW
TURN THE MIKE OVER TO OUR
SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS WITH ME
TODAY HAVE MARTIN KING HAD I NOT
BE TOLD TO RECALL.
GET UP FROM THE CHAIR MEMBERS
MARIN BUT NOW WE HAVE THE NET
CAM AS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
OUR LEGAL BUSINESSES HAVE
SUFFERED -- WE CONTIENEN LAY OFF
WORKERS AS WE CAN'T COMPETE WITH
THEY LEGAL MARKET CONTINUES TO
THRIVE.
ON WE SEE THAT.
IN ANY OF YOUR DISTRICTS YOU
WANT SOMEONE AYE PLATFORM TO YOU
WILL SEE A SOME.
DELIVERY COMPANIES AND LICENSEES
THAT ARE NOT LICENSE OP PROP
SIXTY FOUR WAS WRITTEN IN A WAY
WHERE PENALTIES ARE DIRECTED OUR
LICENSEES FROM CULTIVATORS TO
OUT. TO AYE DISPENSARIES THERE'S
NOTHING THE MENTIONS STATE LEGAL
ACTIVITY BY ONLINE PLATFORMS OR
THIRD PARTIES HI THIS IS THAT
THE FIRST STEP IN THAT DIRECTION.
WE WE NEED THIS AS WE CONTINUE
TO WHY THEY OFF WORKERS SWITCH
IN THE SENSE MEANS.
THE BAND CAN I DON'T HAVE TO
SIGN A PEACE AGREEMENT BUT WE DO
CONTINUE TO DO SO -- BUT WE
ASKED WE ASK FOR A FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ADD THIS IS CRUCIAL THE
SYSTEM CURRENTLY NEEDS
IMPROVEMENT THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ABOUT --
TO RECALL AND HELP THE UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS
LITERACY SKILLS ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL -- I THINK THE POINT
TO TELL MR PANETTA MADE OUR
THIRTY WE AGREE WITH THEM I
WOULD JUST ADD.
THAT THE U. OF C. W.'S BEEN
INVOLVED WITH -- WITH CANNABIS
IN CALIFORNIA FROM THE OUTSET.
WE BELIEVE THAT -- IT HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO BE AN IMPORTANT
INDUSTRY IN A GROWING INDUSTRY
CALIFORNIA CERTAINLY HOWEVER.
WE ARE ADVOCATING TO ASSURE THAT.
THE JOBS THAT ARE CREATED
THROUGH THE INDUSTRY ARE MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS WOULD COULD PAIN.
WITH GOOD PAYING GOOD WAGES
COULD BENEFITS.
ALLOW PEOPLE TO MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES.
THE MARKET CURRENTLY HAS BEEN
UNDERCUT BY A LICENSE OPERATORS
WHO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGE
WHEN IT COMES COSTS.
THAT OUGHT TO PAY THEY DON'T PAY
THE LICENSING FEE THE LOCAL TO
THE TESTING THEY DON'T PAY TAXES.
THEY CERTAINLY DON'T PLAY THEIR
EMPLOYEES FOR WAGE SO THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WILL HELP.
US HELP THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
COMBAT OF ILLICIT MARKET PLACE
WITHOUT RESPECTING US FROM I
LIKE YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PLEASE
COME ON UP AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
ON A LOT OF IN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CAN REST
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE
LEGACY OF CREAMS ON BEHALF OF
EASE STARTS THEY WE SUPPORT THE
BILL AND WE THINK OF THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF FOR ALL OF THE
WORK THAT THEY HAVE DONE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF COOLEY THEM VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DONNA SITES REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE SUPPORT THE BILL
OR WORKING WITH THE MEMBERS
OFFICE AWESOME CLARIFY IN IN ITS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PERSONAL CLOSE HERE ON BEHALF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND FORT.
THANK YOU. TO BRING A VENDOR
COME BEHALF OF BERKELEY PATIENTS
GROUP IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I HUNGER FOR LEASE ON BEHALF OF
SANTA ANA KIND OF ASSOCIATION.
UNITED MEDICAL MARK MARIJUANA
COALITION SAN FRANCISCO CANNABIS
RETAILERS ALLIANCE LONG BEACH
COLLECTIVE ASSOCIATION WHICH
OTHER VALLEY CANNABIS ALLIANCE
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THIRTY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IT'S GOING FORWARD
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GEORGE
MILLER ON BEHALF OF WEED MAPS
AND IN OPPOSITION AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN FIRST I WANT TO START
WITH.
AN APOLOGY FOR MY LETTER OF
OPPOSITION WHICH I THOUGHT THAT
THE OPERATED PRIMARILY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROMOTING OR
DISSEMINATING INFORMATION
LANGUAGE.
I CHARACTERIZE IT AS A BLATANT
ATTEMPT BY THE SPONSORS TO
MINIMIZE OUR OPPOSITION FROM
MANY AND I'VE IT INTERNET.
ADVERTISING PLATFORMS ARE
CURRENTLY ADVERTISE ON LICENSE
CANISTERS RETAILERS.
THIS MORNING IN READING THE
ANALYSIS APPARENTLY IT WAS A
DRAFTING OVERSIGHT THAT
APPARENTLY ALL THE ENTITIES.
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE INCLUDED IN
HERE I THINK I'VE GIVEN MANY OF
YOU THIS IS ABOUT NINETY PAGES.
OF CANNABIS ADVERTISEMENTS FROM
UNLICENSED ENTITIES IN ADDITION
TO BEING ON WE'D MAPS THAT ARE
ON YELP AND BEING IN YAHOO AND
GOOGLE -- IN ANY EVENT IF IT WAS
DRAFTING OVERSIGHT I APOLOGIZE.
FOR ME MY CALLING IT A BLATANT
ATTEMPT TO MINIMIZE OPPOSITION.
ALSO I THINK THAT IN AN OUNCE IS
IT IT DISCUSSES SAW SECTION TWO
THIRTY OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
DECENCY ACT -- THIS BILL WILL BE
GOING TO ANOTHER COMMUNITY WHERE
I THINK THE FOCUS MORE ON THAT
BUT ASSUMING JUST FOR SAKE OF
ARGUMENT THAT.
IT DID NOT APPLY I THINK THERE'S
SOME THINGS THAT NEED TO HAPPEN
AT THE BUREAU BEFORE.
THE BILL CAN BE MEANINGFULLY --
COMPLIED WITH AND THAT IS.
LICENSE LISTINGS -- NEED TO BE.
ACCURATE AND HAVE INCLUDED DOING
BUSINESS AS CURRENTLY THE BCC
ONLY LISTEN NAME OF THE LICENSE
HOLDER NOT THE NAME UNDER WHICH
THE RETAILERS OPERATING SO OFTEN
TIMES.
YOU WILL HAVE A LICENSED ENTITY
BUT IT'S OUR IT'S HARD TO FIND
LICENSE NUMBER BECAUSE YOU'LL BE
LOOKING UP UNDER.
YOU KNOW A NAME OF A BUSINESS
BUT THE LICENSE HOLDER IS --
STEPHEN JOHN -- SO THAT NEEDS TO
BE UPDATED WE'RE ALSO SEEING
DELAYS WISHING TO LACE UP TO
EIGHTY EIGHT DAYS FROM THE TIME
THAT AN ENTITY IS ISSUED A
LICENSE. TO THE TIME THAT IT IS
ACTUALLY ON THE BUREAU'S WEBSITE --
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO BE ASKED TO
TRY AND MAKE SURE THAT.
ONLY LICENSE ENTITIES ARE
ADVERTISING ON WHETHER IT'S WE'D
MAPS CRAIGSLIST YELP GOING THE
OPERATE NOW YOU'LL PULL UP A TON
OF ADVERTISEMENTS YOU WON'T FIND
ANY LICENSE NUMBERS -- IT NEEDS
TO BE ACCURATE AND TIMELY.
AS WELL AS WELL AS THEY NEED TO
HAVE THE ACCURATE ADDRESSES --
THE READER FOR SECOND THOUGHT
NOT HAVING THE ACTUAL LOCATION A
RETAILER INHIBITS OUR ABILITY TO
CROSS REFERENCE FOR LICENSE
ACCURACY.
SINCE THE PHYSICAL LOCATION
ADDRESSES WHAT IS USED TO
IDENTIFY THE RETAILER ON
PLATFORMS.
SO I THINK THERE'S SOME
WORKABILITY ISSUES WITH THE BILL --
AGAIN.
IN OUR LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HOPEFULLY
CLARIFYING THE DRAFTING ERR THAT
WAS THE PLACE EARLIER THAT TOM.
ONLY CARVED OUT THE NON
PRIMARILY WE'D ENTITIES SUCH AS
CRAIGSLIST YELP OTHERS FROM THE
ADVERTISING HE'S FROM THE
DISCLOSURE PEACE BUT NOT THE
ADVERTISING PIECE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
MILLER ANY OTHER -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION COME TO THE MIKE.
BUT SHEPHERD ON BEHALF OF THE
CAL ASIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION.
MICHELLE KNEW WHEN CALIFORNIA'S
PANIC CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JIM YOU WERE WITH A
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION -- WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION.
ON THE BILL A WE WERE OPPOSED TO
ON IT NISHA VERSION OF THE BILL
BUT WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT --
SECTION THREE OF THE BILL WHICH
IMPOSES STRICT LIABILITY ON A
PUBLISHER. FOR THE INCLUSION OF
AN ADVERTISEMENT THAT DOESN'T
HAVE THE REQUIRED DISCLOSURE
PURSUANT TO THAT SECTION.
ARM EVEN THE INITIAL LACK THE
CREATED THE SCHEMATIC THAT WE
ARE NOW LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW
DIDN'T IMPOSE LIABILITY ON THE
PUBLISHER FOR AN ADVERTISEMENT
THAT FAILED TO ADHERE TO THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE LAW -- IN
THIS FOR THE FIRST TIME WOULD DO
JUST THAT IT WOULD IMPOSE
LIABILITY ON A PUBLISHER.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THE ANOMALY -- WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN GET THERE
BUT JUST WANTED TO MAKE YOU
AWARE OF THAT AND WHERE WE ARE
IN THIS NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR TURN MEMBERS COURTNEY JOHNSON
ON BEHALF OF TECHNOLOGY ONE
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE
OF THE NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE ALSO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
THE BILL AND LOOK FORWARD.
TO FIXING UP ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES I'VE BEEN CREATED WITH --
AMENDMENTS CAME EARLIER BUT
THINK THAT WE CAN GET THERE YOUR
AYE AYE JASON BRYANT'S HUMBY
AFTER THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY
GROWERS ALLIANCE THE CAMPUS
DISTRIBUTIONS ASSOCIATION
RUSSIAN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I PLEDGE AS BEING OUT OF ORDER
ONE MAKE SURE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ARE OPEN MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
SENATE ARCHULETA YES -- I'D LIKE --
TO CONGRATULATE LITERALLY
CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK
THE INDUSTRY NEEDS.
A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD I THINK
THE INDUSTRY NEEDS TO BE
FORTHCOMING AND DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
AND IF THIS IS GOING TO OPEN THE
DOOR TO START THINGS ON THE
RIGHT WAY THIS IS YET LICENSING
SHOULD BE PUBLICIZED.
IF YOU'RE LEGAL -- YOU HAVE THE
LICENSE TO DO IT THE LICENSE
NUMBER OF PUT IN THE WEBSITE
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE HOWEVER
THEY ADVERTISED FOR THE CONSUMER
TO KNOW THEY'RE DEALING WITH
SOMEONE AND I URGE YU -- TO
TAKE THIS TO THE NEXT LEVEL NOT
BE WE'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH
YOU AND I'D LOVE TO SEE.
A BIG POSTER ON THE DOOR THAT
SAYS THIS IS IN A STATUS WITHIN
THE LAW.
WITHIN THE EMPLOYMENT -- WHAT
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE AND THERE'S
JUST SO MANY THINGS THAT WE HAVE
TO LEVEL THIS THING OFF?
AND SO I SUPPORT YOU FOR DOING
THIS AND I KNOWLEDGE THE FACT
THAT I THINK WE'RE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AND I JOB AND I BOTH MY
CERTAINLY WAS SUPPORT.
GOOD THANK YOU A CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU AND FIRST OF ALL
SUMMER RUBIO FISHY WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH WITH THIS I
AM CURIOUS ABOUT THE OPPOSITION
FROM I GUESS THE PUBLISHERS AND
TECHNET ABOUT -- ABOUT ISSUE
ROUND.
BUT IT'S SO JUST TO CLARIFY THE
BILL HAS CERTAIN CONDITIONS
UNDER WHICH SOMEONE CAN
ADVERTISE IT THE LICENSE NUMBER
SOME OTHER THINGS -- SO I GET
THE PEOPLE DON'T HAVE LIABILITY.
FOR PUBLISHING ADVERTISEMENTS
THAT DON'T BUT IS THERE AT THE
OTHER SO I GUESS MAYBE I CAN ASK
THEM TO COME UP.
IT'S VIED CLARIFY A SO IS THERE
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE S. IN
THIS CONVERSATIONS WHAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE PANELS PENALTY SO I
GUESS A SECURED YOU DON'T WANT
LIABILITY FOR THAT IS IS.
IS THERE ANOTHER PENALTY IN THE
BILL.
FOR VIOLATING THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL THAT SO BECOMES LAW IN
REGARDS TO THE ADVERTISEMENT ANY.
I'M JUST TRYING TO CLARIFY WHAT
THE ISSUE IS AROUND SO THERE'S
SOME REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY'RE
ASKING THAT THERE BE AN
ADVERTISING TO SURE THAT THE
PERSON ADVERTISING IS.
A LEGITIMATE LEGAL.
BOB YEAH I GUESS RETAILER
WHATEVER WHOSE ADVERTISING SO
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERN ABOUT -- FOR THE
PUBLISHERS -- EIGHTEEN IN TERMS
OF WELL IF YOU MEET THE
PROVISIONS YOU'RE FINE WRITERS
OR ISSUE ROUND THAT.
THERE MAY BE -- AND I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR THE WASHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT -- RENDON'S
JENSEN -- REPRESENTS BUT WITH
REGARD TO NEWSPAPERS ARE TWO
DIFFERENT.
WAYS THAT -- THESE
ADVERTISEMENTS CAN APPEAR ON A
NEWSPAPER'S WEBSITE TOO
PROGRAMMATIC ADVERTISING WITH
WHICH NEWSPAPER HAS.
VERY LITTLE CONTROL OVER WHAT
GOES INTO THAT SPACE THAT SOLD
IT'S ALL DONE BY -- AND ADD
EXCHANGE AND I'M BY THE
ADVERTISER.
AND SO THE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
JUST CRIED SO WE'RE SO THERE'S
THE ADS IN WHICH THE NEWSPAPER
ACCEPTS AND EITHER PUT SENATE'S
PRINT VERSION ARE IN ITS ONLINE
VERSION HE'S TALKING TEXTUAL YES
RIGHT AND THEN THERE'S THE ADS
THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE SOME CONTRACT
WITH SOMEBODY AND THEY THEY'RE
JUST STICKING IT OUT I MEAN
ANYBODY WHO HAS A WEBSITE THAT
ALLOWS THAT'S CORRECT BANNER ADS
WHATEVER DOES KIND OF THING SO
THE ISSUE JUST WITH THOSE OR IS
IT ALSO WITH THE ONES IN WHICH
YOU.
DIRECTLY CONTROLLED IT'S BOTH --
BECAUSE IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY
UNFAIR TO IMPOSE LIABILITY ON A
PUBLISHER WHO HAS VERY LITTLE
CONTROL OVER.
THE CONTENT OF THAT AD AND FOR
FOR THE TYPE OF AD THAT WAS
KNOWN AS A ARE NOT PROBLEMATIC
BUT CONTEXTUALIZED SIZING --
PUBLISHERS DON'T.
HAVE THE THE TIME TO GO OUT AND
FACT CHECKED EVERY SINGLE THING
WE RELY ON THE ADVERTISERS TO
ENSURE THAT THE ADVERTISEMENT IS
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW.
AND SO THAT'S WHY IT'S OKAY SO
SO BASICALLY YOU'RE CONCERNED
HERE IS IS THAT IF SOMEONE
FALSIFIES INFORMATION BUT YOU
YOU WILL DO THE REVIEW AND SAY
YOU GOT THE LIGHT YOU MEET ALL
THE REQUIREMENTS CORRECT BUT
YEAR JUST CONCERNED THAT.
IF THEY FALSIFY INFORMATION NOW
YOU'RE LIABLE RIGHT CORRECT SO
OKAY [inaudible]
SO.
AND THEN IN TERMS OF THE OTHER
TYPES OF ADVERTISING I GUESS
SOMEONE SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE IF
YOU'RE NOT WHO RECOUNTED SO
MAYBE I'LL.
BRING BACK THE AUTHORED SPONSORS
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU THINK IS
ADDRESSABLE FIX YEAH AND WE WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS IN THE
ORIGINAL VERSION OF THE BILL
THEY WERE IN OPPOSITION.
AND AS DISCUSSED AND I'M NOT A
AN ONLINE GIRL HOWEVER WHEN YOU
DO AN ADVERTISEMENT -- YOU
REQUEST CERTAIN INFORMATION FROM
THE ADVERTISER INCLUDING SAY A
CREDIT CARD NUMBER AND A COMMENT
THAT WE DIDN'T COMMITTEE THEN IS
IF YOU'RE REQUIRING ALL OF THESE
THINGS AND ADD ANOTHER LINE TO
REQUIRE THE BUSINESS LICENSE.
NOW -- WE WORKED WITH THEM AND
GOT THEM OFF THE OPPOSITION AND
NOW THEY'RE NEUTRAL -- SOUL WE
FELT THAT WE WERE WORKING WITH
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS BY.
AND THEN ONLINE WORLD AND EVEN
IN THAT -- PRINT WORLD WHEN YOU
PRESENT AN ADVERTISEMENT OR
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU
ASKED WHAT SIZE AND ALL THAT SO
I THINK IT.
WOULD BE FAIR TO JUST ADD
ANOTHER LINE SAY WHAT IS THE
LICENSE NUMBER NOW THE OTHER
ISSUES CAN BE DEALT WITH BY.
THE FACT THAT THEY SAY THAT IT'S
UNFAIR.
THAT WERE REQUIRING THEM TO ADD
ONE MORE LINE TO SOMETHING IS
REALLY NOT AN ARGUMENT IN MY
KIDS BECAUSE THE GOAL OF THIS IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT ENTITIES LIKE THEM ARE
WORKING WITH LEGAL FOLKS YOU
KNOW WE DON'T WANT -- TO ALLOW
THE LEGAL MARKET TO SATURATE AND
THEM TURN A BLIND EYE EITHER AND
SO I THINK THERE'S IN ORDER TO
BE BE A RESPONSIBLE ADVERTISER
YOU ALSO HAVE TO HAVE.
TALENT IS OUR CHECKS AND
BALANCES AND HE STATED THAT THE
FOLLOWING THE LAW WILL IF THIS
BECOMES LAW THEN THAT'S BE JUST
ANOTHER.
OB PORTION THAT THEY HAVE TO
FOLLOW AND IT TO ME IT DOES NOT
SEEM UNREASONABLE -- TO ADD THE
LICENSE NUMBER OKAY AND AND A
YES. FIVE PERSON HIS GAME PAID
FOR THE AD SHOULD BE THE ONE
WHO'S LIABLE RIGHT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL I MEAN THAT
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL I URGE YOU
TO WORK WITH THE FOLKS WHO HAVE
CONCERNS THEIR DEFENSE CLAIMS
THAT OUT BUT I OKAY ABSOLUTELY
SENATOR -- WHEN WE STARTED -- IN
THE ASSEMBLY WE WENT THROUGH A
LOT AND WHEN SPECIFICALLY WITH
THE PUBLISHERS WERE IN
OPPOSITION THEY REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO NEUTRAL BECAUSE WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM.
ALL RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU THANKS
MUCH SO -- I I GUESS I'LL LET ME
CALL EVERYONE'S ATTENTION TO THE
ANALYSIS ON PAGE SEVEN UNDER
PENALTIES AND THE POTENTIAL FOR
APPEAL.
BECAUSE IN THEIR THE SUGGESTION
FROM MY EXCELLENT CONSULTANTS
ARE THAT THE AUTHOR SHOULD
CONTINUE WORK WITH LICENSING
AUTHORITIES AND STAKEHOLDERS. TO
INSURE THAT THE AMOUNT OF THE
FINE IS APPROPRIATE FOR THE
VIOLATION.
BY CONSIDERING THE GRAVITY OF
THE VIOLATION.
THE GOOD FAITH OF THE LICENSEE
OR THE PERSON.
THE HISTORY OF PREVIOUS
VIOLATIONS AND WHETHER AN APPEAL
PROCESS SHOULD BE OUTLINED BASED
ON THESE FACTORS.
AND YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
YES ABSOLUTELY AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN AND AND YOUR
STAFF BECAUSE THAT WAS A A POINT
OF DISCUSSION THAT WE HAD LAST
WEEK TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME FOLKS
THAT ARE UNAWARE AND WE WANT TO
HONOR THAT AND THEN BUT THEN
ONCE THEY KNOW THEN YOU KNOW AND
THEN AFTER THAT THEN THE
PENALTIES -- DO APPLY AND I
THINK IT'S FAIR I IN EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO IF YOU KNOW YOU YOU
WERE YOU DID IT NOW THAN YOU DID
NOT BUT NOW THIS ASSURES THAT
ONCE YOU KNOW IF YOU CONTINUE TO
VIOLATE THE LAW WILLINGLY.
BECAUSE AT THIS POINT YOU'RE
WILLIG -- TO CONTINUE THEN
THAT'S WHERE WHERE IT COMES IN
AND I AGAIN I WANT TO THINK
THAT'S THE STAFF THEY WERE GREAT
AND WORKING WITH ME ON THAT
PROVISION.
IN THE MEDIA ENHANCE THAT THAT
OBSERVATION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR WORK AND CONTINUE YOUR
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK IN
THIS AREA IS THAT.
BECAUSE WE'VE TAKEN OUT THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION HE
REQUIRES A PUBLIC ENTITY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO ENGAGE
AND AND ENFORCING THIS AND I
THINK THAT IT HAS MY CONFIDENCE
THAT THEY'RE NOT GONNA DO IT FOR
A SILLY VIOLATIONS.
THAT IT'S GONNA HAVE TO BE
SOMETHING OF SUBSEQUENT AGAINST
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO MAKE
CHOICES ALL THE TIME.
AS TO WHAT THEY AND FORCE AND
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY LOOKING AT THE
SERIOUS BAD ACTORS HERE IN THIS
BILL WELL IN MY HOPE IS THAT YOU
KNOW THERE'S SOME OMPANIES THAT
ARE.
DRIVING THROUGH THIS THE THEY
WERE YOU KNOW I SAW THE
POSSIBILITIES -- THAT ARE YOU
KNOW ALL OF THE JOBS THAT THEY
WERE CREATING AND YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING THAT THEY WERE
CREATING AND SO I WAS VERY
EXCITED FOR THEM.
AND FOR ME FOR AN ORGANIZATION
LIKE THAT TO STILL CONDONE THE
LEGAL -- ADVERTISERS I FELT THAT
THEY WERE RESPONSE WHEN THEY
TOLD ME THAT THEY WERE
RESPONSIBLE AND THEY WANTED TO
DO.
RIGHT BY THE COMMUNITY RIGHT BY
THE WORKERS AND I BELIEVE THEM
AND SOLD SOLD THIS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A BIG OF
REACH BECAUSE IF THEY WANT TO BE.
GOOD STEWARDS OF OF OF THEIR
THIS NEW -- BUSINESS AND THEY
WERE GOING TO COMPLY BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THAT THEY STILL WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADVERTISE. TO GET THE
ADVERTISEMENT DOLLARS FROM LEGAL --
BUSINESSES AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
GOAL I'M NOT TRYING TO SHUT
ANYBODY DOWN DOWN.
I VOTED ON PROP SIXTY FOUR WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT I WAS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAS GOING TO
RECEIVE ALL OF THESE TAX -- TAX
MONIES MY SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO
RECEIVE IT AND SO FOR ME IT'S
JUST GOING -- MAKING SURE THAT
80% OF THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT --
BUT LEGAL.
SOMEHOW.
IN HOPEFULLY THROUGH THIS BILL
START ON UNDERSTANDING THAT DID
THAT WE'RE SERIOUS AND THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE THE THE RESIDENTS PASSED
THIS PROPOSITION SO THAT WE CAN
SEE THE BENEFIT OF OF THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY SO WITH THAT I
THINK I CAN USE THAT IS NOT
LIKELY THAT IS A CLOSE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
GRAY AND AND THEN THE JUST SAY --
THAT I KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME
ANGST BY.
SOME OF THE FOLKS THAT THEY
ENGAGE IN THESE PLATFORMS.
BUT I I DON'T UNDER MY READING
OF THIS BILL AND YOUR COMMITMENT
TO TRY -- TO WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
DO PICKY LITTLE THINGS WHERE
WE'RE TRYING TO GO AFTER SERIOUS
ABUSE AND THIS IS IN A SPACE OF
GREAT SERIOUSNESS TO OUR STATE.
THIS LEGALIZATION ISSUE THE
VOTERS HAVE SPOKEN I GET THAT --
TO BUT WE HAVEN'T CURTAIL THE
ILLEGAL USE.
OF CANNABIS IN OUR STATE AND
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPLEXITY AND
THERE'S LOTS OF PROBLEMS -- AND
THIS IS ONLY GOING AFTER A PART
OF THE ISSUE AND WE HAVE MUCH
MORE WORK TO DO -- AND AND AND
OUT BUT I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
GOOD WORK.
I THINK THAT YOU'VE TRIED TO
FIND THAT RIGHT BALANCE I THINK
YOU HAVE DONE IT IN THIS BILL.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO TRY -- TO
NOT DO ANYTHING IN IT BURDEN
HERE WE REALLY HAVE TO GIVE A
CLEAR AT TARGET IN MIND I THINK
IT'S THE RIGHT.
ONE THANK YOU WITHOUT LOOKING
FOR A MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION
CENTER ARCHULETA.
ON THE BILL WITH THAT SECRETARY
WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE CHIANG ARCHULETA.
OUR TO LET AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
HILL.
HILL I'D LEYVA.
SORRY I BY.
HAND.
AND I WELL [inaudible]
OKAY.
RIGHT THAT BILL CURRENTLY ENJOYS
THE ENOUGH SUPPORT TO GET APPLE
WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI I'D LIKE TO INVITE UP FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW THIS IS --
ITEM ONE IN YOUR AGENDA.
THE BILL.
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT WELCOME.
SURE IF IF I MIGHT -- WOULD YOU
CONSIDER THE UP ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT FIRE BIG SIZE
AND FOR EACH OF THE OTHER.
EXPERT WITNESSES WHO MIGHT HAVE
TO LEAVE.
OKAY MIGHT THAT BE POSSIBLE
RIGHT -- WILL WITH THE
COMMITTEES ACCEPTANCE OF THAT
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
AGAIN WOULD APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS A
BILL TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
NON PHARMACOLOGICAL OPTIONS
BEING PROVIDED TO ADD TO ADDRESS
IN.
TACKLE THIS OF YOUR CRISIS -- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WOULD BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING TACKLE
THIS MAJOR ISSUE AND WITH
RESPECT AS RIVAL CAN HAVE.
OTHER ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY THEIR WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS A
DAVID BENEVENTO MY DOCTOR OF
CHIROPRACTIC.
I PRACTICED IN FOLSOM CALIFORNIA
BEEN THERE SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE I'M ALSO PAST PRESIDENT
THE CALIFORNIA CARE PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION IN 200-018-0009.
SO THANK YOU FOR LET ME
TESTIFYING.
NON FICTIONAL CITY CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO HAVE A FIXABLE OVER
YOUR PROBLEM.
THAT IS STILL KILLING HUNDREDS
AND MORE LIKELY THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE EACH YEAR. FOR THE LAST
OFFICIAL DATA WE HAVE IS FROM.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT PUTS THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS IN ALMOST TWO
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THAT YEAR.
IT IS NOT JUST THOSE DEATHS BUT
THOUSANDS OF LIVES AND FAMILIES
THAT HIM.
HAVE BEEN RUINED.
IT IS ALSO ALL THE CHILDREN HAVE
LOST A PARENT AS WELL AS A AS
FOR THE PAIN DISABILITY AND
FINANCE RUINED BECAUSE OF THOSE
WHO AVOIDED DEATH BUT NOT THE
ADDICTION.
WITH A. B. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT WE
ARE ASKING YOU TO WORK TO HELP
STOP FEELING THE FINAL OF PEOPLE
BEING GIVEN PRESCRIPTIONS THAT
ARE THE FOUNDATION OF THIS
PROBLEM.
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT WELL FIRST WILL FACILITATE
A COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO HELP
AND DO THIS PROBLEM THROUGH A
MECHANISM THAT IS ALREADY IN
PLACE IN OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
THAT MECHANISM IS FULL WRITTEN
AND VERBAL INFORMED CONSENT.
AS RECOMMENDED BY THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF HEALTH.
AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT WERE
REQUIRED TRANSPARENCY ABOUT THE
FIFTH TOURISTS OF OPIOIDS TO THE
PATIENT.
THROUGH A DISCUSSION AND A
SIGNED CONSENT SO THAT PATIENTS
CAN MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION.
AS A CHIROPRACTOR WE WE ALL WE
ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE INFORMED
CONSENT BEFORE.
DO THE MANIPULATED PROCEDURE ON
A PATIENT IN FACT I JUST HAD A
PATIENT THIS MORNING.
A FIREMAN THAT AND WORKED UP AND
BEFORE I DID THE MANIPULATION
WENT OVER THE YOU KNOW THE PROS
AND CONS OF MANIPULATION.
AND TOOK LESS THAN A MINUTE IT
DOESN'T REALLY TAKE A LOT OF
TIME BUT IT IS IMPORTANT.
ALSO INFORMED CONSENT IS ALL
ABOUT WITH THE ADDED RISK WHAT
WE CONSIDERED A HERE AT RISK.
AND I THINK WE HOPE WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT OPIOIDS CAUSING DEATH
WOULD BE A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
INHERENT RISK.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS BIG RISK HERE.
AND THAT PEOPLE WITH OVER WHAT'S
GOING ON AB EIGHT EIGHT OH ALSO
PUT IN PLACE A REQUIREMENT.
THAT PRESCRIBERS INFORM PATIENTS
THAT EVIDENCE BASED ALTERNATIVES
TO OPIOIDS EXIST INCLUDING
LICENSE NON FARM ARTICLE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
WHAT THE RESEARCHERS TOLD US
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS THAT FOR
PAIN OPIATES ARE GENERALLY NOT
RECOMMENDED?
AND THE NON FORMAL.
LOGICAL PROVIDERS MENTION IN THE
BILL MOST DEFINITELY ARE.
THERE IS NO MANDATE TO FORCE A
PRESCRIBER TO PICK ANY SPECIFIC
PROVIDER OR TO MAKE A DIRECT
REFERRAL ONLY TO ALERT THE
PATIENT ABOUT SEVERAL EVIDENCE
BASED CLASSES OF PROVIDERS THAT
MIGHT BE ABLE TO HELP THEM.
SO IN SUMMARY WE ARE ASKING YOU
TO HAVE.
REQUIRED DOCUMENT THAT PATIENTS
UNDERSTAND WITH THE PRESCRIBER
UNDERSTANDS WHEN THEY'RE BE
GIVEN AN OPIOID.
THEN I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU THAT NEXT WITNESS
JENNIFER SUMMERS WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE MEDICAL BORDERS IN
SUPPORT THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
PRESCRIBERS TO DISCUSS IMPORTANT
INFORMATION ABOUT THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH OPIOIDS OF ALL
PATIENTS.
NOT JUST MINOR PATIENTS IT WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE WRITTEN INFORMED
CONSENT MUST BE INCLUDING THE
PATIENT'S MEDICAL RECORDS WHICH
WILL HELP THE BOARD TO FORCES
BILLS REQUIREMENTS.
THE GROWING OPIOID ABUSE
EPIDEMIC REMAINS A MATTER
CONCERN FOR THE BOARD.
THIS BILL INCREASE EDUCATION FOR
ALL PATIENTS WHICH WILL FOR THE
BOARD'S MISSION OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION IN THE POOREST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YES.
TOM RENT FREE ARM DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND WERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
STEVE KERR TOLD A REPRESENTING
THE INDEPENDENT PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANDREA MCMILLAN REPRESENTING THE
BOARD OF CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
JOHN MOFFITT ON THE HAVE
MEDTRONIC I DON'T KNOW IF YOU AN
IN BETWEEN YEARS NOW OR LATER.
YOU'RE AT THE MICRO I'M HERE.
MEDTRONIC IS SUPPORT IF AMENDED --
WE BELIEVE THAT THE BILL IF IT'S
GONNA INCLUDE THERAPY SHOULD
INCLUDE ALL THERAPIES INCLUDING
IMPLANTABLE DEVICES WE HAVE NO
ISSUES WITH THE DIRECTION THAT
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED THE BILL.
ONLY SUGGESTION WE WOULD MAKE IS
THAT IT BE CHANGED FROM NON
PHARMACOLOGICAL TO NON OPIOIDS
BECAUSE THERE ARE.
SOME FORMAL PHARMACOLOGICAL WITH
IMPLANTABLE DEVICES THAT
DELIVERS A LITTLE BIT OF
MEDICINE EXACTLY WHERE IT'S
NEEDED.
WHICH IS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
OPIOIDS AS WELL SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING
WHATEVER IT IS NOW I'VE BEEN ALL
TOMORROW ON BEHALF OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YOU CAN CLEAR I GUESS I ONE MORE
SPACE TO BE GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MEGAN
ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
I'M WE'RE IN IMPOSING WAS
AMENDED AB POSITION ON THE BILL
WE WANT TO THINK THAT COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS.
AND FOR THE AMENDMENTS REFLECTED
IN THE ANALYSIS.
I AM.
WITHOUT THOSE WE HAVE MOLD MAJOR
CONCERNS ON THE BILL AND EVEN
WITH THOSE THEY'RE STILL A
COUPLE OF CONCERNS LEFT THAT I
WANTED TO ADDRESS.
I AM TWO PIECES IN THE BILL THE
REMAINING BECAUSE OF CONCERN TO
OUR MEMBERS.
THESE A REQUIREMENT THE
PRESCRIBERS DISCUSS NON
PHARMACOLOGICAL TREATMENTS FOR
PAIN REGARDLESS OF THEIR
APPROPRIATENESS TO THE PATIENT
AND THE LANGUAGE THE DRUG%
PRESCRIBER STOP FOR A REFERRAL
TO A NON FARM TREATMENT FOR PAIN
IF APPROPRIATE.
THERE ARE MANY INSTANCES IN
WHICH CHIROPRACTIC TREATMENT
ACUPUNCTURE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AREN'T APPROPRIATE FOR
PATIENTS SUCH AS AFTER MINOR
SURGERY WHICH LEAVES A PATIENT
AND SHORT TERM ACUTE PAIN.
IN THESE CASES THESE NON FARM
TREATMENTS WOULDN'T BE
APPROPRIATE AS THEY SERVE A
GREATER PURPOSE FOR CHRONIC PAIN
A RECURRENT EPISODES OF PAIN.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THESE OPTIONS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR
APPROPRIATENESS AND WITHOUT
EVIDENTIARY SUPPORT TO THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS.
THE BILL ALSO DIRECTS
PRESCRIBERS TO OFFER A REFERRAL
IF APPROPRIATE WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCRETION.
BEING LEFT TO THE PROVIDER THE
WORD REFERRAL IS LARGELY PROBLEM
LARGELY PROBLEMATIC AS A
REFERRAL IS SOMETHING THAT
SPECIFIES A PROVIDER.
AND SIGNIFIES INSURANCE COVERAGE
OF THE FOR TREATMENT.
WITH MANY OF THE SERVICE IS NOT
BEING COVERED BY INSURANCE OUR
REFERRAL WILL PROVIDE A FALSE
RELIANCE ON THE SERVICE BEING
COVERED ONLY FOR THE PATIENT TO
FIND OUT THAT THEIR INSURANCE
DOESN'T COVER THE SERVICE AT ALL.
OR HAS ITS OWN LIMITS ON
COVERAGE WHICH ARE COMPLETELY
UNAFFECTED BY A REFERRAL.
WE WOULD ASK THAT THE WORD
REFERRAL BE STRUCK FROM THE BILL
AND THE MANDATORY DISCUSSION OF
THESE OPTIONS BE CHANGE TO OCCUR
AS APPROPRIATE TO THE PATIENT.
WE WOULD ALSO A HIGHLY DISAGREE
WITH THE PROVISION THAT REQUIRES
AND WRITTEN INFORMED CONSENT IN
THE BILL INFORMED CONSENT IS A
COMPLETELY NEW LEGAL STANDARD.
ON THE DISCUSSION THE BILL WE
HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH WE
SUPPORTED IT LAST YEAR AND A
SIMILAR BILL FOR MINORS WE WOULD
TAKE COURAGE.
EXTENDING THAT TO ADULTS THIS
YEAR THE PROBLEM WITH CALLING IN
INFORMED CONSENT IS THAT NOT
ONLY ARE YOU SAY SIGNIFYING THAT
YOU ARE TAKING ON ALL OF THE
RISKS AND BENEFITS OF THIS
MEDICATION BUT YOU ARE SIGNING
THAT YOU DO THAT JUST AS YOU
WOULD BEFORE SURGERY -- THIS
LEGAL STANDARD WE DON'T BELIEVE
IS APPROPRIATE AND WE WOULD ASK
THAT THE PROVISION ALSO BE
STRUCK.
AS IN THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT'S
WHEN THIS.
INTERNET OFF RESIDENTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND AMERICAN
COLLEGE OBGYN STRYCHNINE.
IN BREVITY.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I GUESS JUST
TO REITERATE.
HER POINTS REGARDING THE
DISCUSSION I THINK YOU HAVE A
PRESCRIBER PARTY'S POSITION ARE
A DETERMINE THE APPROPRIATE
STANDARD OF CARE.
AND THEN WITHIN AFTER -- THEY
TOOK TOMORROW WHAT PROPER CARE
IS FOR THAT PARTICULAR PATIENT
THEY WOULD THEN NEED.
TO DISCUSS SOMETHING THAT THEY
ARE RETURNING WITH MIGHT NOT BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THAT PATIENT'S
CONDITION AND SO WE ASK OUR
DISCUSSION BE DELETED AS WELL AS
THE REFERRAL OPTION AS WELL AND
WE APPRECIATE THE AND THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
WHAT HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR.
ACCEPT THOSE AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE OTHER WAY.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE CANNOT THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN AGREEMENT
WITH THE OTHER TWO PARTIES IN
OPPOSITION -- ARE WE WOULD AS
SEEK THE MOMENTS THAT WERE
SUBMITTED BY COMMITTEE I'M A
SPECIFICALLY FOR DENNIS WE WOULD
SEE THAT -- IT'S NOT ALWAYS A
APPROPRIATE IN MOST CASES NOT
FOR DENTISTS -- ESPECIALLY FOR
ORAL SURGERY OR STRESS
EXTRACTION OF WISDOM TEETH NON
PHARMACOLOGICAL ALTERNATIVES
WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE SO IN --
ALSO SEEK TO HAVE THOSE MOMENTS
TAKEN THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATT ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF KAISER PERMANENTE SAY --
DEFINITELY THINK THE COMMITTEE
ON STAFF ON THE ANALYSIS WE TO
AGREE WITH THE SUGGESTIONS IN
THERE WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED NOW SAYS --
LIKE THE OTHERS SPEAKERS AS WELL
I THINK WE HAVE -- WOOD IF THIS
BILL DOES GET OUT OF COMMITTEE I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEEK WORKING
ON THAT MANDATED REFERRAL -- WE
THINK YOU KNOW THE SHOULD BE A
CASE BY CASE BASIS ON WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S APPROPRIATE.
I TO BE DISCUSSING THE
TREATMENTS BUT WITH OUR STONE
OPPOSE UNLESS THE DECISION THANK
YOU GREAT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARTS SCENE NOW WILL BE THE BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COULD YOU ADDRESS
THE OF THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
IN THE ANALYSIS.
YES IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY IT
IS TO EXTRACT THAT OF THE
WRITTEN INFORMED CONSENT IS THAT
IS THAT ACCURATE THAT'S ONE OF
THEM YES YES IT'S AND THEN THE
THE OTHER -- ONE IT'S ABOUT --
THIS -- CHANGING YOUR SPECIFIC --
NON PHARMACY.
NON PHARMACOLOGICAL TREATMENTS
OF FROM THAT.
SPECIFIC TO A GENERIC -- THAT'S
ON PAGE THIRTY YES YES SO.
AS I UNDERSTAND FROM THAT THE
RECOMMENDED.
A MAN'S OF THOSE TWO FUNCTIONS
ONE IS WITH RESPECT TO RING
INFORMED CONSENT AS YOU JUST
HEARD FROM.
OUR DOCTOR OF CHIROPRACTIC CARE --
THAT IS ALREADY PRACTICED AND TO
BE ABLE TO ENFORCE THIS POLICY.
IS THE DIRECTION WE LIKE TO
HEADED WITH RESPECT TO THE
INFORMED CONSENT IN OTHER WORDS
TO MAINTAIN THAT SO THAT THERE
IS OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE TYPE
OF ENFORCEMENT OTHERWISE.
THERE'S NO TEETH IN THIS THE
WHOLE NOTION OF THE IMPETUS FOR
THIS IS TO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
IS NO CURE CRISIS AND THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE.
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS PRIOR
TO PRESCRIBING THAT THAT -- GOOD
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THAT EVERITT
INFORMED CONSENT PROVIDES THAT
TEETH IN A MECHANISM TO OF GET
THAT ENFORCEMENT THE OTHER THING
YEAH THE SECOND COMPONENT WAS IT
WAS ON THE REFERENCES OF THE
VARIOUS -- THERAPIES ACUPUNCTURE
CHIROPRACTIC CARE PHYSICAL AND
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY AS WELL AS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THAT CORRECT.
THAT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO A STRIKING.
OUT.
HI BUT BUT THAT BUT AS PRESENTED
TO IT IS NOT LIMITED TO SO THOSE
ARE A NUMBER OF VARIOUS OPTIONS
AND I THINK THAT'S IN FACT THE
INTENT.
AND I THINK YOU MAY HAVE SHARED
WITH ME THAT YOU HAD SOME
CONCERN ABOUT NARROWING SUCH A
DEFINITIVE -- SEGMENT BUT RATHER
I THINK THAT'S ACTUALLY THE
INTENT TO HELP.
DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE ARE
NUMBER OF THERAPIES THAT EXIST.
TO COUNTER THIS OF YOUR CRISIS
SO IT IS NOT LIMITED -- TO THESE
VARIOUS THERAPIES -- SO THAT'S
OF THE INTENT OF THE LEGISLATION --
BUT THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF
THIS OKAY SO THE A BIRD THAT THE
BILL AS AS AS AS IT'S PRESENTED
YES OKAY VERY GOOD.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU AND SUMMER LIVE FREE
SHEET THE YOUR EFFORT TO TRY TO
ADDRESS -- THE OVER USE OF
OPIOIDS I GUESS MY CONCERN AND I
AND I HOPE THAT YOU DO TAKE THE
AND THEN IT'S SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
IS THAT CERTAINLY WELL WE CAN
TALK ABOUT VARIOUS DIFFERENT
OPTIONS.
WELL THIS WAS A NOT ALL PAIN IS
THE SAME -- ONE CAN EVEN ARGUE
THAT BECAUSE THIS IS FOCUSED ON
NON PHARMACOLOGICAL -- THERE ARE
MANY OTHER PHARMACOLOGICAL.
TREATMENTS FOR PAIN ASIDE FROM
OPIOIDS AND IN FACT -- MAY
CONVERSATIONS IS THAT -- WE
SHOULD PERHAPS BE USING THOSE
INSTEAD -- CERTAINLY I THINK
YELL NON PHARMACOLOGICAL
TREATMENTS ARE HELPFUL BUT
PROVIDING A I MEAN WHAT AM ZERO
PATIENT HAVE A PARTICULAR TYPE
OF PAIN WE HEARD FROM THE
DENTIST RIGHT I MEAN YOU MIGHT
HEAD OF WISDOM TOOTH TAKEN OUT
YOU COULD HAVE PAIN FROM.
YOUR BACK PAIN WHERE -- WHERE
SOMETHING NAY BUT YOU MAY HAVE
PAIN POST SURGICAL YOU HAVE LOTS
OF DIFFERENT POTENTIAL SOURCES
OF PAIN AND JUST GIVING EVERYONE
A LIST OF?
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT MAY NOT US
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE FOR THE
PAIN THAT THEY HALF BECAUSE WHEN
WE'RE SEEING A PATIENT WHERE.
THEY'RE NOT SAYING OH I JUST
HAVE PAIN THEY HAVE A VERY
SPECIFIC FORM OPINION MAY HAVE
HEADACHE THAT'S WHY THEY'RE HERE
THEY MAY HAVE POST SURGICAL PAIN
ETCETERA.
AND NOT ALL THESE NECESSARILY
APPLY FOR EXAMPLE PHYSICAL
THERAPY CAN BE SOMETHING VERY
GOOD FOR MUSCULOSKELETAL PAIN.
ALRIGHT BUT IF THAT'S NOT MUSCO
SKELETAL WHERE WE BRING IT UP I
MEAN THAT CONFUSES PATIENTS
PATIENTS ARE LIKE I MEAN THEY
WHAT.
THAT'S WHY THEY WANT TAILORED
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THEIR
STICKLER SITUATION AND I AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT -- I
FIND THAT PARTICULARLY
TROUBLESOME BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS
IS NOW WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
WE'RE GONNA POSED BY LAW WE TO
TELL DOCTORS WHAT THEY HAVE TO
SAY.
AND THEY HAVE TO BASICALLY GO
OUT AND TELL.
GIVE PATIENTS OPTIONS THAT THEY
DON'T FEEL ARE ACTUALLY
APPROPRIATE FOR THEM GIVEN THE
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD THIS
KIND OF CONVERSATION AROUND
OTHER AREAS AS WELL -- RANGING
FROM YOU KNOW SO NO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH TO OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
AND I THINK WE JUST GOT TO BE
VERY CAREFUL ABOUT -- NOT.
TELLING DOCTORS TO FORCE THEM TO
SAY THINGS THAT THEY DON'T
BELIEVE IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
PATIENTS.
AND ARDEN IS AN APPROPRIATE FOR
PATIENTS PATIENTS SO IT'S ONLY
THERE ARE PARTICULAR ROLES FOR
DIFFERENT YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE
THINGS -- FOR PARTICULAR
SITUATIONS BUT TO HAVE THEM
REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH THE WHOLE
LIST.
EVEN IF IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE FOR
THE PAGE I THINK THIS CREATES
CONFUSION AND AND CAN BE
MISLEADING FOR PATIENTS AND SO --
I IT'S EIGHT YEAH I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT EIGHT AND
THEN THE NEXT STEP IS REFERRAL
AND AGAIN WE HEARD SOME ISSUES
ABOUT THAT BUT I JUST WANT.
TO RAISE THAT CAUTION APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTING THAT WE
REMOVE THAT SORT OF SPECIFICITY
BECAUSE I THINK AGAIN.
THAT'S WHY YOU GO TO HEALTH
OFFICIALS WILL GO TO BY THE WAY
A PHYSICIAN OR GO TO A
CHIROPRACTOR WE GO TO THE AT ALL
A NURSE PRACTITIONER OR PA OR
ANY OTHER OUR LICENSE
PROFESSIONALS ARE PHYSICAL
THERAPIST.
WE WE EXPECT THEM TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS BASED ON
PROFESSIONAL STANDARD OF CARE
THAT ARE TAILORED TO THE PATIENT
THAT YOU'RE SAYING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HE CENTER PAN CENTER ARCHULETA
YES A QUESTION FOR DR -- YOU
SAID YOU HAD SEEN A PATIENT
FIREFIGHTER THIS MORNING.
AND AFTER YOU YOU DISCUSS.
BUT YOU WERE GOING TO AND SO ON
IF YOU HAVEN'T SIGNED ANYTHING
YES YOU DID YES IT'S REQUEST
BOTH WRITTEN AND ORAL CONSENT
WRITTEN IN AN ORAL SO YOU
DISCUSSED A RISK AND HE RECEIVED
A PAMPHLET THAT I'M SORT SIGNED
FOR IT.
YES WE HAVE A DOCUMENT THAT LIST
ALL THE PROCEDURES AND DISCUSS
WITH THEM WHAT I WAS GOING TO DO
WITH THEM AND HE SIGNED OFF AND
I WENT AHEAD AND TREATED HIM YES.
BUT LET'S BE CLEAR THERE THAT --
THAT'S A REQUIREMENT THE BOARD
OF CHIROPRACTIC.
OF MADE UP OF YOUR PROFESSIONALS
HAVE DECIDED THAT THEY WANTED TO
REQUIRE THAT WASN'T SOMETHING
THAT THE STATE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED IS THAT RIGHT.
I BELIEVE SO CORRECT OKAY SO ARE
YOU AWARE OF ANY OTHER
PRESCRIPTION.
DRUG THAT REQUIRES THIS TYPE OF
INFORMED WRITTEN CONSENT.
IN AND ANY ANYTHING THAT WE DO.
AND NOT ON A DRUG LEVEL OKAY SO
THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST TIME WE
WOULD EVER APPLY THAT TO A DRUG
CORRECT.
AND THE CASE OF YOUR INFORMED
CONSENT IT'S A REQUIREMENT THAT
WASN'T PUT ON YOU BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE WAS PUT ON BY YOUR
BOARD WITH YOUR PEERS SAYING
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO DO
IS REQUIREMENTS CORRECT.
OKAY VERY GOOD OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
WELL THE FUTURE IF I COULD IDEA.
YOU KNOW I WAS STRUGGLING WITH
THIS BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'VE I
ACTUALLY GO TO A CHIROPRACTOR IN
SACRAMENTO -- THAT DOES THAT IS
JOB RELIEVES THE PAIN AND I
CHOSE THAT OF COURSE BECAUSE I
DID NOT WANT THE GOING THE OTHER
DIRECTION -- TAKING THE THE
CHANCE OF NOT.
BY I'D LOOK FOR A SOLUTION AND I
THOUGHT I COULD FIND A SOLUTION
THERE RATHER THAN THAN GOING IN
A DIFFERENT DIRECTION BUT I I IS
A LOOK AT THE BILL AND THAT IS A
LOOK AT THE THE REQUIREMENTS.
THAT ARE NECESSARY -- SEEM TO GO
TOO FAR AND I THINK SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS REALLY GOING TO BRING
IT INTO SOMETHING I THINK PEOPLE
SHOULD BE -- SHOULD KNOW OF
ALTERNATIVES THEY SHOULD BE
AWARE OF ALTERNATIVES BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S THAT THE
PLACE FOR THAT DOCTOR. TO TO GO
THAT FAR WITH REFERRALS WITH THE
THE CONSENT NECESSARY.
TO THAT WE WILL MAKE OUR MEDICAL
CHOICES -- IN THE MANNER IN
WHICH WE WE DO BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IN CERTAIN APPROACHES TO
THAT -- I THINK CERTAINLY
ALLOWING AND AND EDUCATING THE
THE PATIENT IS IMPORTANT -- AND
THE PATIENT SHOULD BE AWARE OF
IT BUT I DON'T I I JUST THINK
THIS IS MORE OF A OF A BURDEN
RATHER THAN.
THE SOLVING OF A PARTICULAR
PROBLEM THAT THAT MAYBE THAT WE
ALL BELIEVE IN -- EXIST TODAY SO --
THAT'S THE CONCERN I HAVE I JUST
THINK IT'S JUST TAKES A LITTLE
BEYOND WHERE I'M COMFORTABLE
GOING.
THANK YOU SENATOR HIM.
LET ME HEAR.
JUST ALONG PLEASE -- LET LET ME
SAY -- TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
AYE AYE APPROVED MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP -- AND AND YOUR
CONCERN IN THIS AREA OF OPIOIDS
IT'S A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM.
AND I THINK THAT -- YOU HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN TRYING TO
CREATE A MUCH BETTER
CIRCUMSTANCE AWARENESS -- ON
SOMETHING THAT REALLY IS A BIG
PROBLEM AND I THINK THAT WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IN THIS BILL.
IN TERMS OF EXPANDING THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR PRESCRIBERS TO
DISCUSS THE RISKS AND DANGERS --
TO ALL PATIENTS WE DID THAT FOR
MINORS.
YEAH YOUR EFFORT YOUR GOAL IN
THIS BILL TO EXTEND THAT TO ALL
PATIENTS IS SOMETHING THAT I
HEARTILY AGREE WITH.
AND I THINK IT'S IT'S WHAT MAKES
THAT PART OF THE BILL SUCH AN
IMPORTANT THING I THINK FOR US
TO ADVANCE THIS YEAR -- I ALSO
THINK THAT -- IN ENCOURAGING --
PRESCRIBERS TO TO TALK ABOUT NON
PHARMACY AT PHARMACOLOGICAL
ALWAYS HAVE TROUBLE WITH THAT
WERE TREATMENTS.
IS ALSO A VERY HEALTHY THING TO
DO -- BECAUSE THERE ARE
DIFFERENT WAYS TO TO DEAL WITH
PAIN SENATOR HILL WAS TALKING
ABOUT HIS CHIROPRACTOR I ALSO GO
TO A CHIROPRACTOR.
AND I FIND THAT TREATMENT TO
HAVE BEEN VERY VERY EFFECTIVE
FOR ME BUT THERE'S LOTS OF OTHER --
TREATMENTS THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT THAT THAT MAY BE MORE
APPLICABLE TO THE DISCOMFORT OR
PAIN THAT THAT PERSON IS
EXPERIENCING.
AND SO I ALSO FIND THAT PART OF
YOUR BILL TO BE VERY POSITIVE
AND VERY ENCOURAGING.
WHERE I DIFFER I THINK FROM THE
DIRECTION THE BILL?
IS A IS IN THESE AREAS A LOT OF
INFORMED CONSENTS NOT SOMETHING
WE'VE EVER REQUIRED -- FOR A
PRESCRIPTION THAT I'M AWARE OF
AND I ALSO THINK THAT BEING SO
SPECIFIC ABOUT THE ALTERNATIVES.
I THINK GOES FARTHER THAN I
THINK -- THAT WE SHOULD BECAUSE
I THINK WE SHOULD BE RELYING
UPON THE JUDGMENTS OF OUR
POSITIONS.
THOSE WHO ARE PROVIDING THE
TREATMENT TO TO BE THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT HOW AND WHAT THEY THEY
TALK ABOUT THAT.
AND I THINK THAT WE'VE GOT BEAT
BY BEING MORE SPECIFIC I THINK
IT TAKES AWAY FROM -- AT A
TAKING DVANTAGE OF THE
PROFESSIONALISM THAT WE EXPECT
FROM THOSE.
FOLKS WHO ARE DOING THAT
EXAMINATION.
SO HERE YOU HAVE A CASE OF THE
YOUR BILL -- ADVANCING SO VERY
MERITORIOUS ALIMENTS THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE ENACTED.
BUT I THINK IT DOES GO A LITTLE
FURTHER THAN I THINK IT IT
SHOULD IN THESE OTHER AREAS.
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERN ON THE
ISSUE OF REFERRALS.
HOWEVER -- MY THOUGHT THERE WAS
THAT -- IF THIS BILL DOES MOVE
FOR THE THIRD BE AN OPPORTUNITY
IN THE HEALTH COMMITTEE -- TO TO
KIND OF TALK ABOUT THAT ISSUE
AND TRY TO SEE IF YOU CAN FIND.
BETTER COMMON GROUND BUT
UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT PREPARED
TO MOVE THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORM WITHOUT THOSE TWO SUGGESTED
A MAN SO.
WHEN TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU AND
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
ANY ANY CLOSING COMMENTS YOU
WANT TO MAKE?
YES SEVEN I THINK WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS ALREADY WITH
RESPECT TO SOME OF THESE ISSUES
I THINK YOU OUTLINED IT QUITE
WELL THAT FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENT -- AS AS I
PRESENTED THIS BILL WITH RESPECT
TO THE VARIOUS.
OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE BUT
NOT LIMITED TO SO WHEN WE'RE
HAVING CONVERSATION ABOUT
NARROWING.
IT'S NOT LIMITED TO SOME OF
THESE.
KIND OF TYPE OF TREATMENTS I
THINK THAT'S ACTUALLY THE INTENT
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
BECAUSE WE WANT TO TACKLE THIS
IN A VERY COURAGEOUS FASHION AND
EVEN IF IT'S NOT DONE BEEN DONE
BEFORE.
BECAUSE STATUS QUO IS NOT
WORKING AND SO I SHARE THAT
COMMITMENT THAT YOU HAVE ALSO IN
TACKLING THIS OPIOID CRISIS --
AND HOPE THAT -- YOU SHOULD THIS
BILL NOT MOVE FOR THAT WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER COLLABORATIVELY ON
THESE VARIOUS ISSUES BUT I JUST
THINK.
WE NEED SOME TEETH TO THIS AND
TO ALLOW FOR MANY OF THESE
DIFFERENT MODALITIES TO CONTINUE
TO BE.
UTILIZED AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND
TACKLING THIS ISSUE SO.
THANK YOU AND I'LL TAKE THAT AS
YOUR CLOTHES AND AGAIN I'D I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND AND CONCERN IN A VERY
IMPORTANT AREA -- AND I HAD I
KNOW IT'S SOMETHING WHETHER
WE'RE GONNA WORK ON THIS OR
SOMETHING FURTHER IN THIS AREA I
LOOK FOR TO WORKING ON IT
TOGETHER WITH YOU.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL THAT'S THAT
COMPLETES OUR TESTIMONY MEMBERS
IS THERE A MOTION ON THIS ISSUE.
ALRIGHT SO WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THE BILL FOR NOW AND AGAIN OUR
THANKS FOR BRINGING THE ISSUE
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE BILL -- NEXT WELL IF IT'S
OKAY WITH YOU WITH START AT THE
TOP ITEM ONE AB.
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT FIVE TWENTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER AT
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- I WANT TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS REGARDING
THE ROOM MOVING UP PROVISIONS
REGARDING WORKERS COMPENSATION
AT THIS BILL HELPS TO ENSURE
THAT THE REPORTING.
IS FROM SEVENTY TWO ONE WORKING
DAY TO WHICH WE KNOW THAT
ALREADY IS IN EXISTENCE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
MAKING ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION I'M AB IN SUPPORT AB
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT CONTAINS
CRITICAL FIXES TO THE MANDATORY
CHECK REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
POSITIONS OF THE CARE SYSTEM.
HE FIXES ENSURE THE POSITIONS A
PULL AVOID DUPLICATE OF WORK
ALLOW FOR DELEGATES ACTUALLY
PULL PATIENT RECORDS OR VIEW IT.
YOU'RE THE VIEW THE CURES REPORT
WHEN IT APPEARS IN FRONT OF THEM
IN AN INTEGRATED EHR SYSTEM.
AND REMOVES OWNERS
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS THAT
DON'T SRVE TO PROTECT PATIENTS
BUT I'D TIME TO APPOINTMENTS AND
OVERALL COST THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH PROTECT ACCESS
SECURES AND PREVENT INSURANCE
COMPANIES FROM UTILIZING THIS
PROVIDER DATE ASSEMBLY TO DENY
PATIENT CLAIMS.
I THINK THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE ASK FOR SUPPORT ON AB.
FIVE TWENTY WEST GERMAN MEMBERS
JOHN NOR WOULD I BE ALPHA ZENITH
INSURANCE COMPANY -- I JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND I WANT TO POINT OUT
BECAUSE I THINK.
THE ANALYSIS AND I CURRENTLY --
INDICATES A REASON WHY YOU WOULD
I HAVE WORKERS COMPENSATION SURE
IS INVOLVED IN THIS.
EMPLOYER.
AND THUS THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURER IS
RESPONSIBLE NOT ONLY FOR THE
INJURY THE WORKERS COMP INJURY
BUT ALSO FOR FOR THE EFFECTS OF
THE INJURY THAT MEANS ANY WITH
THE PROVISION OF MEDICAL CARE HE
TYPES OF ADDICTIONS.
AN ACCIDENT ON THE WAY HE YOU
KNOW TO A MEDICAL CARE ARE BACK
SO THAT.
THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
INSURANCE IS INDUSTRY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL THAT THE
YOUTH EMPLOYEES DOCTORS AND
NURSES THAT WORK COLLABORATIVELY.
WITH THE TREATING PHYSICIANS ON
EACH CASE AND THEY HAVE BEEN TEN
YEARS AGO AHEAD ON THE OPIOID
ADDICTION.
ISSUE BECAUSE THE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PAYING TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CASE TO GET
PEOPLE OFF OF ALL RIGHTS SO WE
THINK THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ADDITION. TO THIS BILL AND WITH
SUPPORT FOR THOSE REASONS THANK
YOU OKAY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BUT MADE VERY CLEAR HE'S TAKEN
AN AMENDMENT THAT ELIMINATES
THAT I KNOW YOU'RE NOT HAPPY
WITH THAT ARE THAT I'M SO I'M SO
I'M.
SORRY.
OKAY ALL OF THAT CASE WILL SAVE
THAT FOR ANOTHER BILL IN ANOTHER
DIRECTION THE EDUCATION IS
ALWAYS VALUABLE SPECIALLY.
FOR SUCH EXPERTISE THANK YOU.
OUR OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR
RENTS SPENCER BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AS WELL AS CHEN I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR SUPPORT AND
BILL AND ASK YOUR SUPPORT THANK.
THANK YOU.
ALLEN COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO AND SUPPORT.
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
DEMAND REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT.
SURE RIVAS WITH CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CRISTINA TO CARL
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU TO MS MASON MISTER LOW
OF COURSE AND MISTER SUMNER FOR
THE AMENDMENTS PERTAINING TO THE
VETERINARIANS VERY HELPFUL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANSWER GRAND WITH BOARD OF
PHARMACY WE APPRECIATE
COMMITTEES MOMENTS IN SPORTS
MEASURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DOES HE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE CANNOT THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WITH MANY AMENDMENTS
WE ARE MOVING BACK OR OPPOSE
MUST AMENDED TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SO MOST OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THE WAR WAS
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THIS BILL.
OVERBOARD STUFF DOES HAVE SOME
TECHNICAL CONCERNS WITH THE
AMENDMENTS BUT THE BOARD LOOKS
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH AUTHORS
OFFICE AND STAKEHOLDERS
ASSESSMENT BILL MOVES TO THE
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND NOT IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BACK A CREAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA HERE
IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION I APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENT THAT WAS TAKEN CAN
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING THAT.
REMOVES SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
OTHER WE NOTE THAT IT STILL
LEAVES A ROLLING BACK OF THE
REGULATION DEADLINE BY ONE YEAR
EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE NO LONGER
ANY SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES TO WHAT
NEED TO BE IN THE REGULATIONS.
AND WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
PUSHING BACK THE REGULATIONS
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT ADDING NEW PRESCRIPTIONS
TO THE KERRS AT BASS.
AND EXTENDING THE WHAT I WAS
CAPTURED IN IT WHILE THE CARES
EITHER BASE REMAINS -- WITHOUT
CRUCIAL PRIVACY PROTECTIONS I
THINK IF YOU ASK ANY CALIFORNIAN
ON THE STREET IF THEIR
PRESCRIPTION RECORDS ARE ANY
DIFFERENT THAN ANY OF THEIR
OTHER MEDICAL RECORDS.
THEY WOULD ASSUME THAT THEY ARE
THE SAME AND TREATED WITH THE
SAME LEVEL OF PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS HOWEVER THEY ARE NOT.
AND THE CARES ADDED BASS IS
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC IN THAT
IT IS I'M NOT ONLY SHARING THESE --
PRIVATE AND RECORDS WITH -- I'M
A BACK UP AND FORGET THAT THIS
IS PROBLEMATIC THAT OUR PRIVACY
OUR PRIVATE RECORDS ARE NOT
PROTECTED UNDER CURRENT THAT THE
DOJ GUIDELINES.
SOMEONE IF THEY ARE LOOKING FOR
A PARTICULAR INDIVIDUALS RECORDS
LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY NEED A
WARRANT BUT IF THEY'RE GOING TO
GET ALL THE RECORDS OF ALL OF
THE DOCTORS PATIENTS THEY
INCLUDE THESE PRIVATE.
THE PATIENT INFORMATION ALONG
WITH THE PRESCRIPTION THE DOCTOR --
PROVIDED THEY DO NOT NEED A
WARRANT WHICH SEEMS A LITTLE ODD
FIT FOR ONE PERSON'S RECORDS YOU
GET.
A WARRANT BUT TO GET A VAST
NUMBER OF PATIENT RECORDS
THROUGH THE DOCTOR REPORT YOU DO
NOT NEED A WARRANT AND SO WE ASK
THAT UNTIL.
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE FOR CARE IS
THAT WE DO NOT EXTEND IT TO TO
SCHEDULE FIVE DRUGS.
PARTICULARLY AS THE AUTHOR
STATEMENT AS LISTED IN THE BILL
ANALYSIS STATES THAT THE REASON
FOR ADDING AND THESE SCHEDULE
FIVE DRUGS IS BECAUSE OF THE
PROBLEM WITH.
COUGH SYRUP WITH OPIOIDS IN THEM
THAT HAS BEEN.
THAT HAS BALLOONED OUT FOR HER --
BEING COMING POPULARIZED AND THE
POP CULTURE AND SO WE WONDER
ABOUT THE NEED.
TO EXPOSE.
OTHER PATIENTS NON OPIOID
SCHEDULE FIVE DRUGS TO REDUCE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS IN ORDER TO
FIGHT SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
COMING FAST A FAIRLY FROM FIRST
RESULTING FROM PRESCRIPTIONS BUT
FROM POP CULTURE.
AND SO WITH RESPECTFULLY REMAIN
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD -- OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEN NINE WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CENTER PAN AND SENATOR GALGIANI.
SEVEN FOR FIRST OF ALL -- A
MARYLAND.
NO I I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY -- AND I KNOW THAT -- YOUR
EFFORTS HERE IS TO TRY TO YOU
KNOW APPROVED SECURES DATABASE I
DO SHARE SOME THE CONCERNS OF
THE ACLU -- IN REGARDS TO
PRIVACY ISSUES THIS.
IS A DATABASE THAT'S IN THE DOJ
SO IT'S NOT NOT HEALTHCARE
ENTITY SO IT'S AS I THINK WE
NEED TO CLARIFY THE THE THE
NATURE OF OUR OUR YOU KNOW BUT
OUR STATE FEDERAL PRIVACY LAWS
HOW TO PLACE TO THIS AND I ALSO
REMIND -- IN A DO YOU KNOW THIS
BUT JUSTREMIND YOU FOR
LISTENING TO THIS IS IS THAT --
OFTENTIMES WE TALK ABOUT
PICTURES AND AND CONTROLS OF
THIS IS ABOUT THE X. OPIOIDS BUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF MEDICATIONS
ARE NOT OPIOIDS.
THAT ARE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
ALL RIGHT.
AND SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOW I
I DON'T THINK YOU LIKE KIDS WITH
ADHD.
THOSE -- STIMULANTS ARE.
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES REASON A
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE BECAUSE
THEY DO HAVE SOME OF AN
ADDICTION POTENTIAL RIGHT AND SO
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE.
OTHER MEDICATIONS THAT ARE --
ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT SCHEDULE --
FIVE THERE ARE LARGE NUMBERS TO
HAVE CODEINE -- THAT'S THE MAIN
SUBSTANCE THAT'S IN THERE BUT
ACTUALLY THERE ARE OTHER
MEDICATIONS THEIR SCHEDULE FIVE
HAD OR NOT THERE ARE NONE OF
MORE -- TOO LATE OKAY -- SO
THOSE ARE IN THERE AND CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW -- RECOGNIZE -- YOU
KNOW WHY YOU WANT TO INCLUDE NAY
UNDERSTANDABLY A LOT OF SUPPORT
IN THE HEALTH COMMITTEE BUT I I
I I THINK THAT -- WE REALLY DO
AND I'M LIKE I ASKED YEAH I'M
NOT SUGGESTING ANY FURTHER
MINUTES FROM THE COMMITTEE AND
SO FORTH I THINK WE DO NEED TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT THIS IS HEALTH
INFORMATION AND YOU CAN FIND OUT
NOT ONLY ABOUT THEIR PAIN
MEDICATION Và LOT OF OTHER
THINGS.
ABOUT PEOPLE VERY SENSITIVE
THINGS I THINKSOME OF THE
STEROIDS -- ARE SO THE PEOPLE
ARE -- ARE ARE ALSO CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES TO SELL -- AND THEN
WE STARTING ABOUT -- S WE START
THE OUT WHAT KIND OF INFORMATION
CAN CAN BE REVEALED AND AND AND
SO FORTH SO -- I APPRECIATE THE
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTING
AMENDMENTS THAT REALLY THE
SHOULD IT JUST FIRST OF ALL
SHOULD ONLY BE USED FOR
ENFORCEMENT AND SHOULD NOT BE A
DATABASE.
FOR PEOPLE TO MIND FOR YOU KNOW
MARKETING -- FOR INSURANCE OR
THINGS LIKE THAT AND THEN ALSO
IT -- I THINK AS THE MATCH BY
ACLU WE NEED TO BE SURE WE HAVE
SOME GOOD BOUNDARIES AROUND.
AROUND THIS AGAIN WILE STILL
HAVING SERVICE FUNCTION TO BE
SURE THAT WE LIMIT YELP USE OF
OPIOIDS SELL -- I'M YOU KNOW I'M
LESS DEPRECIATE YOUR A FOR ONE
OF THEM'S L. SUPPORT THE BILL AS
IT AS AMENDED BY THE COMMITTEE --
BUT I HOPE WE KEEP IN MIND AS WE
THINK MORE ABOUT ACTORS DATABASE
BILLS ABOUT THESE PRIVACY ISSUES
AND REALLY THINK ABOUT -- WE'LL
WHAT KIND OF PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
WERE PUTTING AROUND REALLY AT
HEALTH DATABASE OF OF OF
PARTICULAR SET OF PRESCRIPTIONS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU.
THE CENTER PAN SENATOR GALGIANI --
SO I SEE HERE ON PAGE SIX OF THE
ANALYSIS THAT THE SCHEDULE FIVE
DRUGS ARE GENERALLY USE FOR ANTI
ANALGESIC PURPOSES.
AND I TYRONE REALLY.
IS IS THAT A MISTAKE OR IS THAT
WOULD.
THAT WOULD ALL OF A SUDDEN BE ON
SCHEDULE.
FIVE CAN SOMEBODY WHO KNOWS MORE
ABOUT THAT I I SEE IT OVER THE
THAT.
GOOD TO ME SORRY.
LET ME ASK OUR COMMITTEE
CANCELED OUT TO ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTION THERE ARE SOME DRUGS
AND THAT.
THAT WOULD TREAT THOSE
CONDITIONS THAT OUR SCHEDULE
FIVE THAT WOULD BE REPORTED IN
THE CARE SYSTEM UNDER THE SPELL.
AND THAT'S PRESCRIPTION OR IS
THAT THE OVER THE COUNTER THAT.
THESE ARE PRESCRIPTION.
ALL SCHEDULES -- TWO THREE FIVE
OUR PRESCRIPTION ALTHOUGH THERE
ARE SOME THAT LOOK SIMILAR LIKE
A COUGH SYRUP WITH CODEINE.
WOULD BE A SCHEDULE FIVE DRUGS
WERE AS A COUGH SYRUP THAT IS
OVER THE COUNTER IS NOT A
SCHEDULED DRUG [inaudible]
YOU.
SHARE.
WELL I THINK IT GOES BACK TO THE
POINT OF SAYING IS IS THAT --
WELL WE'RE NOT ALL.
CONTROL CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES OR
SOMETHING THAT POTENTIAL -- AS A
POTENTIAL FOR ADDICTION SO
OBVIOUSLY SCHEDULE VICE VERY LOW
AND SO THE MAIN OPIOID UNDERS
CODING SO BY LIKE CODEINE HELP
SUPPRESS COUGH THAT'S ANTI
TOSSES -- BUT YOU ALSO HAVE SOME
OTHER TYPES OF MEDICATION
THEY'RE ALSO SCHEDULE FIVE AS
WELL -- BECAUSE THEY HAVE AGAIN
VERY LOW POTENTIAL I I
PERSONALLY AND I'M NOT OBJECTING
TO INCLUDING SCHEDULE FIVE BUT I
THINK THE CONCERN I HAVE IS IS
THAT.
IS THAT REMIND PEOPLE THERE'S A
LOT OF DRUGS THAT ARE
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE ND
SCHEDULES OF TWO THROUGH FIVE
OKAY SO WE HAVE TO THROUGH AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE A FURTHER CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE PRIVACY ISSUES BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT.
IN THE WILL IS WHAT ONE COULD
ARGUE THESE IN PRICE AROUND
OPIOIDS BUT WE SHOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHER MEDICATIONS THAT ARE ON
SCHEDULE TWO THROUGH.
FIVE THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH PAIN OR OPIOIDS AND THOSE
ARE ALL BEING THAT AS A
PHYSICIAN THOSE ARE ALL BEING
RIGHT STERN CHURCH NOW I CAN
ALSO SEE FROM SIMPLICITY
STANDPOINT.
I KNOW THE SCHEDULE FIVE
THEREFORE I HAVE TO REGISTER AND
YELL IT MAKES IT EASIER.
FOR THE PEOPLE HAVE TO DO THE
DATABASE AND ABOUT TO ENTER
STUFF IN THE DATABASE TO BECAUSE
IT'S VERY CLEAR DEMARCATION I
YOU KNOW LIKE.
VERSUS SAYING JUST ALL THE ONES
WITH CODEINE -- BUT SO I CAN SEE
FROM A THAT MYSTERY SIMPLICITY
STANDPOINT WAY WE JUST A
SCHEDULE FIVE AND BUT THE FDA
FIGURED OUT BUT I I WOULD ARGUE
THAT THAT AGAIN REINFORCES THE
NEED FOR A GREAT YOU KNOW FOR BE
SURE YOU DRESS THE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS -- BUT YES THERE ARE
MEDICATIONS ARE THERE TO HAVE NO
OPIATES AT ALL OR SCHEDULE FIVE
THAT ARE FOR THINGS LIKE YEAH
THAT WOULD HELP REDUCE DIARRHEA.
ALL RIGHT CENTER GALGIANI GOOD
WITH THAT WHAT YOU'VE HEARD OF
THE SAYS RELATES TO THIS BILL
BEFORE US OKAY CENTER ARE CHILE
YES -- I I'M I'M LOOKING AT THIS
THAT THIRD PARTY ACCESS BUT
YOU'VE ALREADY GOT THIS LAST
MINUTE -- AMENDMENTS AND
AGREEMENTS JUST -- THAT IS GOING
TO BE TAKEN CARE OF THE THE
WORKMAN'S COMP ISSUE YEAH THAT'S
CORRECT HE'S ACCEPTED US AS HE
SAID IT DOES IS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS OR IT'S A EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT HERE -- HE'S
BEEN AND I THINK SEVEN EIGHT ONE
AND I BY THINK IT'S GOOD FOR THE
AMENDMENT THANK YOU OKAY ALL
RIGHT WITH THAT -- LET ME --
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE BUT BEFORE I DO THAT -- ON
PAGE THIRTEEN OF THE ANALYSIS
THAT ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE OF THE
RATIONALE FOR AUTHORIZING
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS WHO.
DO NOT HOLD.
A D. A REGISTRATION TO HAVE
ACCESS TO CURES AND I THINK WHAT
THE ANALYSIS DOES IT ASK YOU TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH.
INTERESTED PARTIES.
TO THE LOOK AT THE IMPACTS
DESCENDING FROM THAT CHANGE IN
THE RATIONALE FOR THAT I WOULD
ASK.
THAT YOU CONSIDER THAT AS A AS
YOU GO FORWARD SO WITH THAT
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE YES AS
SIMILARLY AT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF CERTAINLY WILL WILL DO SO
THESE ARE FEDERALLY CONTROLLED.
SUBSTANCES AND OUT WORKING WITH
THE VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS
UNDERSTANDING OF THE RISKY
NATURE OF SUCH SUBSTANCES IS THE
INTENT OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH AND SO WILL CONTINUE
TO CERTAINLY WORK WITH.
STAKEHOLDERS IN FORT.
AND ELSE YOU WANT TO SAY OR THAT
YOUR CLOTHES YES VERY GOOD OKAY.
I WITH THAT -- MEMBERS THAT --
IS THERE A MOTION.
ALL RIGHT THE THE MOTION IS THAT
DO PASS AS A AS AMENDED.
I WOMEN IN HERE.
OKAY -- TO TO THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE AND WITHTHAT THAT
THIS SECTOR WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
GLAZER HI.
GLAZER AYE CHAIN. TO LETTER ARE
TO LET AYE DODD.
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI I'D KILL [inaudible]
LEYVA.
AND HI CAN I WILK.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THAT LOOKS LIKE IT HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE ONE FINAL
BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S ITEM
NUMBER TWO WHEN OUR AGENDA.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTEEN AND
YOU WELCOME TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AB IS SIX THIRTEEN HELPS
TO ENSURE THE TYPE OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHOUT THE FLUCTUATION.
OF THE ECONOMY AT TO TIE THESE
INCREASES ARE TO OUR CPI AND
STILL PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US IN THE LEGISLATURE. TO
APPROVE AND A ROLL BACK OF THOSE
INCREASES WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S SOME SENSE OF
STABILITY -- WITH THESE
INCREASES A POTENTIAL INCREASES
AGAIN WITH THE TYPE OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE TRANSPARENCY
HAVE THE FROM THE LEGISLATURE SO --
WITH RESPECT AS RIVAL IN HAVE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TESTING YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
MERRY MAKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WITH MANY
AMENDMENTS WE ARE SWITCHING FROM
SUPPORT OF AMENDED TO FULL
SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL EIGHTY SIX THIRTEEN
PROVIDE STABILITY FOR BOTH --
REGULATORY LICENSING BOARDS AND
THEIR LICENSEES OFTENTIMES WE
SEE -- DUE TO THE DC A
REGULATORY PROCESS WHICH IS A
SIX THIRTEEN STEP REVIEW PROCESS.
THAT THE REGULATION PACKAGES TO
INCREASE FEES CAN TAKE UPWARDS
OF A YEAR -- AND WITH THIS WE
CAN EXPECT SOME STABILITY FOR
BOTH THE BUDGETS AND FOR
EXPECTATIONS FOR WHAT THOSE
LICENSING FEES WILL BE -- WITH A
THAT CPI -- IN THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
BEFORE YOU WITH THE NEXT WITNESS
I I WANT TO JUST CLARIFY BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK YOU SEE ACCEPTED
THE COULD THE AMENDMENT TO
SUGGESTED SO LET'S JUST CLARIFY
THAT.
WOULD GLADLY ACCEPTED YOU OKAY
SO THEN YOUR TESTIMONY IS ON
POINT VERY GOOD NEXT NEXT
WITNESS I'M JENNIFER SOMOS WITH
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.%
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE A TOOL
FOR THE BOARD TO USE IN THE
FUTURE TO PREVENT SIGNIFICANT
FEE INCREASES FOR LICENSEES AND
ALLOW THE BOARDS FUND TO STAY
SOLVENT.
OVER THIS BILL DOES NOT PREVENT
THE BOARD FROM PURSUING A LARGER
FEE INCREASED THEIR STATURE OF
NEEDED AND FOR THESE REASONS OF
OR SUPPORTS THIS BILL IN YOUR
CIRCULAR QUESTION ABOUT.
WHAT OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR
PLEASE COME TO THE MIKE?
MORE IS THERE TO GO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT I'M SORRY I DIDN'T SEE
THERE THANK YOU.
AARON BUT WITH THE BOARD OF
ACCOUNTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ROSEANNE HOUSE OF THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AND SUPPORT.
FRAN BURDEN CALIFORNIA DENTAL
BOARD IN SUPPORT.
HI FRAN THE MAILING REPRESENTING
THE CHIROPRACTIC PART IN SUPPORT.
MARK JOHNSON CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
OF A COUNTRY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND SENATOR WITH THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY IN SUPPORT.
MY TIMOTHY CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD THE BOARD IS
ACTUALLY SUPPORT IF AMENDED
THERE WAS A CONCERN THAT THAT
BILL AS WRITTEN WOULD ABROGATE
EXISTING AUTHORITY TO RAISE --
FEES FOR ANY REASON OTHER THAN
THE CPI HOWEVER I BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN AND THE REGISTRAR'S
BEEN GREAT I THOUGHT HE TO
UPGRADE TO FULL SUPPORT IF THE
AMENDMENTSMADE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MAKING ALREADY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION -- IN OPPOSITION TO
AB SIX ONE THREE SB SIX THIRTEEN
REMOVES LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL FOR
FEE INCREASES LEVIED ON
LICENSEES BY THEIR RESPECTIVE
LICENSING BOARD.
ALLOWS FOR AUTOMATIC FEE
INCREASES EVERY FOUR YEARS WHILE
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
AUTHORS OFFER TO THE BILL
THERE'S ONLY STILL A MECHANISM
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO REVIEW
THESE BE INCREASES AFTER THEY
HAVE ALREADY OCCURRED AT EACH
BOARD SUNSET REVIEW.
EXISTING LAW ALREADY ALLOWS FOR
BOARDS TO SEE FEE INCREASES
THEIR REGULATORY AND LEGISLATIVE
PROCESSES AND ALSO.
AND TO ALSO SEE FEE INCREASES
THROUGH THE BOARD SENSE THAT
REVIEW PROCESS EXISTING LAW
PLACES NO LIMITS ON HOW OFTEN
ABOARD CAN REQUEST A FEE
INCREASE.
OVER RECOGNIZE THAT COSTS CAN
INCREASE DUE TO INFLATION AND
UNDERSTAND THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
TO PROVIDE A PROCESS TO
GRADUALLY INCREASE FEES TO
REFLECT INFLATION.
WE HAVE CONCERNS REGARDING THE
BILL'S LACK OF PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY FOR LICENSEES TO
PROVIDE INPUT REGARDING WHETHER
FEE INCREASES ARE APPROPRIATE.
AND THE ABSENCE OF SAFEGUARDS TO
ENSURE THAT DEPARTMENTS DO NOT
REQUEST MULTIPLE FEE INCREASES
THEIR DIFFERENT PROCESS THESE.
THIS BILL DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
CEILINGS CURRENTLY IN PLACE FOR
CERTAIN BOARDS NORMALLY
GUARANTEED THAT LARGE FEE
INCREASES WILL BE NEEDED IN
ADDITION TO THE C. P. I.
INCREASES WHEN ADDITIONAL COSTS
ARE BORNE BY THE BOARDS. FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WE HAVE ASKED THE
OPPOSE AB SIX THIRTEEN AND LEAVE
THE CURRENT AND FUNCTIONAL
PROCESS INTACT RETAINING YOUR
AUTHORITY OVER LICENSING FEE
INCREASES.
VERY GOOD OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION RIGHT SPENT RIGHT
SPENCER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
OPPOSITION GREAT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SIGNAL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS DISCUSSION.
SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU AND SUMMER LOW IT YOU
KNOW.
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE TRYING TO
DRESS A PARTICULAR PROBLEM
PRECIADO COMMITTEES WORKED ON IT
BUT AND THAT DOES SOMEONE WHO --
SO FULL DISCLOSURE I AM A FEE
PAYING LICENSEE.
AND SO IS MY WIFE SO -- BUT I
THINK -- YOU KNOW MY LEGISLATOR
HAD I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
EXERCISE MORE NOW -- OVER
OVERSIGHT AND SELL FORTY I'M
UNABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL --%
TODAY BUT APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS THANK YOU.
GOOD SENATOR HILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN IN THANK YOU
CARILLO FOR YOU KNOW YOU LISTEN
TO THE BOARDS YOU PAY ATTENTION
TO WHAT THEY SAY THAT AND I KNOW
YOU YOU.
YOU YOU WANTED.
YEAH MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
GETTING THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO DO THEIR JOB AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS --
AND I GUESS WHAT THE STRUGGLE
THAT I'M HAVING IS TAKING AWAY
THE LEGISLATORS LEGISLATURE'S
ROLE IN THAT THE WORDING AND SET
IN THOSE FEES.
AND AND IT'S IT'S ALMOST GIVING
THE BOARD OF BLANK CHECK IN
FRANKLY FROM WHAT I'VE.
EXPERIENCED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS WHEN I WAS
CHAIR OF THIS.
WONDERFUL COMMITTEE.
I DON'T KNOW IF I WOULD WANT TO
DO THAT IN GIVEN THE BLANK CHECK
AND THAT'S THE STRUGGLE THAT I
HAVE.
TODAY WITH THE LEGISLATION
BECAUSE IT JUST LIMITED IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S AUTHORITY THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE SUNSET REVIEW THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO LOOK
AT THE DIFFERENT PORTS.
DID TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING AND HAVE THEY
PERFORMED APPROPRIATELY HAVE THE
USE THOSE RESOURCES.
IN THE RIGHT MANNER TO PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY STE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT WE ALL ARE
LOOKING FOR SO I CAN LIKETHE
STATUS QUO AND AND ALL THE HAVE
TO OPPOSE THE BILL TODAY SORRY.
I AND AT ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
WILL OF THE MEDIA.
LET ME SAY THAT -- I APPRECIATE
AND UNDERSTAND FULLY THE
COMMENTS FROM MY TWO COLLEAGUES
ON THE PANEL HERE TODAY -- BUT I
THINK YOU WERE TRYING TO SPEAK
TO STRIKE A BALANCE HERE.
AND WELL I I AS A LEGISLATOR WE
LOVE OVERSIGHT AND WE LOVE THE
ABILITY TO SAY YES FOR NOW.
I THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO BE VERY
PRAGMATIC ABOUT IT IN THE BILL
THAT YOU PUT FOR FORWARD TO US.
I ALSO KNOW -- THAT -- ANY BOARD --
AT THAT IS PAYING ATTENTION --
THAT BEFORE THEY WERE TO DO
ANYTHING OUT OF THE ORDINARY IN
TERMS OF THE COST OF LIVING
INCREASE WHICH IS ALL THAT THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW.
I WOULD PROBABLY DO THEIR
HOMEWORK AND CHECK IN WITH THE
LEGISLATURE NO ONE LIKES TO BE
REVERSED.
AND THE FACT THAT SET UP THE
MOST YOU COULD GET.
OUT OF THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE US
IS -- THREE YEARS MAYBE OF A FEE --
I THINK -- WOULD BE AN
INDICATION THAT.
THIS IS NOT RUN AWAY AUTHORITY
FROM THIS PERSON'S POINT OF VIEW --
BUT I APPRECIATE THAT THE LEARN
A JUDGMENT OF MY COLLEAGUES --
WHO HAVE SPOKEN -- AND
OPPOSITION TO IT BUT FOR ME I
THOUGHT IT STRUCK THE RIGHT
BALANCE.
AND I THINK A GOOD THE
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS COULD BE
PLACED IN IT WITH THE SUNSET
THAT ALLOW IT TO GO INTO EFFECT.
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME AND THEN WE
HAVE A CHANCE TO GO AND RE VISIT
AGAIN.
BUT I GUESS WE CAN WAIT AND SEE
ME MIGHT DISCUSS THAT IN YOUR
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH BUT I
APPRECIATED THE THOUGHTFULNESS
THAT YOU PUT INTO THIS.
TRYING TO STRIKE THAT BALANCE SO
WITH THAT WHEN A BUDGET MAKE ANY
KIND OF CLOSING COMMENTS YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK --
THE THEY'RE STILL OF THE TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
A CENTER FOR AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US IS THE LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY
EVEN ROLL BACK.
THE INCREASES SO WE STILL HAVE
THAT AUTHORITY ASYOU WELL KNOW
AS WELL AND ANY OF THESE
ENTITIES BOARDS CAN PRESENT A
BILL THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE TO
WHICH IT STILL HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY CURRENTLY IN
EXISTENCE. TO INCREASE THEIR
FEES SO WE STILL RETAINED THAT.
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
THE CALENDAR EARLY IN ADDITION
IT'S STILL ALSO NEED TO BE
APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THIRD WE BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
MANY MECHANISMS TO ENSURE THAT
HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND RESEARCHER ALL OF US HERE
WOULD.
BE WELL POSITIONED TO HELP
ENSURE THE THE NECESSITY FOR
THESE INCREASES -- AND ITSELF
SIGNIFICANTLY LIMITED A AND IT'S
OPTIONAL ONLY AND A VOTE A
PUBLIC MEETING BY THE BOARD INTO
WHICH MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC --
CAN PARTICIPATE SO THEY'RE STILL
SIGNIFICANT CHECKS AND BALANCES
THAT ARE PROVIDED -- AND AGAIN
WE STILL RETAIN THAT IS ALREADY
SO -- I BELIEVE SIMILARLY AS
THIS IS CHAIR WITH RESPECT TO
THE TYPE OF ACCOUNTING
TRANSPARENCY NOT JUST LINDEN.
RIGHT RIGHT AWAY WITH IT WITHOUT
HAVING PUBLIC INPUT SO WE STILL
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY -- SO THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD SUGGEST IN TERMS OF THE
COMMENTS -- AND AGAIN WE WANT TO
PROVIDE GREATER CERTAINTY FOR
NOT THESE INCREASES THAT JUST
WOULD HAPPEN -- BUT RATHER AN
OPTION.
WITH THE CPI SO THAT THERE'S A
GREATER SENSE OF CERTAINTY WITH
THAT -- TOO SO THAT BY SEN
SEASONS AND WHY IS IT OF SEND
THE FACT THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE THIS
HASN'T HAPPENED OVER A PERIOD OF
TIME.
SO IT PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THESE ENTITIES BOARDS TO
HELP ENSURE THE TYPE OF
PROJECTIONS THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED.
OUR WALL ALSO LIMITING THE TYPE
OF IMPACT TO LICENSEES AND SO
THAT IS THE INTENT OF THE BILL.
AND WITH RESPECT BASS PRIVATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE A MOTION ON
THIS ISSUE.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT BILL WILL
REMAIN HERE FOR NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SOME
REMEMBER GREAT PRESENTING THANK
YOU FOR IT.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA GO AND LIVE
THE CALLS -- IT IS A GENTLEMAN
ON OUR WONDERFUL WORK TODAY.
LET'S SAY THAT LET'S BEGIN AT
THE TOP MAHOOD SAID FOR ME TO
SEE WHO AS EVERYBODY HERE.
SHE VOTE ON EVERYTHING
[inaudible]
MOST.
OKAY WELL AT BY WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE ABSENT MEMBERS TO
RETURN -- FOR THE SAKE OF THE
THE THE ATTENDANCE OF THOSE WHO
ARE HERE WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH
IT FOR THE TOP AND WE'LL START
WITH THAT GEN ITEM.
ONE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT BY LOW.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL QUESTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO RULES
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTES -- FIVE
TWO ZERO VOTING AYE.
DODD AYE DODD AYE.
HILL.
BILL I'D LEYVA.
THE BILL REMAIN ON CALL FOR NOW.
I WAS SEVEN VOTES.
ITEM.
NUMBER TWO THERE WAS NO MOTIONS --
PRESENTED ON THAT ONE ITEM
NUMBER.
THREE AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. SIX TWO
ZERO CHAIR VOTING I CHIANG.
DODD.
DOT I WILL.
THAT THE DEAL IS AT EIGHT ZERO
ALRIGHT I KNOW -- FOR THERE WAS
NO MOTION MADE SO THAT BILL IS --
TO BE KEPT WE GOT IEM FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY BY
TWO SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS QUESTION IS DO
PASSED THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND SEVEN ZERO CHIANG.
WELL.
OKAY RIGHT THAT BILL WAS AT
EIGHT ZERO GEN ITEM NUMBER SIX
A. B. THIRTEEN FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
ABOUT SEVEN ZERO CHIANG BUILT.
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT.
SEVEN TWO ZERO I HAD MOVES US TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B..
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR SOME OF OUR
QUE HAN.
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL
WRAPS MEMBERS MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE --
BUT SEVEN ZERO CHIANG WELL.
RIGHT THE BILL IS AT SEVEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY FIVE BY MCCARTY.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO PASSES.
THE CURRENT BOTH FOR DESIRO.
CHIANG DODD I DODD I LG YANNI
[inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
WELL.
ALL RIGHT.
BILL WHAT IS A NUMBER THERE.
ARE THAT BILL IS AT FIVE ZERO
ITEM NUMBER NINE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX BY MEDINA
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE -- BUT SEVEN
ZERO CHIANG WELL I WILL BY.
RIGHT THAT BILLS AT EIGHT ZERO
ITEM NUMBER TEN ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN BY BLANCA
RUBIO.
SECRETARY CALL ROLE OF ABSENT
MEMBERS MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BUT
SEVEN ZERO CHIANG GALGIANI.
OUR THAT FILLS OUT -- SEVEN ZERO
ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
CALL THAT REMAINS AND WITH THAT
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY.
AND WILL LIVE.
AND WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
JUST ANOTHER COUPLE MINUTES
. TO
SEVEN OF CURRENT VOTE ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK INTO
SESSION OPEN THE ROLE ONE LAST
TIME.
ITEM ONE NINE A. B. FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE -- BUT
SEVEN ZERO CHIANG LEYVA I LIVE
BY.
RIGHT I THINK IT'S GOOD I THINK
THAT COMPLETES OUR AGENDA FOR OF
OUR MEETING TODAY THANK YOU ALL
AND THE BILL IS OUT.
AND THE MEETING IS ADJOURNED